TO ORDER THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE I EDUCATION
FINANCE TODAY IS OUR OVERVIEW
HEARING ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR OUR HIGHER
ED SEGMENTS OF UCCS YOU IN OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. LET'S TAKE
THEIR OFFERS EXTRA RECORD HERE.
MCCARTY HERE. MEDINA YOUR RIGHT
HERE. BUT OUR HERE. THANK YOU.
AND WE'RE JOINED HERE BY OUR OUR
BUDGET SHARES TODAY- TODAY OF
COURSE IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING- BUT OF COURSE WE ALWAYS
WELCOME OUR BUDGET- COMMITTEE
CHAIR SO TODAY IS TO GET A
PERSPECTIVE ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS RELATE TO THE THREE
SEGMENTS- WE'LL HEAR LATER FROM
OUR COMMUNITY FROM OUR STATE AID
COMMISSIONER FINANCIAL AID-
PIECES WELL SO OF COURSE YOU
KNOW TWO YEARS AGO WE HAD A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION WITH THE
PANDEMIC WE HAD TO MAKE A
DRAMATIC CUTS IN HIGHER ED WE'RE
ABLE TO BOUNCE BACK. SIGNIFICAN
LAST YEAR AND FRANKLY- AS YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT NEVER HIRE A
CHAIR TALKS ABOUT THIS TO THE
BEST BUDGET IN THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
ACCOMPLISHING SOME SOME
SIGNIFICANT ACTIONS- FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN ABOUT TWENTY YEARS
THAT LOOKED AT AND WE ACTUALLY
DID DRAMATICALLY REFORMER CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS EXPANDING ACCESS
WE FUNDED ABOUT HALF OF THE OF
THE BILL THAT WE HAD MISSED
MEDINA AND WITH THAT ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WILL GET GUARANTEED
FINANCIAL AID FOR THE TRANSFER
PROCESS THROUGH THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS SO THAT'S NOT. AN
SIGNIFICANT AND WE WERE ARE
EXPANDING THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
MORE AID TO STUDENTS AND A START
ADDRESSING THE TOTAL COST THE
NON- TUITION COST OF COLLEGE- WE
GREETED SIGNIFICANTLY IN ROLAND
ROMAN ABOUT THE UC AND CSU- WE
ADDRESSED- STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES ONGOING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- BASIC NEEDS CENTERS-
TO FOCUS ON THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
FACING HOUSING INSECURITY AND-
FOOD AND SECURITY AS WELL AS
HELP STUDENTS YEP GET THROUGH
THAT THERE AT THE PANDEMIC WITH
SOME ADDITIONAL AID- WE FOCUSED
ON EXPANDING STUDENT HOUSING-
AND- ALSO AN OUTSTANDING IS TO
BE LOOKING AT- PUT A- PUT
MOTION- TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO
BUILD MORE STUDENT HOUSING. AND
TO ADDRESS. GROWTH THAT ARE UC
AND CSU CAMPUSES WILL LOOKING AT
DOING- THAT MORE- SOME OF THE
HIGH LEVEL FOR THAT I THE HIGH
POINT AYE AYE IN MY PURSE. WAS
FOCUSING ON ENROLLMENT GROWTH-
YOU KNOW WE DID FOCUS ON MAKING
THE UC AND CSU HALL AND FULLY
FUNDING THEIR BUDGET REQUESTS
BUT WE ALWAYS KNOW. BACK HOME
WHEN THE TOP BEACHES WE HEAR
ABOUT. IS ABOUT AMAZING STUDENTS
WHO APPLY TO UC AND CSU AND HAVE
INCREDIBLE GRADES AND GET
SQUEEZED OUT SO LAST YEAR YOU
MADE OUR ONE OF OUR OUR TOP TOP
PRIORITIES. AND WE ALL BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE VOTING ON A NUMBER
OF SIX THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS AT
THE UC LEVEL TO BEGIN.
ENROLLMENT THIS FALL WE ARE
PRETTY CLEAR IN THE LANGUAGE WE
ALL CHEERLEADERS. CELEBRATED IT
AFTERWARDS ALONG WITH OUR
SPEAKER PRO TEM OUR GOVERNOR I
KNOW THERE'S A SNAFU WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM YOU SEE LATER. ABOUT
THAT WORD WE'RE A LITTLE BIT
DISAPPOINTED THAT THERE IS SOME
DISCREPANCY IN THAT NUMBER BUT
WE HOPE TO. AND SETTLE THAT-
THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS- AND THEN FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE ARE ABLE
TO. FOCUS ON FOR FUNDING FOR
THEM TO ALLOW THEM TO GET
ADEQUATE COLA AND- EXPANDING
CAMPUSES THAT DID HAVE GROWTH.
SOME OF COURSE ARE HAVING SOME
DECLINING ENROLLMENT ISSUES
RELATED TO THE TO THE PANDEMIC
SO A LOT TO BE. EXCITED ABOUT WE
HAD SOME- PROPOSALS THIS YEAR WE
WANT TO FLUSH OUT AS WELL- AND
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO HEAR.
FROM PERMANENT FINANCE L. A. L.
OUR FIRST ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AND THEN WE'LL HEAR
FROM THE SEGMENTS. ANY
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS FROM
ANYBODY MR MEDINA. THANK YOU.
THERE AYE AYES BEFORE WE START I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR-
THIS IS MY- ENGINEER. THEY
LEGISLATURE. I THINK CHAIR OF
HIRED YOU FOR THE SEVEN YEARS.
AND AS APPROACH THIS BY YEAR. I
DO WANNA. THANK CHAIR IN THE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
FOR ALL THAT WE'VE DONE A FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS AND AS CHAIR MCCARTY
POINTED OUT WE'VE HAD A COUPLE
OF REALLY GOOD YEARS- IN HIGHER
EDUCATION- BETTER THAN AND IN
SOME YEARS PREVIOUS. BUT THERE'S
STILL LOTS TO BE DONE- IN MANY
PROGRAMS MANY WORTHWHILE
PROGRAMS THAT NEED FUNDING AND
AMONG THOSE PROGRAMS IS THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AND I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY ARE
HERE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS FROM
THE UC. REPRESENTING UC BERKELEY
AND UC IRVINE- AND PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT- THAT HAVE SUCH A GREAT
TRACK RECORD I DESERVED TO BE
FUNDED SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
HEARING TODAY. AND I WILL SPEAK
UP MORE ABOUT THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS PROGRAM. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OKAY SAYING I KNOW
THERE COMMENTED OUT LET'S HEAR
NOW FROM. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD AFTERNOON OF MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS GENERALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M GOING
TO BEGIN WITH A HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AS
WELL AS MAJOR SPENDING PROPOSALS
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND THEN HAND IT OFF TO MY
COLLEAGUE DAN HANAUER WHO WILL
DISCUSS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES. BUILDING
UPON THE HISTORIC INVESTMENTS IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS FIRST
AND FOREMOST EASTERN FOCUSED
BUDGET THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE MULTI YEAR
CONTACTS WITH THE UC AND CSU
ANIMAL TO YOUR ROAD MAP FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TOO MANY COLLEGES
THAT CONTAIN CLEAR COMMITMENTS
AND SHARED GOALS TOWARD INTEREST
EXPANDING STUDENTS ACCESS EQUITY
AND AFFORDABILITY. AND TO CREATE
PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS TO STUDY
IN ENTER HIGH NEED CAREERS AND
HEALTH EDUCATION CLIMATE CHANGE
AND TECHNOLOGY. AT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
COUNCIL FOR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
ESTABLISHED AN OVER ARCHING GOAL
OF ACHIEVING SEVENTY PERCENT.
POSTSECONDARY DEGREE AND
CERTIFICATE ATTAINMENT AMONG
WORKING AGE CALIFORNIANSBY
TWENTY THIRTY. THESE FORWARD
LOOKING GOALS WILL HELP PREPARE
CALIFORNIA AND OUR STUDENTS FOR
THE FUTURE AS WE ADDRESS
CHALLENGES POSED BY THE KOGI
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SHIFTS IN THE
NATURE OF WORK AND THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. WITH THAT I
WILL LIBRARY UPON THIS SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES BOTH
THE UC AND CSU 5% BATES GENERAL
FUND INCREASES IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE TOTALING TWO
HUNDRED POINT FIVE MILLION
ONGOING FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN POINT ONE MILLION ON
GOING FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. THESE INCREASES ARE
PROPOSED AS A FIRST YEAR PLANNED
BASED GROWTH OF 5% ANNUALLY
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN IN RECOGNITION OF CSU AND
UC'S GROWTH. PARDON ME UC'S
COMMITMENT TOWARD ACHIEVING
MULTIPLE GOALS THROUGH THE MULTI
YOUR CONTACTS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AIMED AT
INCREASING ACCESS IMPROVING
STUDENT SUCCESS IN ADVANCING
EQUITY. INCREASING THE
AFFORDABILITY FOR CSU AND UC
EDUCATION INCREASING AND OUR
SEGMENTAL COLLABORATION TO
BENEFIT STUDENTS SUPPORTING
WORKFORCE PREPAREDNESS WITH AND
HIGH DEMAND CAREER PIPELINES.
AND PROVIDING ACCESS TO ONLINE
COURSE OFFERINGS. THE TYPICAL AT
COMMITMENTS FOR EACH OF THESE
OBJECTIVES ARE OUTLINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SUMMARY AND
MORE DETAILED METRICS FOR THE
GOALS WILL BE SHARED AS PART OF
THE MAY REVISION. IN ADDITION TO
THE 5% BASE INCREASES FOR BOTH
UC AND CSU THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED SEVERAL TARGETED
INVESTMENTS. FOR THE STATEMENTS
THESE INCLUDE. ONGOING TRYING TO
FIND SUPPORT FOR ADDITIONAL FULL
TIME RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE ACADEMIC YEAR.
CONSISTENT WITH CONTENT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET ACT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES EIGHTY ONE
MILLION. FOUR CSU ENROLLMENT
GROWTH OF NINE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR STUDENTS AND
SIXTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
FOR USING ROLL ENROLLMENT
GROWTH. OF SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES THIRTY ONE
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
OFFSET REVENUE REDUCTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REPLACEMENT.
OF NINE HUNDRED TWO NONRESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS ENROLLED
AT THREE CAMPUSES WITHIN
EQUIVALENT NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT. UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS
AT THESE CAMPUSES. IN ADDITION
INCREASE SUPPORT FOR FOSTER
YOUTH AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
ATTENDING THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WITH ONGOING
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENTS OF SIX
MILLION AT THE UC AND TWELVE
MILLION AT THE CSU. IN ADDITION
SUPPORT FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECTS
AT THE UC AND CSU WITH THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND PROVIDED TO EACH
SEGMENT. AS WELL AS TARGETED CSU
INVESTMENTS OF EIGHTY THREE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
CSU BAKERSFIELD ENERGY
INNOVATION CENTER. AND FIFTY
MILLION A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR EQUIPMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS FOR CSU UNIVERSITY
FARMS. MARKEDET YOU SEE
INVESTMENTS INCLUDE A HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THREE
COMPLEMENTARY CLIMATE INITIATIVE
CHANGE INITIATIVES. TWO MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
RESEARCH CONDUCTED BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FIREARM
VIOLENCE. VIOLENCE RESEARCH
CENTER AND TEN MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT DYSLEXIA
RESEARCH AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO
DYSLEXIA CENTER. ALTHOUGH
TODAY'S HEARING IS FOCUSED ON
INVESTMENTS IN THE UC CSU AND
CALIFORNIA ME COLLEGES THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO PROPOSES
SEVERAL FINANCIAL AID
INVESTMENTS THAT WILL PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS INTENDED
THESE INSTITUTIONS. WITHOUT I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE DAN
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON- DAN
OR TO PREVENT A FINANCE- I WILL
NOT TURN TO THE INVESTMENT
INCLUDED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AS MENTIONED EARLIER
BOTTOM MY COLLEAGUE THE CCC
MULTI A ROAD MAP BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE FOCUSES ON
EQUITY AND STUDENT SUCCESS. IN
UPON THE SYSTEM'S VISION FOR
SUCCESS THE ROADMAP ESTABLISHES
SHARED EXPECTATIONS AN AMBITIOUS
GOALS. INVESTING AVAILABLE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESOURCES FOR THE COLLEGES TO
SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS AND
EXPANDING CHAPTERS OFFICE
CAPACITY. TO BETTER SUPPORT
COLLEGES IN MEETING THESE GOALS.
IN PARTICULAR THE MULTIROOM APP
FOCUSES ON GOALS RELATED TO
INTERSEGMENT OF COLLABORATION.
FOR TIMELY TRANSFER REDUCING
TIME 2 DEGREES CLOSING EQUITY
GAPS AND IMPROVING ALIGNED WITH
K. TWELVE IN WORKFORCE NEEDS.
TURNED OUT TO THE INVESTMENTS
INCLUDE IN THE BUDGET THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES THE
STATUTORY COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT OF FIVE POINT 33%
EIGHT IN ADDRESSING CONTINUED
ENROLLMENT DECLINES ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND IS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FIRMAMENT OUTREACH AND
STUDENT RETENTION EFFORTS.
BUILDING ON THE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION PROVIDED LAST
YEAR. FURTHER TO MEET THE
DIVERSE LEARNING MODALITY
DEMANDS OF THE STATE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES AN EXPECTATION THAT
DISTRICTS PROVIDE AT LEAST 50%
IN PERSON EXPERT EDUCATION. FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE ACADEMIC YEAR PROVIDED
THAT APPROACH IS CONSISTENT WITH
PUBLIC HELP- GUIDELINES IN PLACE
AT THE TIME. AND STUDENT DEMAND
. RECOGNIZING THE WIDESPREAD
ATTEND ATTEMPTED ADMISSIONS
ENROLLMENT AND FINANCIAL FRAUD
REPORTED ON EARLIER THIS YEAR AT
THE COLLEGES THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND. TWENTY FIVE
MILLION OF WHICH IS ON GOING TO
SHORE UP THE PROTECTION OF
SENSITIVE STUDENT AND FINANCIAL
DATA AND PROVIDE NEEDED UPDATES
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO SUPPORT OUR
PART TIME FACULTY.
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES THE
EIGHT SIGNIFICANT NEW INVESTMENT
OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND IS A PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM.
PROVIDING A STRONG FISCAL
INCENTIVES FOR DISTRICTS TO
OFFER HEALTH HEALTH INSURANCE TO
MORE THE PART TIME FACULTY.
RECOGNIZING THE CONTINUED-
CONTINUING CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PANDEMIC THE
INVESTMENTS AND COLLUDED IN THE
BUDGET LARGELY BUILT UPON
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR THE SOUTH FOR THE
SYSTEM TO IMPLEMENT RECENTLY
CHAPTER LEGISLATION. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED AND FIVE MILLION ONETIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. CONCOURSE NUMBERING
EFFORTS RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN. AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR COLLEGES
TO IMPLEMENT THE TRANSFER FORM
PROVISIONS OF AB NINE TWENTY
EIGHT. THAT DEMOCRATS THE
DEMONSTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT
THE PANDEMIC HAS NOT IMPACTED
ALL GROUPS EQUALLY. THE
FOURTEENTH AND- EVEN BEFORE THAT
PERSISTENT LONG TERM EQUITY GAPS
THAT EXISTED AT MOST IF NOT ALL
OF OUR STATE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AS SUCH THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES OVER FORTY MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. IN FUNDING ACROSS MULTIPLE
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
EQUITY GAPS OF THE COLLEGES.
FINALLY I WILL NOTE THAT
RECENTLY RELEASED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE PROPOSED A PHASED
APPROACH TO THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION IN THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA. WHICH
IS SLATED TO EXPIRE AFTER THE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE-
IS A YEAR. THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES TO CREATE A FUNDING FOR
USING TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE FUNDING LEVELS ALLOWING FOR
A LIVING FUNDING RATES TO
CONTINUE TO INCREASE BY THE
STATUTORY COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. BUT REMOVING THE
APPLICATION OF THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT TO BEHOLD FROM
THIS PROVISION. BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX.
EFFECTIVELY THIS APPROACH ALLOWS
DISTRICTS TO TRANSITION TO THE
CORE FORMULA OVER TIME. WHILE
PREVENTING PHYSICAL DECLINES
BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX. WITH THAT WE
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ABOUT
PROPOSALS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
INCLUDED WITHIN THIS BUDGET.
THANK YOU WHEN I HEAR FROM OUR
L. A. L. JENNIFER CAN CHALLAN.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
YOU SHOULD HAVE A ALEJO BUDGET
THREE FOR FORTY ENTITLED
OVERVIEW AND THE GOVERNOR'S
HIGHER AND BUDGET PROPOSAL I'M
GONNA BE REFERRING TO A FEW OF
THE FIGURES IN THAT BRIEF. AFTER
WALKING THROUGH A FEW OF THOSE-
FIGURES ALL AND FOCUS MY
COMMENTS IN THREE AREAS THE
STATEMENT SPACE BUDGET
ENROLLMENT AND FACILITY
MAINTENANCE. SO IF YOU TURN TO
FIGURE TO ON PAGE THREE YOU CAN
SAY ARE GOING FUNDING FIVE
STORES FOR EACH OF THE SEGMENTS
. UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ONGOING FUNDING WOULD INCREASE
FOR THE COLLEGES BY FOUR POINT
FOUR PERCENT. FOR CSU 6% AND FOR
YEARS THE FOUR POINT 7% IF YOU'D
LIKE TO START ONGOING GENERAL
FUND YOU CAN SEE IT GROWING 10%
AT CSU AND SEVEN POINT 7% AT UC.
SO THESE ARE HIGH- INCREASES
COMPARED TO MOST YEARS. IF YOU
TURN YOUR FOR ON PAGE FOUR OF
THE ALLEY- BRIEF YOU CAN SEE ALL
THE MAJOR ON GOING A ONE TIME
PROPOSALS FOR THE SEGMENTS IN
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION.
REGARDING ONGOING SPENDING
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THE BASING
CREASES ALONG WITH THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDING FOR
EACH SEGMENT. YOU CAN SEE THE
LARGEST OF ALL ON GOING HIGHER
AND SPENDING PROPOSALS AS A FIVE
POINT. I'M SORRY A FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN MILLION AUGMENTATION
AND FOR THE REVAMP MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM. SO THIS
REVAMPS PROGRAM IS INTENDED
PROVIDE MORE CSU AND UC. METAL
AND A LOW INCOME STUDENTS WITH
MORE FINANCIAL AID. AND THE
REGARDING THE ONE TIME SPENDING
YOU CAN SEE HAS AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. IF YOU
TURN TO FIGURE FIVE ON PAGE FIVE
YOU CAN SEE ALL THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SPENDING PROPOSALS
THAT THE GOVERNOR EXCLUDES FROM
THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS MATT.
SO IF YOU WERE TO PROVIDE LAST
THAN ANY OF THE AREAS SHOWN WE
THINK IT LIKELY WOULD NEED TO
SPEND MORE AND OTHER STYLE
AREAS- ALTERNATIVELY IF YOU
SPENT MORE AND ANY OF THE AREAS
SHOWN YOU POTENTIALLY COULD FREE
UP STYLE SPENDING ELSEWHERE.
WITHIN OR BEYOND THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SECTOR OF THE BUDGET.
SO IT'S TURNING TO THE SEGMENTS
BASED BY JETS YOU KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES A FIVE POINT
33% COLA FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
APPORTIONMENT. MORE RECENT DATA
SHOWING THAT COLA RATE IS LIKELY
TO COMING CLOSER TO SIX POINT
SEVENTEEN PERCENT. THAT WOULD
RAISE COSTS ABOUT SIXTY FIVE
MILLION SO INSTEAD OF A FOUR
HUNDRED AND NINE MILLION DOLLAR
PORTION INCREASED. COSTS WOULD
BE FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION. THE COLOR RATE WILL BE
LOCKED DOWN IN APRIL BUT WHETHER
FIVE OR SIX OR SIX AND A HALF
PERCENT THESE ARE AMONG THE
HIGHEST COLDER RATES THE
COLLEGES WHAT ABOUT PERCEIVED.
THE COLLEGE PENSION RATES THOUGH
ALSO ARE INCREASING IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AT AN UNUSUAL PACE.
TWO POINT 2% FOR THE STIRS
DISTRICT CONTRIBUTION AND TWO
AND A HALF PERCENT FOR THE PERS
DISTRICT CONTRIBUTION. AND IS
RELATIVELY HIGH RATES ARE
LARGELY ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE X.
EXPIRATION OF THE PREVIOUS STATE
PROVIDED PENSION RELIEF. AND
THEN IN ADDITION TO PENSION
PRESSURES I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT SALARY PRESSURES
BOTH THE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES LIKE WE ARE- ARE
LIKELY TO FACE GREATER THAN
NORMAL SALARY PRESSURE GIVEN
INFLATION IS AT HISTORICALLY
HIGH LEVELS. THE TURN FOR A
MOMENT IN THE UNIVERSITIES BASED
INCREASE SAYS IF YOU LOOK AT
THINGS HERE SIX ON PAGE SEVEN OF
THE BUDGET BRIEF. YOU CAN SEE
ABOUT CSU'S PROJECTED OPERATING
COSTS SALARIES HEALTH CARE COSTS
PENSION COSTS LEN IN THAT
SERVICE. THOSE PROJECTED
OPERATING COSTS ARE TO GROW
SLIGHTLY MORE THAN THE FIVE
PERCENT THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS-
AT THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED. IN CONTRAST UC'S
PROJECTED OPERATING COSTS ARE
EXPECTED TO GROW SLIGHTLY LESS
THAN ITS GENERAL FUND BASED WHEN
COUPLED WITH THE TUITION REVENUE
AND EXPECTS TO GAIN. AND THE BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE SEGMENTS
IS THIS TUITION FACTOR SO
WHEREAS THE ISSUES OPERATING
COSTS ARE PROJECTED TO FALL
SHORT. EVERY YEAR PERIOD YOU SEE
IS EXPECTED TO MAKE ENDS MEET
LARGELY BECAUSE OF THE GREATER
TUITION REVENUE THAT'S EXPANDING
ITS BUDGET CAPACITY. ATTORNEY
GENERAL MATT WITH A FOCUS ON
WHAT OUR MOMENT LEVELS HOW
THEY'VE BEEN CHANGING WHAT'S
DRIVING THOSE TRENDS ARE THEY
WITHIN THE CAMPUSES CONTROL AND
WHAT CAN THE LEGISLATURE DO
MOVING FORWARD. SO IF YOU LOOK
AT FIGURE EIGHT ON PAGE TEN IT
SHOWS THOSE ENROLLMENT TRENDS.
IT SHOWS THAT ENROLLMENT IS DOWN
NOTABLY AT THE COLLEGES OVER THE
PERIOD. IT SAYS THAT CSU
ENROLLMENT WAS GROWING IN
NINETEEN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT THEN
FALLON TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. IT
SHOWS THAT YOU SEE ENROLLMENT
CLIMBED OVER MOST OF THE PERIOD
BUT THEN DECLINED SLIGHTLY IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. WHEN YOU
WERE STARTING YOUR ENROLLMENT
TARGETS LAST YEAR YOU WERE USING
THE BEST AVAILABLE DATA AT THE
TIME NOT BEST DATA WITH COMING
FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AT THAT
THE COLLEGES WAS DOWN. BUT THE
DATA WAS SHOWING THE ENROLLMENT
AT THE UNIVERSITY IS WAS MORE
ROBUST THAN EXPECTED. EVEN IN
THE EARLY PART OF THE PANDEMIC
WITH THE SHIFT TO REMOTE
OPERATIONS AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
INVOLVEMENT AT THE UNIVERSITIES
BROUGH. SO GIVEN THE STATE OF
MOST FOLKS SIX SUSPECTED THAT
UNIVERSITY ENROLLMENT WOULD
CONTINUE TO GROW IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. PARTICULARLY WITH
THE SHIFT BACK TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. A SENSE THAT TIME
WE'VE LEARNED THAT THE UPDATED
DATA IS SHOWING THE ENROLLMENT
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IS
WEAKER THAN EXPECTED AT ALL OF
THE SEGMENTS. WHAT'S DRIVING THE
CHANGES. ONE FACTOR IS THE JOB
MARKET WE KNOW THAT THE JOB
MARKET IS GOOD RIGHT NOW MANY
JOB OPENINGS A RECENT INCREASE
IN THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE. WE
JUST MORE BROADLY ARE RISING.
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENROLLMENT
AND SENSITIVE TO CHANGES IN THE
JOB MARKET. YOU SEE ENROLLMENT
AND CONTRAST IS THE LEAST THE
FACTOR OF THE THREE SEGMENTS.
MUNITY COLLEGES ALSO HAVE MORE
STUDENTS TO HAVE CHILDREN SO
THESE ADULTS MIGHT HAVE HAD TO
TAKE TIME AWAY FROM SCHOOL AND
WORK SO THEY COULD CARE FOR
THEIR OWN CHILDREN AND OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS. AND THIS
CHALLENGE AGAIN IS MOST
PREVALENT AMONG COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THESE PREVALENT AT UC.
I'M BOTH FACTORS THE JOB MARKET
AND CHILD CARE RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE LARGELY BEYOND THE DIRECT
CONTROL OF THE CAMPUS AS- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. M. AND STARTING TO
IMPACT WHAT WERE SEEN AT THE
UNIVERSITIES SO TRANSFER
APPLICATIONS TO CSU FOR EXAMPLE
ARE DECLINING HAVE BEEN
DECLINING. SO THE DECISIONS
BEFORE YOU ENTERED WHICH ARMS OF
WHAT TO DO ABOUT INVOLVEMENT AND
YOUR CHURCH TRADITIONALLY DO SAT
AND ROMAN TARGETS FOR EACH OF
THE SEGMENTS. OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS YOU TYPICALLY START THEM
FOR BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE THIS
GIVES THE UNIVERSITIES TIME TO
PLAN AND MANAGE THEIR
INVOLVEMENT WHILE STILL ALLOWING
YOU DOES THAT OVERALL TAX THAT'S
LEVELS. UNLESS STATE TYPICALLY
PROVIDES ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FUNDING NOT TO LINE TO THOSE
TARGETS. THE STATE DOESN'T
TYPICALLY GO BACK AND ADJUST
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDING
RETROACTIVELY. SO FOR EXAMPLE
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THAT THE
STATE PROVIDED CSU WITH GROWTH
FUNDING IN NINETEEN TWENTY TO
GROW BY TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
AND ENDED UP GROWING BY ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS BUT THE
STATE DIDN'T GO BACK AND ADJUST
CSU'S LEVEL CORD A FUNDING LEVEL
ACCORDINGLY. YOU SEE OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS HAS EXCEEDED
ITS BUDGET TARGETS IN THE STATE
HASN'T EVEN KNOWING THAT THE
STATE HASN'T TO DATE GONE AND
PROVIDED YOU SEE FIND MORE
FUNDING. THE MAIN REASON THE
STATE DOESN'T MAKE THESE
RETROACTIVE ADJUSTMENTS IS
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T WANT THE
STATEMENTS TO DISREGARD THE
STATE TARGETS SO IT DOESN'T ON
THE STATE THE STATE DOESN'T WANT
TO ENCOURAGE THE STATEMENTS.
INDEPENDENTLY MAKE THEIR OWN
TARGETS THEIR OWN DECISIONS
ABOUT ACCESS ABOUT ASSOCIATED
STATE COSTS ABOUT ASSOCIATED
PROGRAM QUALITY THE LEGISLATURE
HAS WANTED TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS IN COORDINATION WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
SEGMENTS. THE LEGISLATURE DOES
HOWEVER TYPICALLY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT ANY UPDATED ENROLLMENT
DATA WHEN IT SUCKS IT'S NEW
ENROLLMENT TARGETS. SO MOVING
FORWARD. FOR THE COLLEGE AS-
PROVIDING A ROAMING GROWTH
FUNDING EVEN IF IT'S ON USED IS
VERY LOW OVER ASK IF THE
COLLEGES DON'T USE THAT THAT
FUNDING- REVERTS TO THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT RIVERS AN ACCOUNT
BECOMES AVAILABLE FOR OTHER PROP
NINETY EIGHT PURPOSES. AT CSU
YOU COULD CONSIDER NOT PROVIDING
A MOMENT FUNDING IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. DS USER AGREEMENT
IS EXPECTED TO STILL BE DOWN
FROM PREVIOUSLY FUNDED LEVELS.
BUT YOU COULD CONSIDER SPENDING
A NEW TARGET FOR TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR THAT WOULD TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THIS MOST RECENT WOMAN
DATA. ARE YOU SEE EIGHT YOU
COULD PROVIDE LESS FUNDING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THAN YOU
EXPECTED A YEAR AGO BECAUSE I'M
GONNA AS EXPECTED TO. NOT MEET
THE TARGET THAT USE THAT. BUT
THEN AGAIN MOVING FORWARD FOR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR YOU
COULD USE THAT MOST RECENT
EMPLOYMENT DATA THAT YOU HAVE TO
SET A NEW TARGET. REGARDLESS OF
WHAT YOU DECIDE THAT THE
STATEMENTS IF YOU DECIDE ON A
ROMAN TARGET WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SET ASIDE. AFFECTIVELY
RESERVE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FUNDING SO THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
AND BE ABLE TO COVER IT. IN THE
YEAR IN WHICH THE GROWTH
MATERIALIZE THAT THIS THIS IS
WHAT YOU HAD DONE THE LAST FEW
YEARS. AND THAT WOULD BE IN
CONTRAST TO THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH IN THE OUT YEARS OF
FINDING IT WITH IN THE BASE.
FUNDING AND AS A STANDALONE ITEM
IS JUST A MORE TRANSPARENT
BUDGET PRACTICE. FINALLY ON
FACILITY MAINTENANCE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE STATE HAS
BEEN PROVIDING THE SEGMENTS ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THEIR BACKLOGS.
EVEN WITH THE STATE ALLOCATIONS.
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACKLOG
IS ABOUT THE SAME LEVEL AS IT
WAS FIVE YEARS AGO. BOTH THE CSU
AND UC BACKLOGS ARE NOTABLY
LARGER TODAY. A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO THE LEGISLATURE ASK THE
UNIVERSITY IS TO THE METS
FACILITY MAINTENANCE REPORT BOTH
OF THOSE REPORTS HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED WE HAD A CHANCE TO
LOOK AT THEM. THEY SHOW THAT CSU
IS FALLING ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SHORT OF
SPENDING WHAT IT NEEDS TO ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS TO ADDRESS THE
CAPITAL RENEWAL. AND YOU SEE THE
SPENDING ABOUT A BILLION LAST
THAN WHAT IT NEEDS ANNUALLY TO
ADDRESS ITS CAPITAL RENEWAL SO
THAT'S NOT EVEN TO ADDRESS THE
EXISTING BACKLOG THAT'S JUST TO
KEEP THE BACKLOG FROM GROWING.
ADDRESSING THESE LARGE
UNDERLYING BUDGET CAPS IS LIKELY
TO BE DAUNTING. BUT WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO BEGIN THINKING ABOUT HOW
TO ADDRESS THEM AND ULTIMATELY
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
STATEMENTS TO BUILD A LONG TERM
PLAN. THAT WOULD ELIMINATE THE
BACKLOG AND FULLY FUND THE
ESTIMATED ANNUAL CAPITAL RENEWAL
NEEDS. I KNOW I WENT OVER THAT
PRETTY QUICKLY AND I'M HAPPY TO
GO OVER INVOLVEMENT ISSUES OR
ANY OTHER ISSUES THAT MIGHT BE
OF INTEREST TO YOU MORE SLOWLY
IF YOU. THANK YOU. I WANT TO
START BY ASKING- THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO MAKE IT A
PERMANENT FINANCE BACK ON THE
LINE. IF YOU CAN RESPOND TO
THIS- THIS RECENT DEVELOPMENT ON
THE UC ENROLLMENT. THAT LITTLE
LOT LAST YEAR'S- BUDGET OUTLINE
FROM THE LEGISLATURE SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR HAD YOU SEE
ENROLLMENT INCREASES FOR THIS
COMING FALL IT'S SIX THOUSAND
PLUS THE PLUS IS. THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
BECAUSE OF THEIR NON RESIDENT
ISSUE THAT MR TANG AND I'M
WORKING ON FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS- THIS WAS THE AGREEMENT
AND BY THE WAY THIS IS AN
AMAZING STATE BUDGET I HATE I
HATE TO START OUT WITH SOMETHING
NEGATIVE HERE BUT IT IS AN ISSUE
THAT'S OF IMPORTANCE TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WITH HER.
AND THEIR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WANT TO GET TO YOU SEE NEXT
FALL- AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ON JANUARY TEN MEMORIALIZED THIS
UNDERSTANDING WITH- MONIES TO
FIND SIX THOUSAND NEW STUDENTS
TO ENROLL. THIS FALL AT THE UC
SELL KIDS CAN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN LIGHTNESS ON ON YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS ISSUE- AND
LYFT. IN LIVE AND THAT WE HAVE
THE MONEY THAT WE PUT IN THE
BUDGET A FEW WEEKS AGO AND THIS
RECENT FORMATION I'M SURE YOU'VE
GOTTEN FROM THE YOU SEE AS WELL. REBEKAH KIRK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANK YOU FOR THE QUICK
ACTION MISTER CHAIR. I GET THE
GOVERNOR PERSPECTIVE THAT
INCLUDES ITS FUNDING PURSUANT TO
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. EVEN AT DIFFERENCE THIRTY
FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS PRESIDENT
STUDENTS AT THE UC IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE ACADEMIC
YEAR. AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE SPECIFIES THAT
THAT IS USING A BASELINE OF
TWENTY IT. TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THAT SAID WE HAVE HEARD FROM
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
INTEREST IN RATES ON YOUR FOR
THAT IT ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
DISCUSSION WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE UC. AND AS YOU'RE AWARE
THAT WE ADDITIONALLY HAVE
FUNDING IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FOR THE SHIFT OF NINE HUNDRED
TWO STUDENTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLMENT SLOTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY. AND NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS AT THREE CAMPUSES AND
THAT WOULD BE SHIFTING TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT ENROLLMENT
ON TOP OF. THE SIXTY TWO THIRTY
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED. THANK YOU
ARE HAVING SOME AUDIO DIFFICULTY
AND SO SOME OF THE KEY NUMBERS
AND DATES KIND OF CUT OUTS OUT-
BUT I THINK WE GOT THE JUST TO
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND I THINK
THE BIGGEST POINT YOU SAID AS-
WE WERE ITS ONGOING WORK.
LOOKING INTO AND WORKING ON IT.
I GUESS THAT THE ISSUE THAT THAT
WE- ARE GRAPPLING WITH IS THAT.
IT WAS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
WOULD HAVE AT LEAST SIX THOUSAND
NEW SLOTS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS THIS FALL. AND WE PUT
MONEY IN THE BUDGET AND YOU WILL
YOU PUT MONEY IN THE BUDGET. ON
JANUARY TENTH. THE FINALS. CELL
ARE USED IT IS IT UC'S SAYING
THAT THEY WANT TO. BACK OFF THAT
NUMBER WHICH WE HOPE THAT THEY
DON'T DO. BUT IF THEY DO IT. IS
THE GOVERNOR'S. TEAM PROPOSING
THAT THE YOU REDUCE. THE A
PREPARATION TO UC TO BECAUSE
YOU'RE YOU HAVE MONEY IN THE FOR
SIX THOUSAND NOW. AND IF THEY
DON'T DO SIX THOUSAND NEW DO YOU
STILL THINK THEY SHOULD GET THAT
ENTIRE LOT OF MONEY. WOULD YOU.
ALSO IN A MONEY BACK. PROPOSED
TO POSTPONE THE MONEY BACK.
HOPEFULLY THERE THE AUDIO ISSUES
ARE CORRECTED- OUR PROPOSAL IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS FOR
SIXTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
THAT IS DIRECTLY LINKED TO THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF SIX
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FULL
TIME STUDENT THE BASIS FOR THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT PROPOSED IS BASED
ON LOOKING AT THE MARGINAL COST
OF INSTRUCTION THAT THE UC
PROVIDED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. WHEN IS THAT THE
ROAMING HER THROAT WAS
DISCOVERED AFTER THE PART OF
PLASTIC. THIS BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS. SAID THAT THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING PRESENTLY IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
SPECIFICALLY LINKED TO THAT
AMOUNT OF AN ROAMING GROWTH.
BASED ON A BASS LINE HERE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THAT
SAYS THE BUDGET DISCUSSION
CONTINUES AND WE HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE UNIVERSITY.
IF THERE WERE TO BE AN ALTERNATE
APPROACH THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE REPRESENTED PERHAPS AS
PART OF A NEW REVISION ARE
MOVING FORWARD. OKAY THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR. WITH YOU BUT BUT AGAIN
IT'S OUR- HEART STRONG- NOT JUST
HOPE IT'S OUR COMMITMENT THAT WE
ALL CELEBRATED LAST YEAR WITH-
ANNOUNCEMENTS FROM THE GOVERNOR.
FROM THE SPEAKER FROM THE PRO
TAN FROM THE BUDGET SURE THE
ASSEMBLY FROM THE BUDGET SHARE
IN THE SENATE TO ME THE BUDGETS
ARE IN THE SENATE THAT THIS IS
ONE OF THEIR TOP ACCOMPLISHMENTS
IS YOU'RE TELLING CALIFORNIANS
HEY WE HAVE AT LEAST SIX
THOUSAND NEW SPOTS FOR YOU TO GO
THE UC IN THE FALL. PLUS A
COUPLE THOUSAND MORE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE NON RESIDENT
RESIDENTS WHAT SO WE INTEND TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH THAT. AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS MONEY
TO PAY FOR THAT SO THIS IS A
STICKING POINT THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE WEEKLY FIGURE OUT
SO I WITH THAT- OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FROM THIS PIECE FROM THE
FROM THE L. A. L. OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. MISTER
MISTER MEDINA THANK YOU. YEAH I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE L.
A. O. HAVING TO DO WITH-
GOVERNOR'S A- PROPOSAL OF DOING.
GOING FINALLY FOR ALL PART TIME
HEALTH INSURANCE. BEFORE IT DOWN
I ASK ANYBODY. I THE HELLO SO
THINK THAT I WANT TO POINT OUT A
RESPONSE TECHNICIAN. TO READ OF
THE REVENUE BE DE AROUND SHOULD
BE UP. OKAY MISCREANT WAS START
OVER I WILL START OVER- I HAVE
QUESTIONS OF THE L. A. O. REGARD
THE GOVERNOR A PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION I'M GOING
FUNDING TO THE PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTH INSURANCE PROGRAM. BUT
BEFORE ASKING THE QUESTIONS I
WANT TO POINT OUT. SOMETHING
THAT MY COLLEAGUE HERE FROM LONG
BEACH- JUST ASK ME ABOUT AND
THAT IS THE MAKE UP. OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PART TIME
FACULTY AND WHY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO RELY. OF
ON THE PART TIME FACULTY TO
FUNCTION TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND I WOULD
POINT US ALL TO. I THINK A VERY.
INSIGHTFUL ARTICLE THAT CAME
OUT. LAST WEEK AND EDSOURCE AND
IT REFERS TO THE PART TIME
FACULTY AS THE GIG WORKERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND ASK THE
QUESTION ARE CONDITION IS
WORSENING IS THIS YEAR FOR
CHANGES FOR ADJUNCT FACULTY. AND
I WOULD JUST REMIND EVERYONE
THAT YOU KNOW BEING A PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBER IN- THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS
A ROUGH ROAD. WITH NO OR VERY
LITTLE OFFICE HOURS- NO
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH
STUDENTS AND AS THE ARTICLE
POINTS OUT SOMETIMES NOT EVEN
HAVING THE RESPECT OF OTHER
FACULTY MEMBERS AT THEIR OWN
INSTITUTIONS. SO WITH THAT SAID
ABOUT I'LL GO TO- MY QUESTIONS
AND INDICATE THAT I VERY MUCH
SUPPORT. THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR PART TIME HEALTH INSURANCE-
BECAUSE THEY AND ESPECIALLY
THOSE PART TIME FACULTY WHO HAVE
TO GO FROM ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TO ANOTHER HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME IN GETTING- HEALTH
INSURANCE AND SO ONE QUESTION I
HAVE TO- THE L. A. O. IS. AND TO
THOSE FACULTY WHO HAVE TO GO
FROM ONE INSTITUTION TO ANOTHER. THE EXISTING PROGRAM CURRENTLY
DOESN'T ALLOW FOR ANY
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR THESE SO
CALLED FREQUENT FREEWAY FLYERS
DESPITE WORKING OVER 40%
WORKLOAD. AND I WOULD- ADVOCATE
TO CHANGE THAT TO ALLOW IS
FREEWAY FLYERS TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET TO PURCHASE HEALTH CARE
AND WHAT CAN WE DO TO. TO
ADDRESS THOSE OF PART TIME
FACULTY ON HEALTH INSURANCE
BETTER AND THAT IS A QUESTION TO
THE L. A. O. JENNIFER COULD
SHOWER AGAIN FROM THE ALEJO SO
THIS WAS A CONCERN THAT WE
RAISED IN OUR ANALYSIS SO. IT'S
NOT JUST THE YOU WERE RAISING
THE ISSUE OF A PART TIME FACULTY
MEMBERS WHO MIGHT BE WORKING AT
MULTIPLE DISTRICTS BUT JUST WHAT
THE DISTRICT IS DECIDING WHETHER
TO GRANT THEM HEALTH CARE
BENEFITS. AND AT THE SAME TIME
THEY MIGHT BE WORKING ONE YEAR
AND NOT ANOTHER YEAR DEPENDING
ON THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ENROLLMENT DEMAND- SO IT'S FOR
THESE REASONS THAT A FACULTY A
PART TIME FACULTY MEMBERS MIGHT
JUST HAVE A HARD TIME HOLDING ON
TO. GOOD HEALTH CARE YEAR AFTER
YEAR SO AS YOU KNOW COVER
CALIFORNIA IT IS PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE TO PARK CONTENT
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA IT IS
SUBSIDIZED IT'S BEEN MORE
GENEROUSLY SUBSIDIZED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND SO WE WERE JUST
CAUTIONING THE LEGISLATURE
BEFORE CREATING A NEW PROGRAM
THROUGH THE CALL URBAN AND
MASSIVELY EXPANDED PROGRAM
BECAUSE THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
EXISTS TODAY DATES FROM THE
NINETIES BEFORE COVER
CALIFORNIA- BUT FOR THE INCREASE
IN SUBSIDIES THAT'S MAKING
HEALTH CARE IDEALLY MORE
AFFORDABLE- SO IT'S PREDATING
COVERED CALIFORNIA'S THE BEFORE
IT. MAKING THAT PART TIME
HEALTHCARE PROGRAM MUCH BIGGER
WE WERE JUST WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU WANT IN THE STATE
ACTUALLY WHEN IT BE HURTING PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBERS BY EIGHT
MAKING THEM NO LONGER ELIGIBLE
FOR COVER CALIFORNIA BECAUSE AS
SOON AS THE DISTRICT DOES OFFER
HEALTH CARE. IF IT MEETS A
CERTAIN AFFORDABILITY THRESHOLD
THE PART TIME FACULTY OF SORT OF
OBLIGATED TO TAKE AT VAPE
FORFEIT THEIR RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE IN COVERED
CALIFORNIA IT WAS ONE JUST SORT
OF CAUTIONARY NOTE WHICH IS WHY
WE SAID BEFORE MOVING FORWARD
THE STATE COULD COLLECT MORE
INFORMATION HOW MANY PART TIMERS
ARE GETTING HEALTH CARE FROM
WHAT SOURCE. SAYS- AND- HOW IS
IT CAN TO A PARTS WORKERS IN
THIS. AND WHEN WE PEOPLE OUT.
AND IN GOOD HEALTH CARE THAT
PART TIMERS ALREADY MIGHT BE
ACCESSING SO WE DO THINK THERE
ARE SOME WAYS UNDER COVER
CALIFORNIA TO IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY AND I THINK OUR
OFFICE IS DOING SOME WORK IN
THAT AREA SO THAT WE CAN GIVE
YOU SOME IDEAS ON THAT FRONT
THAT SORT OF BE ON. MY HIGHER
AND EXPERTISE BUT WE DO HAVE
FOLKS ON OUR HEALTH UNIT THAT
ARE WORKING ON THAT. RIGHT YEAH
I'M NOT SURE THAT I- HAVE ANY.
AT THE SAME CONCERNS YOU KNOW I
MEAN IT'S CLEAR TO ME THAT THE
NEED IS THERE FOR PART TIME
FACULTY HI AND HELP- I'M JUST
KINDA ASKING. WHAT ELSE CAN WE
DO. TO HELP- IT CAN USE ANYTHING
ABOUT THE 50% CAP- THAT EXIST-
IN REIMBURSEMENT UNIT ENDING UP
ON THAT. HELLO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS AREN'T TO REQUIRE A
REQUIRED TO SPEND AT LEAST HALF
OF THEIR BUDGET FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL PURPOSES SO FOR
APPLE TV IN THE CLASSROOM THIS
CAN BE PART TIME OR FULL TIME
FACULTY JUST FOR INSTRUCTIONAL
PURPOSES- SO I IT'S A
LONGSTANDING RULE IN TERMS OF
IT'S AN ACCESS WITH THE HEALTH
CARE- AS HEALTH CARE COSTS
BECOME A LARGER PORTION OF THE
BUDGET IT JUST CREATES. PRESSURE
IN THIS INSTANCE- BUT I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
MOST INSURMOUNTABLE ISSUE I
THINK THE- TRICKIER ISSUE WILL
JUST BE MAKING SURE THAT THE
WHOLE CARE IS EITHER COMPARABLE
THAN WHAT SOMEONE COULD GET IN
COVERED CALIFORNIA- AND IS AS
SECURE MEANING THAT THE PART
TIMER REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
CLASSES ARE TEACHING REGARDLESS
OF WHICH DISTRICTS REGARDLESS OF
WHICH YOUR CONTROLLED ON TO.
THEM AND THEN MAYBE I JUST AND
BYE BYE AGAIN- SAYING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM LONG BEACH
POINTS OUT TO ME THAT WEEK WE
CONTINUE TO TRY TO DO THINGS
AROUND THE EDGES OF HELPING PART
TIME FACULTY YOU KNOW WHETHER BE
HEALTH CARE OFFICE HOURS- I KNOW
THERE'S A COUPLE OF BILLS COMING
UP. ONE MYSELF INCLUDED- AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ TO
WORK ON- ON THE RATIOS IN THE
AMOUNT OF HOURS THAT PART TIME
FACULTY CAN WORK TO INCREASE
THE- RIGHT TO ALLOW PART TIME
FACULTY TO WORK MORE HOURS- THE
FORMULAS ARE BENEFICIAL TO THEM.
BUT AT THE AT THE END OF THE
DAY. THE ARE NOT REALLY LONG
TIMES. AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN. IS THAT
PART TIME FACULTY. NEED TO
BECOME FULL TIME FACULTY- AND
DOING ANYTHING DIFFERENT IS
CONTINUING TO. EXPLOIT THE PART
TIME WORKERS. AND I'LL CLOSE
WITH THAT. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL. THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIR AND I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE WITH REGARD TO
THE PART TIME SEEMS LIKE WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN- WITH DOLLARS
AND OTHER- POLICY VENTURES TO
AVOID HIRING PEOPLE FULL TIME.
WHEN IT MIGHT EVEN BE CHEAPER TO
HIRE THEM FULL TIME AND ALL OF
WITH ALL THE MONEY WE SEE BEING
THROWN OF THAT EFFORT SO AGAIN I
HOPE THAT SOMETHING. WE CAN TAKE
A LOOK AT THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS GOING FORWARD. M. I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS A START-
THIS IS PART OF A PROCESS. BUT
IF YOU JUST BACK UP A LOOK AT
THIS FROM A GENERAL BUDGETING
PERSPECTIVE. I QUESTION HOW
RESPONSIBLE SOME OF THIS BUDGET
IS BECAUSE I LOOK AT 5% INCREASE
BASIC BASED INCREASE TO UC. 5%
TO SEE ISSUE FIVE POINT THREE
THREE. TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
. AND THAT'S BELOW CPI CPI IS
ABOUT SEVEN POINT FIVE PERCENT-
THEY'RE ALSO GOING TO EXPERIENCE
PERSON STIRS. INCREASES THIS
YEAR OF AROUND TWO POINT FIVE S.
IF YOU COMBINE THE TWO. SO RIGHT
THERE. YOU'RE UP TO WHAT CLOSE
TO TEN PERCENT. AND YET. THERE'S
A 5% BASE INCREASE THE UC AND
CSU. AND A FIVE POINT THREE
THREE TO NINETY EIGHT ON THE ON
THE COMMUNITY CALLED SIDE. IN
GENERAL THERE IS ON AND I'M NOT
I'M NINETY EIGHT WHICH ISN'T
ENOUGH. BUT AND THEN WE'VE GOT
NEW PROGRAM SO WE'RE NOT.
FUNDING PLEASE COLLEGES AT A
LEVEL WHERE THEY CAN STATE
SUSTAIN THE PROGRAMS THEY HAVE
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO GO OUT AND
CREATE A BUNCH OF NEW PROGRAMS I
LOOK AT. THE UC HAS WHAT ONE TWO
THREE FOUR. IT'S LIKE ABOUT FOUR
GIVE OR TAKE THREE OR FOUR NEW
INITIATIVES NEW PROGRAMS ONGOING
RIGHT DOESN'T MEAN THE NOT GOOD
PROGRAMS. BUT YOU LOOK AT CSU
LOOKS LIKE THERE'S ONE OR TWO
THERE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE. OTHER EIGHT EIGHT NEW
PROGRAMS WITH THE CPI OF ONLY
FIVE POINT 33% SO THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO MORE WITH LESS
NEW PROGRAMS- SO TO ME I JUST IF
WE'RE NOT GOING TO FUND. THE
EXISTING OPERATIONS AT A
RESPONSIBLE LEVEL WHY ARE WE
JUMPING INTO NEW PROGRAMS MAYBE-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
SHED SOME LIGHT ON THE.
I THINK
WE'VE LOST SOMEONE MISTER. YEAH
DO WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THERE. REBEKAH CORRECT
APARTMENT OF FINANCE CAN YOU
HEAR ME YEAH JUST. THANK YOU ARE
NOT AN AUDIT EARLIER- THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION I WILL FIRSTLY
I WOULD NOTE SPENT BE BACK HOME
BY THAT IS FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OF THE FIVE POINT 33%
THAT WAS DEVELOPED IN OF COURSE
PART OF OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROCESS AND WOULD BE REVISITED
AS WE PREPARE FOR THE MAYOR
VISION AS WELL. BASED ON ANY
UPDATE THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
ACTING KOLAB. GENERALLY
REGARDING INVESTMENT FOR ALL
THREE SEGMENTS OF COURSE FOR YOU
HERE YES YOU THE PROPER FOOTBALL
DIFFERENT BENEFITS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES GIVEN THAT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE ARE FUNDED
ACCORDING TO THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT KERINCI BUT WHAT THE UC
AND CSU BASE INCREASES OF 5%
EACH PROPOSED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THOSE ARE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN THE VIEW OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OF LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED 5% BASE
INCREASE OF ON GOING FOR EACH
SEGMENT AN ADDITIONAL IN
ADDITION TO RESTORING THE CUTS
THE BASED ON THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT. WE WERE JUST NOTE
THAT 5% BASED BUDGET INCREASES
FOR THE SEGMENT R. VERY STRONG
AND HAVE BEEN VERY STRONG AND
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT IF YOU LOOK
AT RECENT YEARS INVESTMENT.
THANK MENSAH'S WALK. THANK YOU
FOR YOU JUST ONE TO READ THAT-
WE'RE GOING. TO FUND THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO AN ADEQUATE
LEVEL I DON'T KNOW THAT WE
SHOULD BE STARTING A BUNCH OF
NEW PROGRAMS WITH ON GOING MONEY
THAT'S JUST A RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
PRACTICE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE I
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS PART OF
THE PROCESS. AND THEN TO A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF THE RIGHT
OF THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISIONS
I BELIEVE IT'S TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR- THOSE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISIONS. PROVISIONS WOULD
CEASE TO EXIST. IS THAT ACCURATE
THAT'S A QUESTION FOR I DON'T
KNOW MAYBE. SOMEONE IN FINANCE.
IT DAN HAD OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO HE- THE CURRENT HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION OF THE
STUDENT SENATE FUNDING FORMULA
IS SET TO EXPIRE WITH THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. SO IT'S
CLEAR SAID THE LAST YEAR BE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
AND IS IT WAS A WITH THE TO
ELIMINATE THAT THAT SUNSET DATE
SO WHAT WE SET UP AS A CLIFF NOT
NECESSARILY A SLOPE. WHAT. HOLD
HARMLESS PROPOSAL SO DISTRICTS
WOULD THEN BE EITHER WERE ABLE
TO RECEIVE THEIR- ENTITLEMENT
UNDER THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA. OR THEIR TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE- FUNDING
LEVEL. AND SO THEY WOULD AT
LEAST BE ABLE TO RECEIVE WHAT
THEY RECEIVED IN THE PREVIOUS
YEAR- IT'S JUST THAT. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS ARE APPLIED TO THE
RATES UNDER THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA- DISTRICTS WOULD
STRUCTURE THIEF MORE UNDER THEIR
ENTITLEMENT UNDER THE SCF THAN
THEY WOULD UNDER THE FULL
PROMISE ABOUT. SO IT IS MORE OF
A GRADUAL SLOPE TO. ALL
DISTRICTS BEING MOVED TOWARDS
THE COURT- FUNDING COMPONENT OF
THE FUNDING FORMULA. OKAY I LOOK
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO. LEARNING
MORE MORE ABOUT HOW THAT IS A
SLOW. AND NOT A CLIFF FOR SOME
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS THE
STATE. BECAUSE AGAIN RESPONSIBLE
BUDGETING WE HAVE TO LET THESE
FOLKS KNOW. THAT THERE IS A
CHANGE COMING AND THEY NEED TO
BE PREPARED FOR AN ON THE K.
TWELVE SO EITHER TO PROPOSAL.
THE ROLLING THREE YEAR AVERAGE.
TO CREATE A SLOPE NOT
NECESSARILY A CLIFF FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
HAVE DECLINING ENROLLMENT. SO
AGAIN I LOOK FORWARD TO LEARNING
MORE ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL. SO I
CAN- HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HOW IT
IMPACTS. COMMUNITY. COLLEGES AND
WITH THAT THANK YOU. OKAY SO
MEMORY VIA DARTS. THANK YOU- SO
LIKE MOSTLY THINK BUSINESSES AND
FAMILIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE NATION I WOULD
ANTICIPATE ANTICIPATE THE ALL
THREE OF OUR SEGMENTS ARE GONNA
BE FACING HIGHER OPERATIONAL
COSTS- DUE TO INFLATION A THINK
THE LATEST IS THAT INFLATION IS
UP SEVEN PERCENT- WHICH IS THE
HIGHEST THE HIGHEST IT'S BEEN
SINCE I THINK I WAS TOO AND
WITHOUT SHARING MY AGE IT'S BEEN
MORE THAN A COUPLE OF DECADES-
ONGOING COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
NEGOTIATIONS- TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. YOU DO YOU THINK OF
THAT THE INCREASE IN BASE
REFLECTED IN THE BUDGET IS
SUFFICIENT TO COVER INFLATION
AND OTHER OPERATIONAL COSTS FOR
THIS SEGMENT I AM PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS. I ADD
JENNIFER AGREE WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- THE 5% AT THE BASE
AUGMENTATIONS FOR BOTH THE
UNIVERSITY AND THE CSU SYSTEMS.
ARE A PART OF THE AGREEMENT OF
THE MULTI YEAR PART CONTACT AND
IT IS A STARTING POINT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN WITH EACH BUDGETING
CYCLE. AND TO THE L. A. L. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO WEIGH IN ABOUT WHAT
WE SHOULD BE CONSIDERING DURING
THIS TIE ESPECIALLY GIVEN
INFLATION AND THE COST OF THE
SEGMENTS MAY FACE THIS YEAR.
YEAH YEAH IT'S AT THIRTEEN AND
IN YOUR SHOES I'M IN YOUR SHOES
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT THINGS ARE FACING
BECAUSE THE YOU HAVE MONEY BY
INFLATION IS. SEEMING TO SUCK A
LOT OF IT FROM YOUR BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS ARE FROM THE BUDGET
BEFORE YOU. AND YOU DON'T HAVE
THAT MANY OPTIONS. AND OTHER
THAN TO BE AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL IS I THINK INDICATING
EARLIER JUST TO BE CAREFUL.
ABOUT THE NEW PROGRAMS THAT YOU
CREATE SO THAT YOU CAN MAKE SURE
YOUR EXISTING PROGRAMS ARE WELL
SUPPORTED YOUR EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FACILITIES
ARE WELL SUPPORTED. BEFORE YOU
DECIDE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
CREATING NEW THINGS. YOU ALSO
ARE TRYING TO RESTORE TO PROTECT
YOURSELF MOVING FORWARD YOU
DON'T WANNA KNOW WHAT. WHETHER
INFLATION IS GOING TO BE
TEMPORARILY HIGH YOU DON'T KNOW
THE SLOPE AT WHICH WITH IT'LL
DECLINE IN SO YOU DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR HOLD. SO ALL THE MORE
REASON JUST TO BE CAUTIOUS IN
YOUR EXPANSION OF ONGOING
PROGRAMS AT THIS TIME IT'S SORT
OF LIKE THE BEST ADVICE THAT WE
CAN GO. I THOUGHT. THEY YOU'RE A
AND I AGREE. YOU KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEACH- AND AS I'M
LOOKING AT THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITIES SOME OF THESE ARE
REALLY GREAT PRIORITIES BUT
WHETHER IT'S NEW PROGRAMS- OR
SOME OF THESE GREAT PRIORITIES I
REALLY WANT TO. ASK MY
COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW FOR US TO
FOCUS THIS YEAR. THAT IT IS OUR
JOB IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
ALLOCATE FUNDING ALLOCATE
FUNDING- AND IF WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO MAKE TO PRIORITIZE
THINGS SO. OF ALL YEARS- THAT
THEIR MOST CRITICAL IN HIGHER
EDUCATION LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE SETTING THE PRIORITIES
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE. THANK
YOU I JUST WANT TO KNOW IF YOU
CAN ALL LOOK AT THE L. A. O.
PAGE EIGHT I AGREE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE BOTH SAYING. AND WE'LL
GET INTO IT WHEN WE GET OUR
REVENUES IN THE MAY. JUST CAME
OUT LAST OUR THAT LAST MONTH WE
HAD SIXTEEN BILLION ABOVE. FROM
WHAT'S IN THE JANUARY BUDGET SO
THERE'S GOING TO BE A- SURGE. IN
ONE TIME MONEY AND POTENTIALLY
SOME ONGOING FOR PROP NINETY
EIGHT. BUT THE MAJORITY OF THESE
ONE TIME THINGS. YES I'M I'M
SORRY THE MAJORITY THE SO CALLED
NEW PROGRAMS. ARE ONE TIME MONEY
SO WE REALLY CAN'T USE THAT ONE
TIME. TO BOOST UP THE CALL
ANYWAY I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL
HAVE AN INCREASE. PROP NINETY
EIGHT NUMBER WITH THAT.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE HE WILL
ROUGHLY 11% SPLIT WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO DO. AN INCREASE
ANYWAY. FOR THE CALYPSOSTBARTH
I'M COME HOPE FOR THE BY TIME WE
GET NEW REVENUE NUMBERS IN MAY.
WE CANNOT DO JUST WHAT WE'RE ALL
SAYING HERE RIGHT NOW. JOINT
MISSOURI I JUST WANNA CLARIFY
THAT THE PROGRAMS I WAS
REFERENCING. OUR PROGRAM FOR THE
ON GOING MONEY OKAY NOT A ONE
TIME MONEY SUCH AS I UNDERSTAND
THE DIFFERENCE IN. YEAH IN IN IN
AGAIN I'M GONNA MY CONCERNS. ARE
ABOUT ONGOING MONEY. THAT'S IT
OKAY LET'S HEAR NOW FROM OUR-
FROM OUR- MISTER KING. JUST ONE
QUICK QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE- I NOTICED YOU
MENTIONED- 50% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WILL BE IN PERSON IS
THERE A REASON. FOR THE 50%
VERSUS JUST HAVING THEM GO
COMPLETELY BACK IN PERSON. ON
EARTH OBVIOUSLY THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES MAY CHANGE THAT. IN
ORDER PART IN A FINANCE.
IMITATIONS PHOTOS REALLY
DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
HAVE A VARIETY OF OPTIONS WHEN
PURSUING- THEIR ENROLLMENT- WE
NOTICED THE SIGNIFICANT ROLE
WITH A CLIENT AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND SO D. D. CORE
ASPECT OF THE- ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IS REALLY TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS HAVE AVAILABLE
OPTIONS- AND I THINK. THAT'S
RIGHT ABOUT 50% IS TO TRY TO
MEET STUDENT DEMAND. GOT GOT IT
HAVE HAVE WE HEARD FROM STUDENTS
ARE DIFFERENT- COLLEGES THAT
THIS IS THE WAY THEY WANNA. THEY
WANT TO GO. THERE THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME- ATTEMPTS TO CONDUCT
SURVEYS OF STUDENTS GET
UNDERTAKEN BY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE I'D I DEFER TO STAFF AND
THAT THE CHANCE UP TO SPEAK MORE
TO THE RESULT OF THE SERVICE
BUT- I KNOW THAT HAPPENED TO.
GOT IT SO THAT THE THING THAT WE
COULD SAY FOR CANCER OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I GUESS I
WOULD JUST SAY I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT. OF THE THREE SEGMENTS NOT
THE ONE SEGMENT THAT HAS NOT.
COME BACK IN PERSON EVEN THOUGH
THE OTHER. INSTITUTIONS HAVE
FOUND A WAY TO BE BACK IN PERSON
THEY HAVE- THEY HAVE GONE BACK
TO ONLINE FOR A COUPLE WEEKS BUT
IN GENERAL HAVE BEEN BACK IN
PERSON SO I AM VERY CONCERNED
THAT THE COMMUTER CALL JUST
CONTINUES TO REMAIN THIS HIGH
PERCENTAGE. ON THROUGH DISTANCE
LEARNING AND I DO WONDER WHETHER
THAT'S THEM- KEEPING KEEPING
STUDENTS LESS MOTIVATED OR
KEEPING STUDENTS AWAY THANK YOU
. SOMEONE ARRESTS. AS A FOLLOW
UP TO YOUR TEAM'S QUESTION IT'S
CLEAR THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT HAS SUFFERED THE
GREATEST LOSS AND- SO PERHAPS.
THE THIS I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT REALLY NEEDS TO
BE VISITED- THE FACT THAT WE'RE
NOW GOING TO FIFTY PERCENT-
ONLINE. BUT I'M WONDERING IF
THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE
THAT THAT THAT BEEN
IDENTIFIED- THAT ARE CAUSING THE
DECREASE IN ENROLLMENT. BOTH AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND AT
CSU'S AND WHAT IT IS WE CAN DO
TO HELP IN THAT REGARD. MAYBE I
FELT THE SPONSOR JENNIFER PAJALA
AGAIN AT THE L. A. L. I'M I
THINK IT'S TRICKY AGAIN BECAUSE
ONE OF THE KEY FACTORS SEEMS TO
BE THE JOB MARKET AND THE JOB
MARKET IS REALLY COOL AND- SO
THAT IS A BEEN WE DON'T KNOW
AND- HOW COLLEGE IT NORMALLY WE
SEE DURING ECONOMIC RECOVERY IS
THAT COLLEGE ENROLLMENT
DECLINES. AND COLLEGES EVEN
BEFORE THAT TOWARD THE FINAL
YEARS OF THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
WERE ALREADY PATCHED HOLE IN. SO
IT IS THE- TO KNOW WHAT IS
WITHIN THE COLLEGES CONTROL TO
TRY TO INCREASE THEIR ENROLLMENT
LEVELS BECAUSE IT COULD BE THAT
JOBS ARE JUST VERY ATTRACTIVE
FOR THE POPULATION WHO
OTHERWISE. WOULD BE AND BUILDING
ON THE COLLEGE'S. AND WE ARE
ALSO TOLD THAT WHEN THE COLLEGES
HAD BEEN OFFERING THE SAME
COURSE IN PERSON ANDONLINE
THEIR WAIT LIST FOR THE ONLINE
ARE LONGER AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
OPENING UP MORE ONLINE. SO I
THINK SOME COLLEGES ARE TRYING
TO BE AS SENSITIVE TO STUDENT
DEMAND AS POSSIBLE. AND BECAUSE
COLLEGES GENERALLY ARE FACING
SUCH ENROLLMENT DECLINES ARE
STARTING TO BE MORE CREATIVE TO
TRY TO ATTRACT STUDENTS SO
THEY'RE STARTING TO DO SHORTER
TERMS FOR CERTAIN CLASSES SO
THAT MAYBE RATHER THAN A SIXTEEN
WEEK SEMESTER THEY MIGHT OFFER
SOMETHING FOR FOUR WEEKS. AND
THEY'RE STARTING TO DO THINGS
LIKE HAVE OPENED AN OPENING
DATES THAT AREN'T ALWAYS JUST
THE BEGINNING OF SEPTEMBER THE
BEGINNING OF JANUARY WHERE YOU
COULD ENROLL A MID TERM AND
STILL GET A CERTIFICATE OR
COURSE CREDIT. SO THERE. ON AT
LEAST SOME OF THEM ARE TRYING TO
BE CREATIVE- BUT WHETHER IT'S
GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO EVER GET
BACK TO PRE PANDEMICS IS VERY
UNCERTAIN. AND WHETHER 50% OR
80% OR 20% IN PERSON IT'S
PROBABLY GOING TO VERY BY THE
PROGRAM HOW MUCH HANDS ON WORK
IS TYPICALLY REQUIRED. STUDENTS
LEVEL OF INTEREST YOU CAN
IMAGINE VERY DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES FOR CULINARY ARTS AS
AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
IN ENGLISH OR MATHEMATICS. SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
COLLEGES DO HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO SURVEY THEIR
STUDENTS FIGURE OUT THEIR
INTEREST DEVELOPED THERE- COURSE
OFFERINGS ACCORDINGLY AND THAT
WE CAN RECOGNIZE IT THERE ARE.
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS WITHIN
COLLEGES CONTROL AND THEN THINGS
LIKE THAT JOB. MARKET THAT ARE
OUTSIDE THEIR CONTROL. THANK YOU
AND I DON'T THINK IT WAS MUCH TO
PUT BLAME ON ANY JUST TO WHAT IT
IS WE AS A STATE NEED TO DO. TO
HELP BECAUSE IT IS A PROBLEM
THIS DIDN'T DECLINE IN
ENROLLMENT AND BOTH CAMPUSES AND
BOTH- OKAY THE ISSUE AND THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SORRY FOR
INTERRUPTION- OKAY NOW NOW WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM OUR THREE
SEGMENTS WE'RE GONNA START WITH
MICHAEL DRAKE FROM THE UC UNTIL
PASTOR FROM C. U. N. N. E. LOW
ORTIZ OAKLEY FROM THEIR
COMMUNICATORS FROM HERE FROM ALL
OF THEM AND THEN- GOING TO
QUESTIONS AND- ISSUES FROM THE
MEMBERS. MISTER DRAKE ARE YOU
THERE. YES OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON
YEP IF YOU CAN HEAR ME AM I
CORRECT YES WE CAN'T THINK RIGHT
BUT OKAY GOOD TO SEE ALL. TEN
YEAH AGUIAR-CURRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY TO DISCUSS THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BUDGET. AT THREE
REFLECT ON TWO YEARS OF PANDEMIC
I'M REALLY PROUD OF OUR STUDENTS
OUR FACULTY. AND OUR STAFF FOR
THEIR STEADFAST EFFORTS TO KEEP
THE UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY SAFE.
AS WE CONTINUE TO OFFER THE
CALIBER OF EDUCATION PATIENT
CARE AND RESEARCH THAT WE ALL
EXPECT. DESPITE THE CHALLENGES
POSED BY COVER THE UNIVERSITY OF
MAINTAINED ITS EXCELLENCE IN
TEACHING. BY CONTINUING TO OFFER
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. FOR FALL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE UNIVERSITY
RECEIVED THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
UNDERGRADUATE APPLICANTS
ARTISTRY AND ADMIT OUR MOST
DIVERSE FRESHMAN CLASS EVER.
ADDITIONAL UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH SAID ARTS
CENTER'S EXHIBIT EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORT AND CARING FOR PATIENTS
PROVIDING VACCINES AND
CONDUCTING BASIC AND CLINICAL
RESEARCH THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
. HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND
RESEARCHERS HAVE BEEN AND ARE
TODAY ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE
GLOBAL CRISIS THAT WORK HAS
SAVED LIVES. I WANT TO THANK
THEM FOR THEIR DEDICATION AND
PERSEVERANCE. WE RATE IN THIS
GOOD WORK BY YOU THE LEGISLATURE
AND OUR OTHER PARTNERS AND I
APPRECIATE THE CRITICAL SUPPORT
THAT YOU'RE PROVIDED. TURNING
NOW TO THE COMING YEAR AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE
COLLECTIVELY. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES TO ACHIEVE A BUDGET
THAT PROVIDES THE CRITICAL
RESOURCES WE NEED. TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF
PREDICTABLY EVERY PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE. WE ALSO WANT TO IMPROVE
OUR ABILITY TO TACKLE TOUGH
ISSUES. LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS INCLUDING
HOUSING. THE SUPPORT TO PROVIDE
UNIVERSAL CALIFORNIA ENABLES US
TO IN TURN TO STRENGTHEN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THROUGH OUR
TEACHING RESEARCH SERVICE AND
PATIENT CARE. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND PRODUCTION IS AN
IMPORTANT AND APPRECIATED STEP
IN THIS PROCESS. WE BELIEVE IT
ADDRESS THIS CRITICAL RESOURCE
NEEDS AND ALSO REFLECTS OUR
SHARED VALUES WHEN IT COMES TO
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
IMPORTANTLY THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET PRODUCTIONS WELCOME NEWS
FOR ACCESS AND EQUITY. THE
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE UNIVERSAL
WITH 5% INCREASES ANNUALLY FOR
FIVE YEARS OFFICE BUDGET
STABILITY AND RELIABLE SUPPORT
THAT WILL BENEFIT OUR STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. AS WELL AS
OUR FACULTY AND RESEARCHERS. THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES
MUCH NEEDED ONE MOMENT FUNDING
FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. BY
SUPPORTING THESE INVESTMENTS YOU
CAN HELP US MAKE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN ACHIEVING OUR SHARED
GOALS. INCLUDING GROWING
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT EXPANDING GRADUATE
EDUCATION. ELIMINATING GAPS IN
GRADUATION RATES FOR STUDENTS
FROM DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS.
IN THE HANDS IN COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY FOR FAMILIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THIS BUDGET
IS A CRITICAL BOOST NOT ONLY FOR
ACCESS AND EQUITY BUT ALSO FOR
OUR ENVIRONMENT. I DON'T THINK
AND UNIVERSITIES UNIQUE
CAPABILITIES TO MEET THE STATE'S
GOALS FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCY WE
CAN REALLY TAKE A BOLD STEP
FORWARD AND THIS IN THIS ARENA.
WE BELIEVE THESE PRIORITIES
REFLECT OUR SHARED COMMITMENT TO
EXPANDING THE IMPACT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ON THE
LIVES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS. LET
ME FIRST TURN TO ACCESS AND
EQUITY. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS TO ENROLL
DURING THE PANDEMIC ARE ABLE TO
SUCCEED. WE WANT TO PARTNER WITH
YOU TO DELIVER EXCELLENCE THAT
OUR STUDENTS DESERVE. THE BUDGET
MAKE MEANINGFUL PROGRESS TOWARD
CLOSING GRADUATION GAPS ENSURING
THAT YOU SEE STUDENTS WILL
THRIVE AND CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY
. UNIVERSITY WANTS TO EXPAND
ACCESS BY INCREASING ENROLLMENT
BY TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS BY
THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY. THAT IS
THE EQUIVALENT OF ADDING AN
ENTIRELY NEW MIDSIZE UC CAMPUS
OVER THIS DECADE. THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE BUDGET REFLECTS
ALIGNMENT WITH THIS GOAL. BY
SUPPORTING ECONOMIC GROWTH OF
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES AND
REPLACING NONRESIDENT STUDENTS
WITH RESIDENT STUDENTS AT THREE
OF OUR AMPUSES WHAT THE HIGHEST
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT. THIS
MOMENT GROWTH ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT
THE UNIVERSITY IN FUTURE YEARS
WITH 1% ANNUAL ENROLLMENT
GROWTH. WILL HELP THE UNIVERSITY
ACHIEVE THE AMBITIOUS GOAL OF
TWENTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS BY TWENTY THIRTY. AND
ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY TO PRODUCE
A NEW DEGREE AS OUR STATE'S
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY ECONOMY
REQUIRES. UNIVERSITY IS
COMMITTED TO ACHIEVING THE
SHARED GOAL WITH THE STATE.
HOWEVER IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THERE ARE SOME FACTORS THAT
ARE NOT IN OUR CONTROL THAT.
COULD IMPACT OUR PLANNING. FOR
INSTANCE YOU MAY HAVE HEARD WE
ARE CURRENTLY ENGAGED IN
LITIGATION AT THE UC BERKELEY
CAMPUS THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
CAMPUS TO DECREASE ITS
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT. ABOUT
FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER STUDENTS
FOR FALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND
LIMIT OUR ABILITY TO EFFECTIVELY
MANAGE THE CAMPUS'S ENROLLMENT
IN COMING YEARS. EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS CASE COULD
IMPACT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. WOULD BE A
NIGHT THE NIGHT ACCESS TO ARE
YOU SEE EDUCATION. UNIVERSITY
WILL CONTINUE ASSESSING THESE
MATTERS EXPLORING EVERY POSSIBLE
OPTION TO PROTECT STUDENT
ENROLLMENTS AT UC. I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
HOW WE CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS AND EXPAND ACCESS.
AT THE SAME TIME. THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL INCLUDES SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FOR STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. ARE CURRENTLY GRADUATED
NOTICEABLY LOWER RATES THAN
OTHER STUDENTS. SUPPORT FOR THE
COUPON JUST GIVE ME SUPPORT FOR
THESE FUNDS. WILL HELP IS VERY
WORTHY STUDENTS SUCCEED THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. ACCESS
WITHOUT AFFORDABILITY THAT'S NOT
TRUE ACCESS. YOU SEE STUDENTS
BENEFIT GREATLY FROM THE STATE'S
TRULY EXCELLENT CAL GRANTS
PROGRAM AND AS YOU KNOW THE
UNIVERSITY PROVIDES AN EXCELLENT
NEED BASED FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM
FOR STUDENTS. THIS TOGETHER WITH
PELL GRANT AND OTHER TYPES OF
EIGHT. MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO ENSURE THAT FULLY
55% OF CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS HAVE THEIR TUITION
FULLY COVERED. BUT THERE'S MORE
THAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE FURTHER
STRIDES TOWARD A DEBT FREE
EDUCATION BY THE TWENTY TWENTY
TIME FRAME AVAILABLE.
UNIVERSITIES BUT GOD HELPING
PLANS TOWARD THIS GOAL AND IS
GREATLY ASSISTED BY RECENT
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM. AND LEGISLATIVE ACTION
THAT DEFINES DEBT FREE AT A
LEVEL OF STUDENT CONTRIBUTION
THAT COULD BE MET WITH PART TIME
WORK. EARLIER I REFERENCED THE
UNIVERSITY UNIQUE ABILITY TO
HELP ADDRESS THE EXISTENTIAL
THREAT OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
PREVIOUS EFFORTS BY THE
UNIVERSITY AVE POSITIONED US TO
PLAY A KEY ROLE IN THIS FIGHT.
THE TIME IS NOW TO BUILD ON
THOSE PAST SUCCESSES AND
SUPERCHARGE THESE EFFORTS. THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDES A
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE UNIVERSITY TO
LEVERAGE OUR INTELLECTUAL
LOGISTICAL AND PHYSICAL ASSETS
TO HELP THE STATE CHEAP GOALS OF
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND CLIMATE
RELATED WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
UNIVERSITY IS READY TO PARTNER
WITH THE STATE ON SIGNIFICANT
ACTION. INCLUDING NEW
INITIATIVES THAT CAN ASSIST ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IN RELATED TO AND
THE UNIVERSITY FUELS CHOOSE ALL
OF OUR ACTIVITY. INCLUDING
ADDRESSING FACILITIES NEEDS
THREE CLIMATE LANCE. SO ANY
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY'S EXTENSIVE BACKLOG
OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
CRITICAL LIFE SAFETY PROJECTS.
BUT NOT ONLY A NECESSITY BUT
ALSO OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS AN
INCREASE OUR ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
AS PART OF A PATH TOWARD FULL
CARBON NEUTRALITY AND ULTIMATELY
DECARBONISATION. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN THESE
EFFORTS AND FOR YOUR INTEREST IN
DISCUSSING OUR PRIORITIES AND
CHALLENGES LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE COMING
MONTHS DEVELOP A BUDGET THAT
SUPPORT HIGHER EDUCATION. LIVES
UP OUR STUDENTS AND ALLOWS THE
UNIVERSITY TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUR PRESIDENT DRAKE
WILL COME BACK TO YOU AFTER THE
OTHER TWO- MISTER CASTRO ARE YOU
THERE. YES I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE PROCEED. SURE MCCARTY
AND MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH OU TODAY. ALONG WITH
MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES REGARDING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITIES FISCAL NEEDS. I
WANT TO BEGIN BY EXPRESSING MY
GRATITUDE FOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
FORWARD THINKING BUDGET
PROPOSAL. WORKERS SPECIALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF ITS PROPOSED
MULTI YEAR CONTRACT WHICH WILL
PROVIDE A RECURRING GENERAL FUND
INCREASE OF AT LEAST 5% EACH
YEAR THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN. IN RECOGNITION OF
THE CSU'S CONTINUED COMMITMENT
TOWARD ACHIEVING A NUMBER OF
LONG STANDING STUDENT FOCUSED
GOALS. EXPANDING ACCESS
ADVANCING EDUCATIONAL EQUITY AND
ENHANCING STUDENT SUCCESS. WHEN
I MIGHT JUST MENTION THAT IT'S A
5% INCREASE IN OUR GENERAL FUND
AND- AND SO WHEN YOU INCLUDE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A TUITION AS
PART OF OUR BUDGET. THAT ENDS UP
BEING ABOUT A TWO POINT 85%
INCREASE FOR US. WE THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR THIS PROPOSED
INVESTMENT WHICH REFLECTS HIS
STRONG BELIEF IN OUR MISSION AND
OUR WORK. AND HIS UNDERSTANDING
OF OUR NEED FOR A SUSTAINABLE
PREDICTABLE FISCAL FRAMEWORK.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED COMPACT WHICH GIVES THE
CSU A MUCH NEEDED SAFETY NET TO
PROTECT THE UNIVERSITY AGAINST
ECONOMIC FLUCTUATION OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. A SAFETY NET
THAT EXTENDS TO OUR STUDENTS. IN
FACT BASED LARGELY UPON THE
COMPACT I ANNOUNCED LAST MONTH
THAT BARRING UNFORESEEN CHANGES
TO OUR FISCAL OUTLOOK THE CSU
WOULD NOT RAISE TUITION. FOR THE
UPCOMING ACADEMIC YEAR. HOWEVER
WELL I AM PLEASED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL IT DOES LEAVE
UNADDRESSED A NUMBER OF CRITICAL
NEEDS AND PRIORITIES. AND I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE WORK WITH US IN
TIMES SUCH AS THESE TIMES WHEN
RESOURCES ARE ABUNDANT. AND
NEEDS ARE GREAT TO INVEST
ADDITIONAL RECURRING AND ONE
TIME FUNDS SO THAT WE CAN MEET
THESE KEY PRIORITIES.
SPECIFICALLY WE SEEK THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO BE ADDED TO THE C. S.
USE BATES BUDGET. WHILE OUR
FLAGSHIP STUDENT SCCESS AFTER
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE CONTINUES TO DELIVER
AN UNPARALLELED RETURN ON THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT WITH
GRADUATION RATES CURRENTLY AT
ALL TIME HIGHS FOR STUDENTS FROM
ALL BACKGROUNDS. THESE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL ALLOW
US TO BE EVEN A TO DO EVEN MORE
TO CLOSE PERSISTENT EQUITY GAPS
FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR. LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS. ARE EQUITY
ACTION PLAN WILL NOT ONLY
ELEVATE THE LIVES OF STUDENTS OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS RACES
ETHNICITIES ABILITIES AND
IDENTITIES IT WILL ALSO HELP US
CREATE A HIGHLY SKILLED DIVERSE
WORKFORCE THAT REFLECTSALL OF
CALIFORNIA. AND TAKES FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THE DYNAMICALLY
DIVERSE TALENTS PERSPECTIVES AND
SKILLS OF ALL OF OUR STATES
COMMUNITIES. THESE ADDITIONAL
RECURRING FUNDS WILL ALSO HELP
US EARLY COMPENSATE OUR FIFTY
SIX THOUSAND VALUED EMPLOYEES
WHO HAVE SO ABLY CREATIVELY
INSTEAD ONLY INSURED THE FORWARD
PROGRESS OF OUR STUDENTS THROUGH
THESE UNPRECEDENTED TIMES. THANK
YOU MAY I KNOW THE UNIVERSITY
FACES SIGNIFICANT COMPENSATION
COSTS FOR THE SALARY INCREASES
WE'VE NEGOTIATED AS PART OF THE
RECENTLY APPROVED SUCCESSOR
CONTRACT WITH OUR FACULTY UNION
AND FOR SALARY INCREASES WE
ANTICIPATE TO COME. FOR
REPRESENTED AND NON REPRESENTED
STAFF AND SUPERVISORS WE ARE
CURRENTLY CONDUCTING A NON
FACULTY STAFF SALARY STUDY THAT
WILL INFORM BOTH OUR UPCOMING
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS AS WELL AS
AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING REQUEST
LATER THIS SPRING. BY INVESTING
BOLDLY IN THE CSU YOU HELP US TO
RECRUIT RETAIN AND FAIRLY
COMPENSATE THE TALENTED AND
MISSION DRIVEN FACULTY AND
STAFF. THAT ARE SO ESSENTIAL TO
OUR STUDENTS SUCCESS. WE ALSO
ASKED FOR NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING TO
GIVE OUR STUDENTS THE SAFE
MODERN AND SUSTAINABLE
FACILITIES THEY DESERVE. AND TO
HELP US BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE
IDENTIFIED NEED OF SIXTEEN POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
ACADEMIC FACILITIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND THE
CSU'S CURRENT BACKLOG OF FIVE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
DEFERRED RENEWAL PROJECTS. AS
FACILITY NEEDS EXIST ON EACH OF
OUR TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES AND
THEY RANGE FROM DECADES OLD LAB
SPACES TO ANTIQUATED CLASSROOM
SETTINGS THAT DETRACT FROM OUR
STUDENTS LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
SHARE MCCARTY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AS WE CONTINUE TO EMERGE
FROM THE EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGES OF THE PAST TWO
YEARS. AND WITH OUR STATE IN A
STRONG FINANCIAL POSITION. CSU
STANDS READY TO DO MORE.
TOGETHER I BELIEVE WE MUST DO
MORE FOR OUR TALENTED AND
DIVERSE STUDENTS FOR OUR
REMARKABLE FACULTY AND STAFF AND
FOR THE GOLDEN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
THIS AFTERNOON. PLEASE KNOW THAT
I'M ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO DISCUSS
HOW THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY CAN BE A RESOURCE TO
YOU AS YOU CONTINUE TO EXPLORE
WAYS TO DEVELOP CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE SUPPORT PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION AND TACKLE THE
CRITICAL ISSUES. CURRENTLY
FACING OUR GREAT STATE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHANCELLOR CASTRO
AT NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
CHANCELLOR ORTIZ OAKLEY. ARE YOU
THERE. I AM HERE YES PLEASE
PRESS THAT AFTERNOON AND THAT.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON AND HAPPY NEW
YEAR CHORE MCCARTY AND MEMBERS
OF THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FINANCED TO PLEASURE
TO BE HERE THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
THE WORK AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY COLLEAGUES
IN PARK RIDGE BUT YES YOU'RE THE
SEE. HERE TODAY. FOR I CAN INTO
A DISCUSSION OF THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET PROPOSAL I
WANT TO SHARE. SOME EXCITING
FINDINGS ABOUT THE IMPACT OF OUR
SYTEM RECENTLY. WE RELEASED A
TIMELY REPORT WITH DATA. THAT
FOR THE FIRST TIME ILLUMINATES
ENORMOUS VALUE OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AT THAT THE
VALUE THAT IT BRINGS TO OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY. OR QUANTIFIED
CIRCLE IMPACT OF OUR COLLEGES
AND REINFORCES THE HARD WORK OF
OUR FACULTY OF OUR STAFF AND OF
COURSE OF COURSE STUDENTS. AS
THEY ARE AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
THE STATE'S ECONOMY. CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE HAD AN
ANNUAL ECONOMIC IMPACT OF MORE
THAN A HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS. WHICH IS EQUAL
TO APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT 2%
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL GROSS
STATE PRODUCT. FOUR HUNDRED
SIXTEEN COLLEGES ARE AMONG THE
STATE'S LARGEST EMPLOYERS. WITH
MORE THAN NINETY ONE THOUSAND
FULL TIME AND PART TIME FACULTY
AND STAFF- BUT THE ECONOMIC AND-
IMPACT IN THE BENEFITS OF OUR
SYSTEM EXTENDS MUCH FURTHER.
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PROVIDES ABOUT TO FULL RETURN ON
INVESTMENT FOR OUR TAXPAYERS.
FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT ON
EDUCATING STUDENTS ATTENDING OUR
COLLEGES THE PUBLIC WILL RECEIVE
AN AVERAGE OF TWO DOLLARS AND
TEN CENTS IN RETURN OVER THE
COURSE OF STUDENTS WORKING LIFE
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR EVERY
DOLLAR INVESTED. STUDENTS WILL
GAIN FIVE DOLLARS AND FUTURE
EARNINGS. THAT SUM TOTAL OF
SOCIAL SAVINGS COMBINED WITH
STUDENTS INCREASE FUTURE INCOME
COMES TO AN ESTIMATE ESTIMATED.
TWO POINT SIX TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. SO THE
PRIMARY TAKEAWAYS ITS CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN OUR COLLEGES MEANS
INCREASED SUCCESS FOR MILLIONS
OF STUDENTS. WHO WILL IN TURN BE
HIGHLY VALUED AND ESSENTIAL PART
OF CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. WE
PROVIDE YOU A COPY OF THE REPORT
AND I HOPE YOU GET A CHANCE TO
REVIEW IT WHEN YOU GET AN
OPPORTUNITY. I'LL NOW TURN MY
FOCUS- TO THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUDGET
PRIORITIES I WANT TO BEGIN. BY
THANKING ALL OF YOU- THANKING
EVERYONE IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR
HELPING LAY THE FOUNDATION FOR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY JUST A YEAR
AGO OUR COLLEGES WERE SHELTERING
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN DEFERRALS. AND NOW WE ARE
PRESENTED WITH THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO ADVANCE AN EQUITABLE RECOVERY
FOR CALIFORNIA. WE'RE PROUD TO
TODAY'S COLLEGE POPULATION LOOKS
LIKE AND REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA
IN FACT. 64% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ENROLLEES OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR
. AND MORE THAN 40% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OR OLDER. IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE PLACED A GREATER FOCUS ON
HOW TO REACH THE POSTER
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS THIS FALL.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE VISITED
EIGHT OF OUR COLLEGES TO LISTEN
TO AND HEAR DIRECTLY FROM OUR
STUDENTS ABOUT THEIR NEEDS. WHAT
ONE STUDENT IN PARTICULAR ARE
FROM SAN DIEGO COLLEGE MONIQUE
SHARE THE FOLLOWING WITH US.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE THE ONLY
SAFETY NET AVAILABLE FOR
INDIVIDUALS LIKE ME WHO HAVE
BEEN FAILED BY OUR SYSTEM. OUR
WORK IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS CHALLENGING BUT IT'S
CRITICAL. AND WE ASK OUR STATE
LEADERS TO REMAIN OUR STEADFAST
PARTNERS SO THAT WE DON'T LOSE
ANY MOMENTUM. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ROAD MAP FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SETS FORTH A
BOLD NEW VISION FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AS A LEVER FOR
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND AS A
MEANS TO CLOSE STUBBORN EQUITY
GAPS IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
FRAMEWORK BUILDS UPON THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS VISION FOR SUCCESS
GOALS IT CREATES NEW AVENUES FOR
DATA SHARING ACROSS WITH THE
COLLABORATION AND FUNDS
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR BOTH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND OUR
SYSTEM. WITH A CLEAR EMPHASIS ON
CLOSING RACIAL EQUITY GAPS AND
ADVANCING STUDENT SUCCESS THIS
IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR GOALS IN
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS AND IT'S
A VALIDATION OF THE WORK WE HAVE
BEEN PRIORITIZING FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. THE GOVERNOR AGAIN
HIGHLIGHTS ITS COMMITMENT TO THE
STUDENT CENTER FUNDING FORMULA.
OATES'S MINIMUM FUNDING LEVELS
FOR A DISTRICTS SOMETHING THAT
MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR. THE STUDENT CENTER
FROM FUNDING FORMULA IS A KEY
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO AN
EQUITABLE RECOVERY AND
ESPECIALLY IN THIS TIME OF
DECLINING ENROLLMENT. IT'S
CREATED A FORM OF STABILITY FOR
COLLEGE. FURTHER THE DRIVING
TENANTS OF THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA ACCESS EQUITY
AND SUCCESS ARE MORE RELEVANT
THAN EVER. IN OUR REMINDER THAT
OUR STUDENTS NEEDS AND SUCCESS
MUST COME FIRST. DURING THE
PANDEMIC. NATIONAL DECLINES IN
ENROLLMENT HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCED. BY COLLEGES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AS WELL
HERE'S CALIFORNIA. ONLY DURING
MY TIME- SUPPORTING- ARE-
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION MAKO
CARDONA. I GOT TO SEE FIRSTHAND
THE DECLINES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AND THEY ARE TROUBLING
IT'S BEEN POINTED OUT BY
MEMBERS. OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. UP
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SERVE THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS AND ADULT LEARNERS. SO
THE PROPOSED A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME PER
STUDENT RETENTION ENROLLMENT
EFFORTS ARE TIMELY AND NECESSARY
AND THEY WILL. ENABLE OUR
COLLEGES TO DO. MARKET
STRATEGIES TO ENGAGE OUR
STUDENTS WHO MAY HAVE WITHDRAWN
DUE TO THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC AND TO CONNECT WITH
CALIFORNIANS WHO MAY BE
HESITATING TO ENROLL IN A
COLLEGE. THIS PROPOSAL
RECOGNIZES THAT OUR ENROLLMENT
EFFORTS MUST ALSO INCLUDE A DEEP
LOOK AT OUR ACADEMIC PATHWAYS.
WE SUPPORT INVESTMENTS IN
STREAMLINED ACADEMIC PATHWAYS
SUCH AS COMMON COURSE NUMBER
RAIN TRANSFER. AND THE ADDED
MOMENTUM TO THE EFFORTS TO
STRENGTHEN RETENTION AND TO
SUPPORT TEACHER TRAINING. WE'RE
ALSO PLEASED TO SEE A ROBUST
INVESTMENT IN PART TIME FACULTY
- PREVIOUSLY HAD ONLY FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND WE HAVE
BEEN UNDER INVESTING IN THE
HEALTH OF OUR PART TIME FACTOR.
WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE FOR OUR FACULTY THIS
INVESTMENT IS LONG OVERDUE. AND
WE BELIEVE IT IS ESSENTIAL. AS
WE ENTER THE SECOND YEAR THE
PANDEMIC. WE NEED TO EMBRACE THE
LESSONS AND THE OPPORTUNITIES OF
THIS PANDEMIC AND RECOGNIZE THE
COLLEGE'S FACULTY AND STUDENTS
WILL NEED TO LEVERAGE TECHNOLOGY
TO INCREASE ACCESS. AND TO
CONTINUE TO INNOVATE IN AND OUT
OF THE CLASSROOM. NOW I KNOW
THAT THERE WILL LIKELY BE
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHERE WE'RE AT
IN TERMS OF ONLINE INSTRUCTION.
THE ONE THING THAT WE HAVE
LEARNED ABOUT THIS PANDEMIC IS
BY IMPLEMENTING QUALITY
TECHNOLOGIES AND SUPPORTING OUR
FACULTY WE CAN CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE OUR STUDENTS. EVEN
THROUGHOUT THIS CRISIS. THE
SEVERITY OF OUR NEEDS CONTINUES
TO INCREASE IN THE AREA OF
TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT JUST IN THIS
LAST FEW DAYS WE'VE HAD ANOTHER
CYBER SECURITY ATTACK ON ONE OF
OUR COLLEGES SO FUNDING THIS
AREA THIS AREA OF TECHNOLOGY
RESOURCES IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW TO OUR
COLLEGE AND MODERNIZING OUR
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURES SUCH
AS SIXTY THREE APPLYING IT'S
CRITICAL TO ENSURE FACULTY AND
STUDENTS SENSITIVE DATA ARE
PROTECTED FROM THESE ATTACKS. A
SPECIFIC IMPORTANCE TO THEIR
CALIFORNIA'S A RECOVERY IS THE
ABILITY OF THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE TO ADVANCE EQUITABLE
EDUCATIONAL REFORMS AND
WORKFORCE PATHWAYS TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS RECOVER DR. BUT I
BECAME CHANCELLOR IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN. BOB MY OFFICE
HAD A HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS ADDED
MINISTER SEVENTY ONE PROGRAMS I
REALLY APPRECIATE MY FAVORITE
SIMPLY MEMBER FROM LONG BEACH
BRINGING UP THIS ISSUE. BUT WHEN
I BECAME CHANCELLOR WE HAD
SEVENTY ONE PROGRAMS TODAY OUR
OFFICE ADMINISTERS A HUNDRED
FIVE PROGRAMS WITH ONLY FIVE
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND WHEN THE
PANDEMIC STARTED 10% OF OUR
STAFF WERE REDIRECTED TO STATE
EMERGENCY SUPPORT AND OUR AGENCY
LIKE ALL OF THE OTHER AGENCIES
ALSO HAD TO ACHIEVE FIVE
PERCENT. SAVINGS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO THE PROPOSED
POSITIONS FOR THIS OFFICE ARE
MUCH APPRECIATED AND ARE NEEDED
TO CONTINUE TO BETTER SERVE OUR
COLLEGES AND OUR STUDENTS LASTLY
WE CONSIDER THE FINAL TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE SPENDING PLAN I
URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO PURSUE
SOLUTIONS THAT REPRESENT THE
TRUE TRUE COST OR THE TOTAL COST
OF SUCCESS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS I THINK- MEMBER MCCARTY
AND ALL OF YOU FOR THE EFFORTS
THAT YOU HAVE MADE TO HELP. FUND
THE TOTAL COST OF EDUCATION FOR
OUR STUDENTS WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO PUSH FORWARD- AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE GREATER
INVESTMENTS IN OUR STUDENTS. WHO
NEED IT RIGHT NOW THE MOST
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREAS OF
HOUSING INSECURITY MENTAL HEALTH
AND FOOD AND SECURITY ADDRESSING
THE TRIP COST OF COLLEGE WILL
HELP OUR STUDENTS THRIVE. AND IN
TURN HELP OUR STATE. SIXTY
EIGHT. I'LL CLOSE BY EMPHASIZING
THAT THIS MOMENT CALLS. FOR US
TO LEVERAGE TE RESOURCES
PRESENTED IN THIS BUDGET TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS AND WITH
URGENCY THAT THEY EXPECT FROM
US. WE REMAIN FOCUSED ON KEEPING
STUDENTS ON THEIR SUCCESSFUL
JOURNEYS AND MAKING SURE THAT IT
CONTINUES TO BE THE NORTH STAR
OF OUR WORK. THANK YOU TO ALL OF
YOU FOR YOUR ONGOING PARTNERSHIP
AND SUPPORT AND I LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH YOU THROUGHOUT
THE REST OF THIS BUDGET YEAR.
OKAY THANK YOU- LET ME ASK THE
FIRST QUESTION TO MR MR TEAM ONE
AND HE HAD THE HE HAD TO LEAVE
THE HEARING BUT WHEN WE ASK ALL
THREE OF YOU. TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF- GETTING BACK TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AND I KNOW
ITS- FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MORE SEVEN ISSUE THE UC AND CSU
BUT- PERSONALLY YES THINGS ARE
CHANGING WE'RE SEEING THE
NATIONAL DEBATE RIGHT NOW WITH
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS. SO WHERE ARE
YOU IN OUR PLANS TO GET TWO MORE
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. SURE I'D
BE HAPPY TO BEGIN- A CHARMER
CARTY THIS IS- I KNOW I'M GOING
ISSUE THAT ALL OF OUR HUNDRED
SIXTEEN COLLEGES ARE DEALING
WITH AT THIS BEEN REPRESENTED.
ALREADY OUR STUDENTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
HAVE BEEN HIT HARD BY THIS
PANDEMIC- THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET- THERE- LOOKING
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
AND WE ARE CONTINUING TO BE AS
FLEXIBLE AS WE POSSIBLY CAN IN
ORDER TO MEET THEIR NEEDS. WE
FULLY WANT TO ENGAGE OUR
STUDENTS. IN PERSON IN OUR
COLLEGES ARE WORKING HARD WITH
OUR LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN OPEN UP
MARKETS OUR CAMPUSES. IN THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF STATE
MANNER AND ALSO WORKING WITH OUR
FACULTY AND STAFF- RIGHT NOW WE
ARE- APPROXIMATELY 60% IN PERSON
- WE HAD HOPED TO BE- A LITTLE
GREATER THAN THAT- BEFORE THE-
MAKRAN VIRUS YET. BUT YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT HAD AN IMPACT ON
OUR- SPRING SEMESTER. BUT LET ME
ALSO SAY THIS WE ARE VERY
SENSITIVE TO STUDENT DEMANDS- WE
HAVE CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF
STUDENTS. ABOUT A 60% OF OUR
STUDENTS- BURKE SHOULD BE ABOUT
HALF OF OUR STUDENTS 50% OUR
ASKING FOR A HYBRID SOLUTIONS
THAT MEANS- IT PERSON AND ONLINE
I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE DEMANDING US
PRESS TO PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
FLEXIBILITY AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO PROVIDE THAT
FLEXIBILITY- AND- THIS IS EVEN
HIGHER FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
LATINO STUDENTS- SO WE'RE
PARTICULARLY SENSITIVE TO. OUR
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND OUR LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS- AND AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE- MANY OF OUR PARENTS- SO
THEY'RE WAITING FOR THEIR
SCHOOLS. TO BE COMPLETELY IN
PERSON AS WELL CHILD CARE IS A
BIG ISSUE FOR OUR STUDENTS. SO I
DO FEEL THAT WE ARE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THAT MRE
MORE STUDENTS ARE CHOOSING- IN
PERSON OPTION IN OUR COLLEGES
ARE ANXIOUS. TO ENGAGE THEM IN
PERSON HOWEVER THERE WILL BE
CONTINUED DEMAND. FOR AS MUCH AS
MUCH FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE AS
LONG AS WE CONTINUE TO FEEL THE
EFFECTS OF THIS PANDEMIC. OKAY
THE UC AND CSU. DOT ORG I CAN
GAGO NEXT THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND SAY THAT- OUR SCHOOLS ARE
THAT. IF THE TWO THINGS FAR ARE
HOSPITAL'S ART AND ART GRADUATE
FROM- THAT PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS
RELATED HEALTH SCIENCES HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN IN PERSON OUT
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE- PANDEMICS
ARE PART OF OUR ENTERPRISES BEEN
OPEN IN FACT WORKING THAT OUT
EVEN THOUGH A BURNING THE
MIDNIGHT OIL REALLY SENT- ABOUT
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PANDEMIC
OUR UNDERGRADUATE CAMPUSES ARE-
THEY CHANGE THEY VERY A BIT BUT
THEY RANGE BETWEEN ABOUT 858285%
NINETY SEVEN PERCENT. IN PERSON
AS WE SPEAK- AND THAT'S- THAT
DEPENDING ON VARIOUS LOCAL
FACTORS SO OVERWHELMINGLY THEY
HAVE RETURNED DO IN PERSON- IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AS YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A LARGE RESIDENTIAL MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS LIVE ON CAMPUS
AND SO. IT THAT THEY'RE THERE AT
THE CAMPUS ALREADY IN BEING IN
PERSON DOESN'T REQUIRE TRAVELING
AND THAT THEY HAVE RETURNED
LARGELY TO IT IN PERSON CLASS WE
DO HAVE. ON ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES
OF MUCH GREATER FRACTION OF
INSTRUCTION AVAILABLE. AS
VIRTUAL INSTRUCTION EVEN THOUGH
STUDENTS ARE LIVING ON CAMPUS
THEY MAY BE IN THE DORM BUT A
WHOLE SERIES OF CLASSES ARE
PROVIDED ARE BEING PRESENTED IN
AN ONLINE FASHION AND MANY MORE
THAN WITH THE THAT WERE THE CASE
TWO YEARS AGO AND AS WE LOOK
TOWARD THE FUTURE THAT SET AN
ACTIVE AREA OF EVOLUTION. FOR
OUR FACULTY WE ARE SURE THAT THE
NUMBER OF ONLINE COURSES
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS. AS IS THE
CASE TODAY TE ONLINE THE-
NUMBER OF COURSES NUMBER OF
ONLINECOURSES AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS AT THAT THAT THIS YEAR
NEXT YEAR THE YEAR THEREAFTER
WILL INCREASE UNTIL WE'RE AT A
PLACE WHERE THERE'S A GOOD
BALANCE BETWEEN. THE ONLINE AND
IN PERSON. BUT BUT AS WE NOW TO
BUY EIGHTY FIVE. EIGHTY FIVE TO
NINETY SEVEN PER ARE A PERSON WE
SPEAK. OKAY THANK YOU NEXT. YES
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY- FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY-
THERE THERE IS A SOME
DIFFERENCES BY CAMPUS BUT ON THE
HIGH SIDE IT'S ABOUT 85% AND ON
THE LOWER SIDE ABOUT 70% IN
PERSON- WE ARE VERY MUCH STUDENT
FOCUSED AND- AT EACH CAMPUS
THEY'VE WORKED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING WHAT WE CAN TO
SUPPORT THERE'S SUCCESS. AND AS
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED-
SOME STUDENTS ACTUALLY PREFER
ONLINE EDUCATION OR PREFER A
HYBRID OPPORTUNITIES SO WE'RE
TRYING TO BE AS THOUGHTFUL ABOUT
THIS IS WE CAN GOING FORWARD AND
AT THE SAME TIME WE KNOW THAT-
MOST STUDENTS REALLY WANT TO BE
ON THE CAMPUSES AND- WE'VE BEEN
AS- SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN. OKAY THANK YOU
WELL IT CERTAINLY ARE- OUR
DESIRE THAT WE GET BACK TO
NORMAL AS MUCH ASWE CAN WITH
FIRST AND FOREMOST IT'S
ENROLLING IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
EMAIL THE BURKINI COLLEGES TOOK
THE BIGGEST HIT- AND ALSO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FACED THE
THAN THE LARGEST NUMBER. OF OF
FULLY ONLINE COURSES SO YOU KNOW
IS THERE A CORRELATION THERE I
DON'T KNOW BUT IT IT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS A CONCERN- I
NEXT WENT TO- MOVED TO-
QUESTIONS FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA- MISTER DRAKE IF YOU
CAN COME BACK. I WONDER IF YOU
CAN- TALK TO THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
THIS COURT DECISION THAT CAME
OUT LAST WEEK I KNOW MR MEDINA
IS AWARE OF IT I'M NOT SURE IF
THE OTHERS BUT- HE SENSUALLY A-
ALAMEDA SUPERIOR COURT-
BASICALLY- PUT IN MOTION- AT A
RULING WHICH WOULD ESSENTIALLY-
FREEZE ENROLLMENT. AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BERKELEY
AND NOT ONLY FREEZE ENROLLMENT
BUT HAVE THEM HAVE TO SLASH.
THEIR FRESHMAN FRESHMAN CLASS BY
ABOUT 30% OR ABOUT THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS. AND YOU KNOW
THIS COULD POTENTIALLY HAVE AN
IMPACT ON OTHER- COLLEGES AS
WELL THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO-
MISTER DRAKE CAN YOU GIVE US AN
UPDATE ON ON AND- THAT. THAT
RULING JUST A FEW DAYS AGO-
WHAT'S NEXT I KNOW IT'S BEING
APPEALED TO THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT. AND THEN- YOU
KNOW POTENTIALLY ARE THERE ANY
LEGISLATIVE- REMEDIES THAT THAT
COULD BE DONE TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. MR JEFF THANK YOU YES
THANK YOU DOCTOR MCCARTY AND WE
WERE OF COURSE VERY DISTRESSED
BY THE UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT
DECISION BY THE COURT AND THEN
ARE WE FILED THE STAY AND- THE
LAST WEEK WE HEARD THAT THE
STATE WAS DENIED ALLOWING THE
APPEAL TO GO FORWARD BUT DID NOT
AND LET'S. WON'T BE DECIDED
UNTIL THE SUMMER SOMETIME SORT
REALLY A COMPLETELY THAT'S THAT
FREEZING OR CAPPING OF THE
STUDENTS AT THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DOT LEVEL THAT
IMPACTS BOB THAT IN A
DEVASTATING FASHION THE
ACCEPTANCE AS WE WOULD BE
SENDING OUT OR IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL WEEKS SO WE- HAVE FILED
IT- I MOTION FOR THAT TO GRANT
THE STATE TO THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT UNDERSTAND THAT
WAS. FILED EARLIER TODAY THIS
REALLY CAME OUT LAST THURSDAY
AFTERNOON SO FILE THAT APPEAL-
THE BILL TODAY SO WE WILL WORK
THROUGH THE LEGAL PROCESS TO SEE
IF WE CAN GET A STATE WELL THE
ISSUES THAT ARE BEFORE THE
COURTS ARE BEING ADDRESSED THEM.
OUT SO WE'RE NOT PUTTING ALL OF
OUR RESOURCES. INTO TRYING TO UP
- GET THE STATE WHAT YOU MEANT
IS TRUE THAT IS THAT THE LOWER
COURT ACTION HAD A- PUT ON. THE
ENROLLMENT PLANNING FOR THE FALL
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WHICH TENDED TO BE A TIME
WHICH WAS COMPLETELY A TYPICAL
FOR OUR INVOLVEMENT OBVIOUSLY WE
HAD. HIGHER ENROLLMENT AT
DIFFERENT TIMES OF THE YEAR BUT
THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WAS A TIME WHEN WE WORK OUT
JUST- YOU'RE STILL RETURNING
BACK. UNDER THE PANDEMIC AND SO
IT PUTS AN ARTIFICIALLY LOW CAP
ON OUR- ON OUR INVOLVEMENT AT UC
BERKELEY AND- REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN THE
FRESHMAN CLASS BY THREE
THOUSAND. WOULD HAVE A
DEVASTATING IMPACT OBVIOUSLY ON
THOSE THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS
BUT THEN THAT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THAT FACT OF HAVING SO
MANY OF YOUR CLASSES FOR FIRST
YEAR STUDENTS WHAT IMPACT
INSTRUCTION AS THEY BECAME
SECOND YEAR STUDENTS AND THIRD
YEAR STUDENTS. IT WOULD IN FACT
UNIVERSALLY UNDERSTOOD FOR YEARS
AND WE COULDN'T REMEDY THIS BY
SAYING WELL THAT'S FINE THIS IS
A- THAT HIP FOR THIS ONE YEAR-
BIG HIT AS IT MAY BE A HIT THIS
ONE YEAR NEXT YEAR WILL TAKE IN
A NORMAL FIRST YEAR CLASS AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT NEXT ADDITIONAL
THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS. AS
SOPHOMORES THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
SUCH THING SO THAT WE ARE VERY-
FOCUS VERY MUCH ON THIS AND-
WITH THE SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE LEGISLATIVE LEAD
OTHERWISE THE THINGS WE WILL OF
COURSE BE EXPLORING ACTIVELY AS
THE WEEKS. ALONG WITH THE IN THE
LEGAL ARENA TODAY WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS FILED AN. APPEAL BUT TO
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
YES CERTAINLY IT IS. AND I KNOW-
YOUR REPRESENTATIVE THERE- IN
BERKELEY IN THE ASSEMBLY MISS
WICKS HAD BEEN COMMUNICATING
WITH SOMEONE DIRECTING AND I END
UP BUT IT'S NOT JUST- BERKELEY
YOU KNOW FRANKLY UC BERKELEY
BELONGS TO CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
BERKELEY OF COURSE BUT THIS HAS
AN IMPACT. ON ALL OF HIGHER
EDUCATION SO- WE'RE EXTREMELY
CONCERNED WE DON'T WANT TO LIMIT
ACCESS AND I THINK YOU KNOW. THE
FRESHENING PIECES WERE LISTENING
TO THE CONCERNS OF THESE COLLEGE
TOWNS LIKE BERKELEY AND SAYING
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO BUILD MORE
STUDENT HOUSING AND SELF I KNOW
THIS CAMPUS AMONG OTHERS HAS A
PLAN FOR EVERY TIME YOU ENROLL.
MANY STUDENTS WE ADDRESS A
HOUSING ACCORDINGLY SO- I THANK
YOU THAT INSTEAD I GUESS THE
QUESTION THAT I ASKED THAT IT I
DIDN'T HEAR. IS YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW MILLER TRYING TO FIGHT THIS
ISSUE WITH THE COURT SYSTEM BUT
IS THERE ANY. FAINT POTENTIALLY
THE LEGISLATURE. COULD DO. TO TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE CAN CONTINUE HIGHER
EDUCATION ENROLLMENT ACCESS. YES
I THINK OVER- OVER THE- IF THE
MEDIUM TERM SOLUTION THAT'S VERY
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS CAME
FROM A SEQUEL- REVIEW AND GOOD
REALLY WITH EXPANDED OR IN LARGE
VIEW OF WHAT IT SEEK ROUTE
REVIEW SHOULD INCLUDE AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT BACK TO PLAY WITH-
THE OF THE LEGISLATURE AND OUT
THEN AND MORE BROADLY WORK ISSUE
WERE ENTIRELY. INTERESTED IN
HAVING APPROPRIATE THAT STRUCK
OUT AT CLASSROOMS AND
LABORATORIES IN HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS THAT'S WORTH ENTIRELY
INTEREST IN THAT AND WE'RE
ENTIRELY INTERESTED IN THAT
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY OF THE COMMUNITIES IN
WHICH WE LIVE AND THOSE THINGS
NEED TO BE BALANCED BOB THIS
DUCK GOES ENTIRELY IN ONE
DIRECTION AND ENTIRELY AGAINST
THE OTHER AND- ALSO WE WILL NEED
TO HAVE A LONGER TERM SOLUTION
AND WE'LL BE HAPPY TO DISCUSS
THIS WITH YOU AND- AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES. THAT THESE DAYS AND
WEEKS ROLE FOR. YEAH I KNOW THAT
WAS A- HOT POTATO POLITICALLY SO
TO SPEAK- YEARS AGO GOVERNOR
BROWN SAID REFORMING. C. BECAUSE
GOD'S WORK SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
BUT- YOU KNOW I KNOW THE- FORMER
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AS WAS MY
COLLEAGUE HERE MR DONNELL AND
EVERY TIME WE APPROVE A NEW
TARGET OR WALMART OR HOTEL.
THAT'S WE HAVE A SECRET.
ANALYSIS I DIDN'T NECESSARILY
THINK IN ROLLING- MORE STUDENTS
IN EXISTING CAMPUS- HAS THAT
THRESHOLD SO I THINK THAT'S A
UNIQUE UNIQUE- BASICALLY TOOL
THAT SOME NIMBYS. IN A PART OF
CALIFORNIA WHO WON THE FIGHT
KAJOL CARE DUCATION ESSENTIALLY
SO I THINK THAT RAISES SOME GOOD
QUESTIONS- MISTER O'DONNELL I
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY AND I FIND
IT INTERESTING NOW THAT YOU
CAN'T GO TO COLLEGE BECAUSE A
SEQUEL. RIGHT WHAT AN
INTERESTING DYNAMIC WE FIND
OURSELVES IN- BUT ON TO OTHER
THINGS- I THINK I APPRECIATE-
ALL THE PRESENTATIONS TODAY-
MIKE AND I AND AGAIN I AGREE
WITH MR CARTY MISTER KING THAT
COLLEGES NEED TO BE OPEN. I LIVE
ACROSS THE STREET FROM LONG
BEACH STATE AND I CAN TELL YOU
TRAFFIC THERE IS MUCH LATER-
THEN IT WOULD BE IF THE SCHOOL
WERE OPEN. SO THERE ARE NOT A
LOT OF PEOPLE. YOU KNOW FROM
FROM FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- GOING
ON CAMPUS SO. AGAIN I. PEOPLE
LEARN BEST IN PERSON THAT'S THE
TEACHER IN ME AS THE PARENT OF
THE ENEMY I HAVE A DAUGHTER THAT
IT COMMUNITY COLLEGE AT MR
OAKLEY'S FORMER COLLEGE-
ENJOYING THE COLLEGE PROMISE
THAT HE HELPED CREATE. AND I CAN
TELL YOU I KNOW THAT SHE'S GOING
TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL SHE'S IN
THAT CLASSROOM AND I UNDERSTAND.
THAT SOME PEOPLE OF CHILD CARE
HEALTH ISSUES THAT WE SHOULD
ACCOMMODATE AS WELL BUT AGAIN-
WE NEED TO GET OUR COLLEGES OPEN
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN K. TWELVE ZERO
- WITH THAT- BUT MIKE. MIKE
COMMENT IS- FOR QUESTION REALLY
IS FOR. MR OAKLEY- I ASSUME
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE RECENT
K. TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE
AUDIT- WHEREIN THAT PROGRAM WAS
AUDITED THAT IS- MONEY THAT IS
GIVEN TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ADMINISTER
FOR THE K. TWELVE SIDE. M. DID
YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THAT ON
THE FINDINGS OF AN HONOR ROLL
MISTER PUBLIC JOE CIRCLING. WHAT
THANK THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION A MEMBER O'DONNELL-
IT'S IT YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE
TALKED ABOUT THE K. TWELVE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM FOR A
LONG TIME- THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES STAND READY TO SUPPORT.
A STRONG WORK FORCE IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM THAT WE CAN- IT
WAS THIS IS NOT OUR CHOICE- THIS
WAS APPROPRIATED TO US BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND FORMER GOVERNOR.
AND WE WILL WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN WITHIN THE
CAPACITY THAT WE HAVE IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. TO TO
ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM IS
YOU'RE AWARE. WHEN THAT PROGRAM
WAS APPROPRIATED TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANGES OFFICE
IT WAS DONE SO WITHOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL- DOLLARS FOR STAFF OR
ANY RECOGNITION. OF THE STAFFING
SHORTAGES THAT WE HAD AT THE
TIME BUT HAVING SAID ALL THAT
WE'RE COMMITTED. TO
ADMINISTERING THIS PROGRAM
ACCORDING TO- YOU KNOW THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE PROGRAM AND
THE EXPECTATIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WORKING. TO RESPOND
TO THAT AUDIT AS WE SPEAK RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND I TO ME THIS THE
SOLUTION QUITE SIMPLE MOV THAT
MONEY BACK OVER. TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE- THE CD THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION BECAUSE THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCE DOING IT IN FACT.
THEY AND HAVE THOSE ONES HAVE
THE C. T. FUNDS ANNUALLY. ARE
DOLED OUT BY CD THEY HAVE THE
LOGISTICS THEY HAVE THE
EXPERTISE THIS WOULD TAKE ONE
PROGRAM OFF YOUR PLATE. OF THE
MANY THAT YOU'VE BEEN GIVEN- SO
I THINK I THINK THE WISE MOVE
HERE. AS WE HEAD FORWARD IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS IS TO MOVE THAT-
FUNDING BACK OVER JUST WALKED
OVER TO CDP WHEREIN THEY ALREADY
ADMINISTER A GOOD AMOUNT OF
MONEY I AND I SHARE. YOUR YOUR
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
C. T. AS OF C. T. S. AS A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER FOR A LOT OF KIDS
THAT'S THEIR HOOK IN SCHOOL
THAT'S OUR HOOK. SO WE NEED TO
GET THESE MONIES OUT IN AN
EFFICIENT MANNER. AND I THINK
YOU. MISTER DANCER OKAY THANK
YOU- MR MCCORMACK YOU MISTER
MEDINA THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR-
MAYBE START WITH- GRAY IF I
COULD- AND MAYBE BEFORE THE
QUESTION JUST LET ME REITERATE
WHAT I'VE HEARD HERE AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF A BOLD INVESTMENT
BOLD INVESTMENT AT ALL OUR
LEVELS OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND
THE- THE PAYOFF THAT WE GET. ON
THAT INVESTMENT COULDN'T AGREE
MORE WITH THE HEADS OF ALL THREE
OF OUR SEGMENTS BUT. PROGRAM AND
I'M LOOKING THAT MANY OF THE
STUDENTS ARE HAVE LEFT NOW FROM
UC BERKELEY- THE NUMBER HERE AND
I DID HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH THEM BEFORE OUR OUR
SUB TO MEETING- I HAPPENED TO BE
A TEACHER WHO WORKED IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. BOTH AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER IN THE
EARLY SEVENTIES THAT- SOLEDAD
AND THEN AS A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER ADULT EDUCATION TEACHER
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR
WOMEN CIW RIGHT TAUGHT FOR TWO
YEARS. AND TEACHING AND JUST TO
YEARS AT SEA I W. I
UNFORTUNATELY SAW THE RECIDIVISM
THAT WE HAVE WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
THAT I SAW LEAVE AND COME BACK.
IN THE TWO YEARS THAT I WAS
THERE. AND WE NOW HAVE PROGRAMS
AT ALL THREE LEVELS OF OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION WE HAVE A
PROGRAMS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THE RISING SCHOLARS WERE
WE PUT IN TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET TO INCREASE
THEIR PROGRAM. I HAVE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE CSU. THE
C. ISSUES- RAJIT REBOUND THAT WE
PUT IN IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE GRADUATION CEREMONY AT CAL
STATE FULLERTON. AND THOSE
STUDENTS. AND THOSE OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS THAT
PARTICIPATED IN PROJECT REBOUND
. AND I COULD NEVER HAVE BEEN
ANY PROUDER OF ANY OF OUR
STUDENTS KNOW OUR OF CSU AND THE
PRESIDENT OF CAL STATE FULLERTON
FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO THAT
PROGRAM- CAL STATE FULLERTON HAS
A- HOUSING PROGRAM. WHERE THE
FORMER INCARCERATED STUDENTS-
CAN LIVE AND GET THE SUPPORT AND
WE PUT IN MONEY AND THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET TO REPLICATE
THAT PROGRAM ADDED ANOTHER CSU.
SO THE STUDENTS ARE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON ASKING US THE
LEGISLATURE AND UC. TWO FOUR
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE ONLY SEGMENT WHERE
WE HAVE NOT SEEN INVESTMENT. AND
I WILL- PUSH FOR THAT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR. INCLUSION IN THE
STATE BUDGET WHICH IS NOT NOW
REFLECTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ANALYST ASKED MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT ME IN THAT
ASK. NOT A LOT OF MONEY BUT THE
MOST EFFICIENT USE OF MONEY
BECAUSE ALL THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
. MORE THAN A NINETY PERCENT.
SUCCESS AND MOST OF THESE
PROGRAMS HAVE ZERO RECIDIVISM
AND THEIR PROGRAM SO I SUPPORT
THE ASK OF THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
HERE FROM UC BERKELEY AND UC
IRVINE AND WILL PASS THAT WE PUT
IN FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
STATE BUDGET. TO FUND THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS PROGRAM AND
I DON'T KNOW IF PRESIDENT DRAKE
IF YOU COULD GIVE ME A SHORT
RESPONSE TO THE STUDENTS REQUEST
. PRESIDENT REGULAR THERE YES I
AM AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MR NEED RIGHT NICE TO SEE YOU
AND I HAD THE POP PRIVILEGE OF
VISITING ABOUT THOSE WITH THAT
ENOUGH FOR THE SAME STUDENTS
PRIVATE THAT DEMOCRATS
CALIFORNIA AT BERKELEY- EARLIER
THIS- THIS YEAR IN OCTOBER I WAS
THERE ACTUALLY ONE OF MY FIRST
VISITS TO A CAMPUS- WE WERE
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO BE ON CAMPUS
AND HAD A GREAT- THE GREAT TIME
VISITING WITH THE MIKE BREY WITH
THE MOST EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM. THAT'S IT AT
IRVINE MAYOR THING CALLED THE
ORANGE WHAT SCHOLARS PROGRAM NOT
QUITE THE SAME AS A WHILE AGO
THAT I WAS THERE THIS IS A
PROGRAM FOR FOSTER YOUTH THAN WE
HAD OF A SPECIAL WELCOMING
CEREMONY THEN WE HAD A
GRADUATION CEREMONY A SPECIAL
PRIVATE GRADUATION CEREMONY FOR
THOSE FOSTER YOUTH IN ADDITION
TO THE BROADER GRADUATION
CEREMONY AND I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF PARTICIPATING IN THAT
CEREMONY CEREMONY WOULD HAVE SIX
OR EIGHT STUDENTS AND IT
COMPARED TO THE THOUSANDS THAT
WE HAD WITH THE OTHERS BUT WE
GOT TOGETHER WITH THEM AND
REALLY. CELEBRATED THE
INCREDIBLE PATHWAY THAT THEY HAD
TAKEN TO GET ADMITTED TO THE
UNIVERSITY AND THAT THE PROCESS
THROUGH AND GRADUATE THAT THAT
PROGRAM HAS GROWN- IN IN THE
FIRST YEAR SO HAPPY TO HEAR THAT
BURKE THE ENTERPRISE WERE
REPRESENTED FOR YOU TODAY AND
I'LL SAY THAT OUR AND OUR
PROPOSAL- TO THE GOVERNOR WE HAD
ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
AND WE PUT TWO PROFESSORS ARE
PROGRAMS TOGETHER AND THIS WAS
ON. A PROGRAM FOR PARTIALLY
IMPACTED STUDENTS AND FOSTER
YOUTH OUT AMONG OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AND CHALLENGE
STUDENTS THE ABOUT GOVERNOR OF
BUDGET ARE REFLECTED THIS THAT
OUT LOWER AMOUNT AND NARROWED
THE SCOPE A BIT BUT WE HAD
REQUESTED THAT A LARGE AMOUNT OF
MONEY SO THAT WE COULD INCLUDE
MORE SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
PARTIALLY IMPACTED THAT STUDENTS
AND FOR FOSTER STUDENTS TONIGHT
AGREE WITH YOU THAT EVERY ONE OF
THEM WHO SUCCEEDS AS A GREAT
TRIUMPH FOR THE. UNIVERSITY OF A
GREAT SUCCESS FOR SOCIETY. THANK
YOU PRESENT REAGAN I WOULD ON
SAY THAT. I KNOW BECAUSE I'VE
MET. WITH STOOD THAT USE RIVER.
FORMERLY AND- STUDENTS WHO ARE
PART OF THE PROGRAM AS WELL. WHO
ARE TRYING TO WORK. OUT WITH
WITH THIS PROGRAM TO. KIND OF
GET STARTED. AT UC RIVERSIDE
WHICH AS YOU KNOW I REPRESENT.
SO AND THEN AND LASTLY. YOU KNOW
JUST THE INCREDIBLE SUCCESS WITH
THE STUDENTS I'VE HAD. GOING ON
TO GRADUATE SCHOOL A MEETING ONE
HERE THIS AFTERNOON WHO. WILL GO
ON TO LAW SCHOOL IT'S JUST AN
INCREDIBLE PROGRAM. MANY OF THEM
AS I SAY GO ON TO GRADUATE
SCHOOL AND- GET P. H. D.'S GET A
MAYES SO I WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
SUPPORT THE REQUEST THANK YOU
PRESIDENT DRAKE. AND IF I COULD.
DIRECT ONE QUESTION TO
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY. CHANCER
AUBREY- AS YOU KNOW WE'RE DOING
A LOT THIS YEAR AND HOUSING
ESPECIALLY FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND- WE HAVE THAT
LEGISLATION BY ASSEMBLY MCCARTY
IN MYSELF TO INCREASE HOUSING-
ESPECIALLY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHICH THEY AUTOS THEY
DESPERATELY NEED. CHANCER OAKLEY
WHAT OBSTACLES MIGHT THERE BE
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
FACING. ANY PROBLEMS THAT THE
COMMUNICATORS ARE EXPERIENCING
IN GETTING. THE MONEY TO- TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR
OAKLEY. OR IF WE MOVE FORWARD
ANY ANY. ISSUES THAT YOU MIGHT
FORESEE. BUT IT THANK YOU FOR
THAT- CHAIR MEDINA IS WONDERFUL
TO SEE YOU IF NOT IN PERSON- AS
YOU KNOW YOU'RE VERY WELL AWARE
THAT OUR THAT OUR CAMPUSES ARE-
HUNGRY FOR STUDENT HOUSING GIVEN
THE- ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF ALARMING
AMOUNT OF- HOUSING INSECURITY
THAT EXIST IN OUR SYSTEM. SO WE
ARE WORKING HARD TO- WORK WITH-
R. SEVENTY- THREE DISTRICTS TO
COME UP WITH A COMMON WAY OF
APPROACHING THIS IN TO BUILD THE
INTERNAL CAPACITY TO HELP THE
SYSTEM. WHICH IS NOT
TRADITIONALLY- OVERSEEING
STUDENT HOUSING BUT NOW- THERE
IS A CONSENSUS THAT THIS IS THE
DIRECTION WE NEED TO MOVE AND I
SUPPORT THAT. DIRECTION SO. I
KNOW THAT EXECUTIVE VICE
CHANCELLOR SAID NEVER READ GOING
TO YOU KNOW WELL IS WORKING HARD
TO. LOWER THE BARRIERS FOR OUR
FOR OUR COLLEGES I THINK THAT-
YOU KNOW. ONE OF THE CONCERNS
ONCE WE DO BUILD A BECAUSE I DO
THINK THAT WE ARE ON OUR WAY TO
BUILDING MORE STUDENT HOUSING.
IS HOW STUDENTS ACTUALLY PAY FOR
THAT HOUSING AND CERTAINLY THE
EFFORTS THAT WE'RE MAKING A
ROUND CAL GRANT REFORM THE
EFFORTS THAT WE'RE MAKING TO
INCREASE PELL FOR COMMITTEE
COSTUMES. ESPECIALLY FOR TALKING
STUDENTS WILL BE IMPORTANT TO
HELPING TO PAY FOR THE HOUSING-
BUT- I WILL- MAKE SURE THAT
EXECUTIVE VICE CHANCELLOR
NAVARETTE- COMMUNICATES YOUR
OFFICE ANY CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
HAVING. I THINK THE MAIN
CHALLENGES THIS IS NEW FOR OUR
SYSTEM WE'RE TRYING TO
COORDINATE IN SUPPORT OF OUR
COLLEGES- WE ARE VERY DISPERSES
THURMOND UNLIKE THE CSU IN THE
UC. WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR SEVENTY
THREE DISTRICT TO PARTICIPATE AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE ALL SEVENTY
THREE HAVE DIFFERENT- CHALLENGES
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM. AN
EXPEDITE- THE RESOURCES THE MUCH
AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU
CHANCELLOR. THANK YOU MR MEDINA
CORRECT IS- A PILOT A COUPLE
YEAR ISSUE SO FIRST OF ALL THE-
THE PROGRAMS FOR THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED 100% HOW WE'RE ALL
IN ON THOSE- WE DID THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ONE LAST YEAR
RISING SCHOLARS ON GOING SO WE
SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT THAT BUT
THE REALLY THE PERSON WE SHOULD
BE TALKING TO IS MISTER DRAKE
HITS. YOU KNOW MAINTAINING THE
SPEAKER AND ATKINS WORDS ARE
TURNED OUT TO FUND OUR
PRIORITIES SO THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE- PUT THIS IN
OUR PLAN. OKAY VERY HAPPY TO
HEAR THAT AND WHEN I DRESSED IT
TO PRESENT DRAKE I WAS JUST KIND
OF LOOK AT NINE FOUR NINE.
NUMBER GLAD TO HEAR YEAH WELL MY
GOODNESS HIS HIS ROLLS OVER IN
THIS PART NOW IT'S UP TO US. TO
DO IT. RIGHT AND THEN FOR THIS
ON. YEAH I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HOUSING. IT'S OUR ROLE IN THIS
INTO THE CHANCELLOR. WORRY
SENSUALLY THE BANK USED TO GARA
BORROW MONEY FROM WALL STREET
THINK THEY CHARGE YOU HIGH
INTEREST RATES AND THIS AND THAT
AND THEY- YOU KNOW HE HAD TO.
LEVERAGE A LOT JUST TO GET THE
MONEY AND SO OUR ROLE IS TO JUST
BE THE MIDDLE PERSON TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE. THAT LANDING I'M NOT
SURE THAT WE'RE IN THE POSITION
TO. TO HELP PROVIDE FURTHER
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING AND BITE ON
THE COSTS BUT- YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE GONNA BUILD A PROJECT
POTENTIALLY GO BORROW MONEY
FROM- WALL STREET OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THIS IS AN OPTION TO
DO IT. AT A MUCH CHEAPER RATE 0%
INTEREST. AND ITS REVOLVING LOAN
FUND SO. THE MONEY WILL GO BACK
INTO DOING MORE HOUSING. FOR THE
DECADES TOGETHER SO- I THANK
WILL BE CLEAR THAT'S WHAT IT IS
IT'S NOT TO. TO DO ANYTHING
DIFFERENT OTHER THAN THAT- WITH
THAT SOMEONE EMBRACE. THANK YOU
MISTER. OF PRESIDENT REAGAN THE
CHANCELLOR CASTRO SO GOOD TO BE
BACK HERE ON THE SCREEN WITH YOU
AND CHANCELLOR ORTIZ OAKLEY IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK FROM DC.
GLAD YOU WERE THERE FOR THE
PRESIDENT BUT WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE
YOU BACK HERE IN CALIFORNIA. MY
BIGGEST CONCERN HAS TO DO WITH
THE GRADUATION RATES AND THE
GAPS IN GRADUATION RATE FOR OUR
MINORITY STUDENTS. OUR
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT FOSTER YOUTH THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED. WHAT IS IT THAT WE
NEED TO DO WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
ABOUT THE SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM I
KNOW THAT AT CAL POLY POMONA DR
REDFORD REESE HAS A SIMILAR
PROGRAM WITH. THAT CHAIN WAS TO
DO FOR MANAGING INSTITUTE FOR
WOMEN. WHAT IS IT ONE OF THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS BESIDES THE
USE THAT WE NEED TO WORK ON AND
WHAT IS THE COST. ASSOCIATED
WITH A PROVIDING THE SUPPORT
THAT YOU NEED TO CLOSE THE
GRADUATION GAP. AND THIS I WOULD
ADDRESS TO EACH OF YOU IF YOU
COULD JUST ADDRESS IT BRIEFLY.
I'M HAPPY TO JUMP IN HERE.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN NICE TO SEE YOU
AND I WELCOME YOUR QUESTION
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS ONE OF
OUR MOST SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
AND MY HIGHEST PRIORITY AS
CHANCELLOR IS TO ELIMINATE THESE
EQUITY GAPS ONCE AND FOR ALL AND
FOR THE CSU- IT HAS TO DO WITH-
SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS YOUR
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WHICH I THINK YOU'RE
PROBABLY AWARE OF. WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO INCREASE OUR GRADUATION
RATES DRAMATICALLY- OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS IN FACT OUR FOUR
YEAR GRADUATION RATE IS UP SIXTY
THREE PERCENT- SINCE WE STARTED
THIS PROGRAM AND WE JUST HAD A
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF GRADUATES
IN OUR HISTORY ABOUT A HUNDRED.
AND THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
GRADUATES IN MAY BUT WE STILL
HAVE MUCH MORE WORK TO DO AND IN
OUR BUDGET REQUEST IS A SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS- OF
PERMANENT FUNDING THAT WE WOULD
USE TO HIRE MORE FACULTY. FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS WHO ARE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT AND
UNDERSTAND THE DIVERSE STUDENTS
THAT WE SERVE A MORE ACADEMIC
ADVISORS AND A RANGE OF
STRATEGIES THAT HAVE COME OUT OF
THE WORKING GROUP THAT I SET UP
IMMEDIATELY AFTER I BEGAN AS
CHANCELLOR I'LL GIVE YOU THE
FIVE PRIORITY AREAS OF THAT
WORKING GROUP JUST VERY BRIEFLY.
NUMBER ONE IS TO RE ENGAGE AND
RE ENROLL ARE UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS WE'VE BEEN VERY ACTIVE
IN REACHING OUT TO THE STUDENTS
WHO- THE LEFT US AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC- MAYBE
EVEN BEFORE THAT AND WELCOMING
THEM BACK TO CAMPUS AND WE'VE
HAD SOME VERY GOOD SUCCESS. AT
MANY OF OUR CAMPUSES ARE WE WANT
TO EXPAND CREDIT OPPORTUNITIES-
FOR SUMMER AND INTERCESSIONS SO
THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN TAKE
CLASSES DURING THOSE PERIODS OF
TIME AND MAKE PROGRESS MORE
QUICKLY- ENSURE ADEQUATE FULL
ACCESS TO DIGITAL DEGREE ROAD
MAPS SO THAT OUR STUDENTS. KNOW
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO WHEN AND
HOW AND IT'S- IT'S DIGITAL AND
IT'S A SUPPORT TOOL FOR THEM-
AND PROVIDES NUDGES TO THEM TO
DO CERTAIN THINGS ATCERTAIN
TIMES. WE'RE GONNA ELIMINATE
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS TO
GRADUATION- AND THERE THERE ARE
STILL SOME OF THOSE DESPITE OUR
EFFORTS. AND I'M COMMITTED WITH
MY COLLEAGUES TO ELIMINATING
THOSE KINDS OF BARRIERS SO THAT
OUR STUDENTS CAN GRADUATE. IN A
TIMELY WAY AND THEN FINALLY
PROMOTING EQUITABLE LEARNING
PRACTICES AND REDUCING THE
NUMBERS OF DEASON ABSENT
WITHDRAWALS IN SOME OF OUR
COURSES. THAT ARE ACTING.
UNFORTUNATELY AS BARRIERS AND
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY THAT'S
THE CASE AND IT WORKED OUT BY
CUTTING ANY CORNERS ACADEMICALLY
BUT WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS. HAVE THE TOOLS AND
SUPPORT TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO GIVE YOU MORE
INFORMATION LATER ABOUT THESE
EFFORTS AND OTHER ONES THAT WERE
UNDERTAKING. THANK YOU
TRANSFERRED. MAYBE ALL OF US
SPEAK UP NEXT TO SAY GREAT AND
VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION AND VERY
IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR UP FOR US
AS WELL AND LET ME ACTUALLY
CONGRATULATED CHANCELLOR CASTRO
AND HIS PREDECESSOR FOR- REALLY-
IT INCREDIBLE SUCCESS OF THIS
LAST DECADE IN INCREASING THE
FOREIGN SIX YEAR GRADUATION
RATES AT THAT THE CSU AND NOW
THAT SOMETHING THAT STUCK TO
GAIN NATIONAL ATTENTION AND
APPRECIATE THAT I I'LL SAY THAT
I HAVE TO EFFORTS THAT WE'VE
WORKED ON AS WE LOOK TOWARD
ELIMINATING THESE GAPS OVER THE
NEXT DECADE AS WELL AS- I
MENTION OUR GOAL OF INCREASING.
THE SIZE OF OUR OUR
UNDERGRADUATE VIRGINIA STUDENT
POPULATION BY TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS OVER THE NEXT DECADE
THAT INCLUDES AND THEN
INCREASING THE SIZE OF OUR
FACULTY TO TEACH THOSE STUDENTS
AS WE FOCUS ON THE INCREASE IN
OUR FACULTY WE ARE GOING TO BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY FOCUSED ON
INCREASING THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
FACULTY WHICH HAS LAGGED BEHIND
OUR OTHER EFFORTS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF MAKING SURE
THAT OUR UNIVERSITY IN TWENTY
THIRTY IS NOT ONLY LARGER BUT
ALSO BROADLY FROM STUDENTS
THROUGH FACULTY MORE
REPRESENTATIVE. COUPLE OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE PARTICIPATED IN
OVER THE YEARS THAT HAVE HAVE A
TERM REALLY GREAT SUCCESS AND
BUT. WE ARE CONTINUING TO EXPAND
. ABOUT WHAT IS A UP. THAT WE'VE
BEEN IN ADDITION. BUT USE YOUR
BOB I WAS TO. THERE AND THE GOAL
IS TO JUST THE THINGS THAT- JEFF
CASTRO MENTION THAT IS TO. LOOK
AT THOSE PLACES. IMPAIR YOUR
COURSES WHERE WE HAD DIFFERENCE
LET. BETWEEN STUDENTS WHO CAME
FROM MARGINALIZED AND MINORITY
RIGHTS THEN DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS AND THE MEAN. I KNOW
THAT GOD THE LAST THAT I WILL
HAVE A FROM A YEAR OR SO AGO AND
TWO YEARS AGO I SAY AND- THE
BLACK WHITE. DIFFERENTIAL IN A
GRADUATION- THAT ACHIEVEMENT
HAVE BEEN ELIMINATED ESSENTIALLY
AT THAT CAMPUS TO IT SO
DIFFICULT LEVEL SO THAT IS GREAT
THERE WERE STILL SOME OTHER. IF
YOU LOOK MORE GRANULAR THERE
WERE STILL SOME OTHER CHALLENGES
BUT WE SAW THAT A REAL FOCUS ON
PROJECT THE- BARRIER COURSES AND
UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATION. COULD
HELP YOU TO REALLY ACHIEVE.
ELIMINATE THOSE THAT GAPS BY
INCREASING THE SUCCESS OF THOSE
STUDENTS WHO BURKE WERE FALLING
BEHIND. AT A CHANCE TO
PARTICIPATE FOR. SIX YEARS AS A
YEAH FIRST BEGINNING MEMBER AND
THEN AS THAT COMING ON
OVERSEEING PROBLEM SUPPORTER OF
A THING CALLED UNIVERSITY
INNOVATION ALLIANCE IT WAS A-
NATIONAL EFFORT. LOOKED AT
ELIMINATING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND
RAISING THE- LEVEL OF GRADUATION
OF THE UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE-
COUNTRY THAT PLACE THAT I WAS
INCREASED ITS GRADUATION. RATE
BY EIGHTEEN PERCENT. OVER THAT
TIME THAT WE WERE THERE DURING
THAT UC RIVERSIDE IS A PART OF
THAT THAT IT FOCUSES ON. THAT'S
THE THINGS THAT THE GAME
CHANCELLOR CASTRO'S MENTION
FOCUSES ON. MAKING SURE TO HAVE
THE APPROPRIATE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR FACULTY. HELPING
TEACHERS WHO ARE ALREADY GREAT
TEACHERS BE EVEN BETTER TEACHERS
FOR TEACHING TEACHERS TO TEACH
BETTER WE COULD TALK MORE DETAIL
ABOUT THAT- LATER. FOCUSING ON
STUDENT ADVISING MAKING SURE
THAT WE- THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
SUPPORTED AND AIMED AND- AND
NURTURED THROUGH THEIR PATHWAY-
THROUGH THE COURSE SO THAT THEY-
CAN. REALLY BE HELPED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL FROM THE VERY VERY
BEGINNING YOU CANNOT WAIT UNTIL
SOMEONE. GETS A BAD GRADE ON A
MID TERM OR FINALLY SAY GOSH
THERE ARE SOMETHING WRONG. YOU
START VERY EARLY WITH LOS.
QUIZZES AND WITHIN THE FIRST
WEEK OUR FIRST TWO OUT TO GIVE
STUDENTS ABOUT FEEDBACK OVERALL.
AND THEN REALLY CELEBRATING THIS
THAT'S THE- HAVE ALL THE CAPS
FOCUS. ON THOSE PLACES WHERE
THERE ARE TREATMENT CAPS AND
HAVING THE ELIMINATION OF
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS OF BRITAIN INTO
THE- EVALUATION CRITERIA FOR OUR
CHANCELLORS AND- WE ARE VERY
THAT. VERY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT OUR
ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO ELIMINATE
THOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND THEN
RAISE THE GRADUATION. RATES FOR
OVER VERY ARE BROADRIDGE BREAKS
OUT THANKFULLY ARE ARE RANKED
AMONG THE HIGHEST IN THE-
COUNTRY BUT THEY'RE STILL
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT WE WANT TO
ELIMINATE AND AS WE DO THAT.
OVERALL RITUAL RISE EVEN HIGHER
. IT WILL JUMP IN- IN ALSO SAY
THANK YOU MEMBER IS WONDERFUL TO
SEE YOU. THE CLOSING OF EQUITY
GAPS IS A FUNDAMENTAL-
OVERARCHING THEME IN THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS VISION FOR SUCCESS-
SO I'D SAY THERE'S A FEW THINGS
THAT. I THINK- WITH YOUR
PARTNERSHIP WE CAN DO TO
CONTINUE TO CLOSE THESE GAPS ONE
IS ME. TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS THEY
CONTINUE TO FOCUS EFFORTS. ON
IMPROVING ACCESS TO CAL GRANT OR
STUDENTS I KNOW YOU ARE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH OUR STUDENTS- DAY-
CONTINUE TO ACCESS AND HAVE HAVE
LESS ACCESS TO THE COVERAGE JUST
THEM. THEN THERE APPEARS IN THIS
ISSUE IN THE YEARS SINCE A WEEK
AGO- THAT THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART IN THE CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS- SO WE HOPE THAT- WE
CAN CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES. ON
IMPROVING THE CAL GRANTS IS DONE
AND SUPPORTING THE BASIC NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS. I ALSO THINK
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO SUPPORT-
OF FUNDAMENTAL REFORMS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT INTO MOTION OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS IT'S A POOR
CLOSING EQUITY GAPS WE'VE SEEN.
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT IN THOSE
AREAS BASED ON THESE REFORMS AND
THAT WOULD BE SUPPORT FOR THE
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA. WHICH WE HAVE
DOCUMENTED EVIDENCE THAT IT IS
IMPROVING- THE TARGETING OF
FUNDS TO PROGRAMS THAT. SUPPORT
CLOSING EQUITY GAPS. ALSO
REFORMS LIKE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FIVE- AS WELL AS THE GUIDED.
REYES AND THEN ALSO THE WORK
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AROUND IS
SUCH A DEGREE FOR TRANSFER WHICH
IS A VERY IMPORTANT COMPONENT
FOR STUDENTS SO THEY CAN ACHIEVE
TRANSFER TO THE CSU INTO THE UC
AS WELL AS OUR A. I. C. C.
PARTNERS. I WILL SAY THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT. THAT AS- FOR FACULTY
AND STAFF IMPROVE THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT ACHIEVED THE
AGREED FOR TRANSFER. OVER CAUCUS
IN THE FUNDING CAPACITY AT THE
CSU AND UC FOR TRANSFER- AND
THEN FINALLY I'D SAY- AND AS
IMPORTANTLY. THAT WE DIVERSIFY
OUR FACULTY AND STAFF SO THAT
STUDENTS SEE THEMSELVES IN THE
CLASSROOM AND ON CAMPUS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MY I DO
RECALL THE FIRST TIME WE WERE
ALL TALKING ABOUT SOME O THESE
ISSUES. THE ONE WORD THAT
CONTINUED TO BE SHARED WITH
EQUITY AND I WANT TO THANK THE
THREE OF YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND KEEPING EQUITY AT THE TOP OF
THE LIST. OKAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I DON'T HAVE ANY
OVER OR OVER AT ANY OTHER
OVERARCHING HIGHER ED UC CSU
COMMITTEE BECAUSE QUESTIONS ARE
THE WHEN I ASKED EARLIER- I KNOW
WE'RE GONNA GET DOWN IN THE
WEEDS IN A FEW WEEKS- WITH OUR
SPECIFIC HEARINGS ON THE
PROPOSALS ARE TODAY'S JUST OUR
FIRST CHANCE TO HEAR FROM YOU.
ON THE GLOBAL PUSHED GLOBAL
PERSPECTIVE- WITH THAT SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS WILL NOW GO TO
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT IS ANYBODY
HERE I IN THE AUDIENCE PLEASE-
COME UP TO THE- TO THE FRONT AND
WILL ALLOW YOU TO. FOCUS ON
PUBLIC COMMENTS. THIRTEEN
SEVENTEEN ONE YEAH AND PLEASE
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TWO ONE
MINUTE OR LESS SIXTY SECONDS OR
LESS THANK YOU SO MUCH. A GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KEVIN
MCCARTY I'M INCARCERATED
SCHOLARS OF COORDINATOR AT UC
BERKELEY. I WAS ACCEPTED INTO UC
BERKELEY WHILE I WAS IN PRISON
AND THIS WAS ONLY POSSIBLE
BECAUSE OF THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS HELP ME WITH THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND
EVERYTHING FROM EIGHT IZZY-
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO HAVE
FOLLOWED- AFTER ME WHO WERE
ACCEPTED WHILE INCARCERATED AND
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS. THERE ARE
MANY OTHER INCARCERATED STUDENTS
WHO WISH TO COME TO THE UC
PROGRAM AND IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO SO. BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING- LAST
LEGISLATIVE SESSION THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB FOUR
SIXTEEN. WHICH REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS- TO WORK WITH
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AND PROJECT
REBOUND- SO WE NEED THIS FUNDING
TO COMPLETE THAT- TO COMPLETE
THAT MISSION TO COMPLETE- YOU
KNOW WITH THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED AND- AGAIN- AS ASSEMBLY
MANNER A MEMBER MEDINA POINTED
OUT. WE HAVE A 0% RECIDIVISM
RATE AND 95% GRADUATION RATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BOTH. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HECTOR SAID
ABOUT THIS I'M HERE REPRESENTING
UC IRVINE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING
ASK FOR THE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
PROGRAM- THIS FUNDING WAS
INCLUDED IN THE UC REGENTS
BUDGET YOU'VE SUPPORTER FORMALLY
ON A FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND
SYSTEM IMPACTED STUDENTS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL AND AT
THE CSU LEVEL I'M HERE TO ASK
YOU TO CLOSE THE GAP AND FUND
FORMING CARS RATED SYSTEM
IMPACTED STUDENTS AT THE UC
LEVEL. I ENTERED THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM ON ALL THIRTEEN
YEARS OLD AND I WAS ABLE
THANKFULLY TO ESCAPE AT TWENTY
THREE. I COMPLETED MY BA AT UC
IRVINE AND MY MAA UC IRVINE. AND
I WOULDN'T BE WHERE I WAS IF IT
WASN'T FOR THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS PROGRAM. I GAME
LEADERSHIP. SKILLS I GAINED
ACCESS TO RESOURCES. THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT BEEN
AFFORDED TO ME ACCESS TO THE-
NETWORK NETWORKS THAT HELP ME.
SHARPEN MY SKILLS BUT ALSO
ADVANCE IN MY ACADEMIC CAREER MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER. SO WITH
THAT I ASK YOU AND URGE YOU T
PLEASE CLOSE THIS GAP AND FUND
OUR PROGRAM AT THE UC SYSTEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO OF
THE GOING MY NAME'S OLYMPIA IS
GOOD AFTERNOON- A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED TRANSFER STUDENT
FIRST JAN AND- I JUST WANT TO
MENTION THAT YOU SEE I HAS
HELPED ME ENGAGE WITH THE
UNIVERSITY- D'APPLICATION
PROCESS AND BEING FROM ORANGE
COUNTY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BEING
NEW TO THE BAY AREA- HOUSING WAS
A MAJOR ISSUE FOR ME AND
SECURING HOUSING WITH SOMETHING
THAT US I ALSO HELPED ME- YOU
KNOW SECURE. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT- UNDERGROUND PATTERSON
I'M GONNA HAVE A GREAT THE VAST
MEANS OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND-
DURING THE PANDEMIC I DID
CONSIDER DROPPING OUT OF
UNIVERSITY LIKE DROPPING OUT OF
SCHOOL. BUT I'M YOU SEE I. US I
HOPE ME STAY CLEAR YOU KNOW AND
CONTINUE MY ENROLLMENT AND I
JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT- YOU
KNOW A DECLINE IN IN A- A
DECLINE IN ROMAN IS A MAJOR
CONCERN IS THAT JUST LEADER
O'DONNELL. HAD- REACHED THE
POINT THAT AN INCREASING YOU UC
OR CSU FUNDING AT 5% LEVEL FOR
NEW PROGRAMS RESEARCH EXISTING
PROGRAMS AS ONE THAT REQUIRE
SPECIAL ATTENTION. AND DOM I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT SUPPORTING
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS IS A
CONTINUING PROGRAM. WITH A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD THAT IT WAS
SUCCESSFUL RECRUITMENT RETENTION
AND GRADUATION. USE USI'S GOALS
ALSO ALIGN WITH THIS COMMITTEES
GOALS. OF YOU KNOW I ROAMING AND
RETENTION AND- IN CLOSING I JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT- I STATED. IN
THIS COMMITTEE ACCESS WITHOUT
AFFORDABILITY IS NOT ACCESS AT
ALL. AND I JUST ALSO URGE YOU
ALL TO. YOU KNOW CONSIDER THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND APPROVING IT
BECAUSE THE UC NEEDS THIS
FUNDING TO. MAKE THE UNIVERSITY
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED AS WELL. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS ERIC GENTRY I AM
THE- PROGRAM MANAGER. FOR ONE OF
THE RISING SCHOLARS NETWORK
PROGRAMS THAT SHOULD BOW
COLLEGE. I AM A FORMING CARS
READY INDIVIDUAL MYSELF. WHO WAS
ONCE A PART TIME CONTRACT
EMPLOYEES AS YOU SPOKE OF
EARLIER A PART TIME FACULTY. I
WAS LIVING UNDER THAT STRUGGLE
IS A PART TIME CONTRACT
EMPLOYEE- AND I KNOW WE ALL
CELEBRATED WHEN WE GOT THOSE
RISING SCHOLARS CATEGORICAL
FUNDING APPROVED FOR OUR CAMPUS
IS- AND I'M HERE TO STRESS. THE
APPROVAL OF THE FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ARE YOU SEE PARTNERS
AS I SAID AND- COUNTLESS NUMBER
OF OUR STUDENTS OVER TO THEIR
PROGRAM- BEING THAT MY PROGRAMS
IN A WORD. WE SEE A LOT OF OUR
STUDENTS GO TO UC BERKELEY AND
OTHER UC SYSTEMS. AND I'M JUST
HERE TO STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
APPROVING- THESE CATEGORICAL
FINDINGS FOR THEIR SYSTEMS- AS
IT WAS A GODSEND FOR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAM-
ACROSS THE STATE- AND I'D LIKE
TO SEE THAT FOR UC'S AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS THAT THEY WERE DONE I'M
HONORED AND GRATEFUL TO BE HERE
TODAY IN FRONT OF YOU- THANK YOU
FOR THIS TIME AND SPACE SO MY
PATH TO YOU SEE I STARTED AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I TRANSFERRED
I'M A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH-
SYSTEM IMPACTED AND FRUSTRATION
SCHOLAR AND IT WAS THREE ASIDE
THAT I EVEN WAS HAD THE ABILITY
TO THINK ABOUT RESEARCH AND
GRADUATE SCHOOL- I BECAUSE OF US
I SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE I
ACTUALLY GOT HA SCHOLARS AND IT
MATTERS SO I WILL BE DOING
RESEARCH- AND- I WILL BE
ACTUALLY CONSIDERING GRADUATE
SCHOOL AND BE APPLYING THIS.
FALL BECAUSE I'M SEEN- SO. WHICH
WITH EACH ONE OF US WE COME WITH
LIKE HUNDREDS MORE WE REPRESENT
A VERY VAST AND BROAD COMMUNITY.
AND YOUR SUPPORT MEANS
EVERYTHING THIS FINDING IT
CHANGES LIVES AND I'M JUST SO
GRATEFUL TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO EVEN BE HERE. AND
IT WOULD JUST BE. SO IMPACTFUL
FOR A COMMUNITY TO HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER LEVINE
I'M A GRADUATE STUDENT I'M
GETTING MY MASTER'S IN
CRIMINOLOGY LAW AND SOCIETY
EASIER IRVINE I WANT TO TELL YOU
HOW- IMPACTFUL HIGHER EDUCATION
HAS DONE FOR MY LIFE I'M
FORMERLY INCARCERATED- LIVED
MOST OF MY LIFE IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE TRAUMA YOU NAME IT AND
IN A JAIL THIS ALL KINDS OF
ENTRY NO BECAUSE LONG WITH THAT.
ANYHOW SO I TRY TO CHANGE MY
LIFE A REENTER SOCIETY AS THEY
CALL IT SEVERAL WAYS OVER
SEVERAL TIME PERIODS AGES AND
NEVER NOTHING WORKED- HIGHER
EDUCATION WORKS A TRANSFORM YOUR
IDENTITY M. MOVING TO YOU SEE
OUR ON CAMPUS HOUSING I LIVE IN
PEACE. I DON'T LIVE IN PEACE- I
WAS ABLE TO LEAVE EVERYTHING
BEHIND EVERYTHING BEHIND AND
HAVE A WHOLE NEW LIFE AND I SEE
MYSELF COMPLETELY I UC IRVINE
ALLOWED ME TO SEE MYSELF
DIFFERENTLY NOT JUST SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN IN JAIL. CELL- I KNOW
THE CHANCELLOR- SOME PEOPLE HAD
MENTIONED ABOUT THE STRESSING
THE IMPORTANCE OF- YOU KNOW
STUDENTS THAT ARE WORTHY OF A
FUNDING OR SUPPORT I JUST WANT
TO TELL YOU SOME FACTS ABOUT
THIS REAL QUICK AN OBJECT SO
FIRST FACT OUR AVERAGE GPA IS
THREE POINT FIVE WE HAVE AVERAGE
HIGHER GPAS. WE HAVE HIGHER
GRADUATION RATES WE HAVE HIGHER-
GOING INTO- PEACH JEEZ AND
MASTERS AND ALSO WE HAVE HIGHER
RATES UP ON A SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETE OUR DEGREES AND- SO I
CONSIDER US OF DEFINITELY WORTHY
OF SUPPORT AND I ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE- SUPPORT. US WITH THE
FORMING THANK THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS A MCCALL AND I AM A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED STUDENT AT
UC BERKELEY MAJORING IN LEGAL
STUDIES- I FIRST ATTENDED UC
BERKELEY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE WHICH WAS A LONG TIME
BEFORE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS WAS.
WAS THERE WHEN I WAS TWENTY TWO
YEARS OLD. AND I WAS ALREADY
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AT THAT
TIME AND- I COMPLETED ONE
SEMESTER BEFORE I ENDED UP GOING
BACK INTO CUSTODY AND- HI- LEFT
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR MORE THAN
FIFTEEN YEARS- HAVING BEEN AT
THE UNIVERSITY BOTH BEFORE AND
AFTER THE UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
CAME INTO EXISTENCE I'VE NOTICED
AT. HUGE DIFFERENCE AND- THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR STUDENTS IN THE IN AND
REDUCING THE STIGMA ASSOCIATED
WITH IT WITH- BEING FORMALLY
INCARCERATED. AND I JUST I CAN
JUST SAY FROM MY END THAT IS
PART OF WHY LIKE I'M HERE TDAY
AND WHY I FEEL LIKE IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT AND VALUABLE PROGRAM.
THAT WOULD THAT TRULY CHANGES
LIVES I KNOW THAT THROUGH MY
ENGAGEMENT WITH UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS I BEGAN TO LIKE
ACTUALIZE MYSELF AS A LEADER FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN MY LIFE. I AND
AMBASSADOR PROGRAM COORDINATOR
FOR- BERKELEY UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS WHERE WE WORK WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- AND- WE
ARE WE DO LEADERSHIP TRAININGS
WITH THEM EVERY MONTH AND- TEN
YEAH SO. I DID A REALLY BAD JOB
OF EXPLAINING THAT JUST NOW
FIRST. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU. HER NAME IS MICHELLE
MAXWELL AND I AM A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED- I AM LEGAL STUDIES
MAJOR AT UC BERKELEY. AND I JUST
WANTED TO- REALLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FUNDING FOR YOU YOU ARE
BROWN'S COLORS BECAUSE IT REALLY
CHANGE OF OURS AND I KNOW THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE HEARD THIS FROM
ALL ASPECTS. LIKE I DON'T KNOW
WHERE I WOULD BE WITHOUT A
NUMBER. OUR THEY ARE NOT. I
SPEND MOST OF MY LIFE LEGAL
DEPARTMENT LIFE IN PRISON AND-
THERE ARE TRYING EVERY WAY TO
CHECK RIGHT RIGHT YEAH THANK GOD
ON EDUCATION EDUCATION REALLY
MADE A DIFFERENCE FOR ME. MY
WHOLE LIFE IS DIFFERENT AND I'M
DIFFERENT THAN IT WOULDN'T BE
WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM AND THERE'S
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO THOSE
THINGS AND THERE'S A BIT OF MORE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO GET DONE.
AND WE CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT THE
FUNDING AND WE WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS TYLER
DENTON AND I AM A MEMBER OF
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
THROUGH THE UC IRVINE CHAPTER
I'M ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
FOR UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AS AN
ALUM OF PROJECT REBOUND PROGRAM
AT SACRAMENTO STATE I CAN
PERSONALLY ATTEST TO HOW
EFFECTIVE LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT
HAS BEEN FOR JUSTICE IMPACTED
STUDENTS WITHIN THE CSU SYSTEM I
HAVE SINCE GRADUATED AND ENTERED
THE UC SYSTEM TO PURSUE A
GRADUATE DEGREE IN PUBLIC
POLICY. HOWEVER I FELT THE STARK
CONTRAST IN REGARDS
INSTITUTIONAL SUPPORT WITH THE
BUDGET ALLOCATION OF FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS STUDENTS SUCH AS MYSELF
WHO DECIDE TO PURSUE A HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE UC SYSTEM WOULD
BE GIVEN THE SAME OPPORTUNITY AS
OTHER C. SYSTEMS TO SUCCEED AND
THRIVE WITH THE APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES. SUPPORTING THIS
PROGRAM IS AN IMPORTANT STEP FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
LOOKS TOWARD A MORE EQUITABLE
AND INCLUSIVE FUTURE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ARE
THE DAYS OF ROBBIE I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE BERKELEY
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS PROGRAM I'M
ALSO AN ALUMNUS OF UC RIVERSIDE
AND UC HASTINGS. I WAS THE
SYSTEM IMPACTED STUDENT WHEN I
WAS A UC RIVERSIDE AND NEVER
KNOWS PROGRAM SUPPORTING
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND SYSTEM
IMPACTED STUDENTS. I WAS ON
CAMPUS MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY
AND I AND WOULD STATE PRISON
FROM FRIDAY THROUGH SUNDAY AND
THERE WAS NO PROGRAM THERE TO
SUPPORT THAT EXPERIENCE FOR ME.
I'VE BEEN IN THIS ROLE FOR ABOUT
THREE YEARS FOR THE FIRST TWO
YEARS I WAS THE ONLY FULL TIME
STAFF PERSON IN THE ENTIRE UC
SYSTEM WORKING TO SUPPORT
FORMERLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS.
OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS WE
RAISED A COUPLE MILLION DOLLARS
TO ADD MORE STAFF. BUT ALL OF
THOSE ARE CONTRACT POSITIONS
THAT WILL EXPIRE AND WE NEED TO
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTINUE
TO EXPAND AND SUSTAIN OUR
PROGRAMS. AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
UC IS ACCESSIBLE TO THE SEVEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED TAKING C.
TRANSFERABLE COURSES. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON ANDREW
MARTINEZ COMMITTEE COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA. A FIRST
OVER EVERYTHING FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO REFLECT SOME OF THE
THINGS YOU HEARD EARLY DEREK
MISTRAL DOLLAR REFLECTED ON THE-
RISING INFLATION COSTS THOUGH
BECAUSE WE FACING SO ANOTHER KEY
CHRIS THE PACE WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED. AS WITH BITING OF
THE PENCIL CATIONS AS AGAIN ALSO
MENTION IN THE ALLEY ANALYSIS.
COMES RELEASED THIS. ON FRIDAY.
FINALLY WE ARE ALSO WON'T BE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU-
FUND FOUR TO CREATE A ADDRESS
FINANCIALLY REFORM THAT
ADDRESSES THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE- CERTAINLY OUR OUR
STUDENTS HAVE. A PROSPECT THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BECOMES
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING. FOOD.
AND TEXTBOOKS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN
REYES MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED TWENTY
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDS WERE A
PART TIME FACULTY HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAM A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES RELY HEAVILY ON PART
TIME FACULTY YET THE INVESTMENTS
FOR THESE- FOR THIS CONTINGENT
WORKFORCE HASN'T KEPT PACE WITH
A TREMENDOUS NEED OF YOURS
LEGISLATURE TO NOT ONLY INCLUDE
A AND APPROVE THESE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS BUT TO ALSO INCLUDE. THAT
THE NECESSARY PROGRAM EXCHANGES
TO ENSURE THAT ALL THESE BONDS
ARE USED TO ENSURE THAT MORE
PART TIME FACULTY HAVE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE AND QUALITY
HEALTHCARE THESE WORKERS ARE
HELPING TO TEACH AND TRAIN THE
FUTURE LEADERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE URGE LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE
THESE CHANGES APPROVED APPROVED
DESIGNS TO ENSURE THESE WORKERS
HAVE THE SUPPORT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY WILL
NOW GO TO- PUBLIC COMMENT. ON
THAT PHONE. AND IN CASE YOU THE
NUMBER IT'S. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. AT WITH THAT OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE.
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN THE PRESS ONE OF
THEIR- AT THIS TIME. AND FIRST
TO GO TO LINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI
MY NAME IS EMILY HEALTH PLAN AND
I AM NOW A FULL TIME PART JERRY
INSTRUCTOR AT GLENDALE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS I'M GOING
FUNDING. FOR HEALTH CARE FOR
PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY. I THINK THE FIRST
ELEVEN YEARS OF MY CAREER AS A
PART TIME INSTRUCTOR WHO COULD
NOT AFFORD HEALTH CARE. FOR
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY. WITH THE
SUPPORT OF MANY FACULTY MEMBERS
CRITICAL JOBS. AND ULTIMATELY
HARMS OUR ABILITY TO BE THERE
FOR STUDENTS. THAT IS WHY YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL. IS
CRUCIAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
. THE NEXT LINE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU CAN HEAR ME
. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
HELLO YES- GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIR
MCCARTY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ARGHA NEATLY MANY
PERSBERICHT I TEACH AT AMERICAN
RIVER COLLEGE AS I ALSO SERVED
AS THE FACULTY UNION PRESIDENT-
ERIC THE UP YOU PRESIDENTIAL OUR
COMMUNITY. AT AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE. I AM CALLING URGE YOU
TO PLEASE REPORT THAT TO ME ONLY
TWO HUNDRED MILLION ON GOING
FUNDING FOR PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTHCARE- I AT THE FACULTY
UNION PRESIDENT I MIGHT COME
BACK. EVERY SEMESTER I HEAR
HEARTBREAKING STORIES OUT WELL I
TOOK IT REAL LIFE STORIES FROM
MY PART TIME COLLEAGUES. ABOUT
HOW THEY WORK. BUT HOW THEY WORK
SO WORRIED ABOUT HOW THEY CAN
SUPPORT AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILY ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO HEALTHCARE THEY HAVE NO IDEA
HOW THEIR KIDS DON'T GET HELLO-
HERE AT THE HOSPITAL WHEN
THEY'RE SICK. THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND IT IS NOT IT'S
HEALTHCARE THANK YOU MENTAL
RIGHT NOT TO SAY THAT IT IS THAT
PEOPLE WHO EDUCATE STUDENTS. IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THEIR
COLLEGES AND THEY WORK VERY HARD
TO DO SO PLEASE SUPPORT THAT
BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IN THE ON GOING. FUNDING
FOR HEALTHCARE FOR PART TIME.
FACULTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS SHANE THE MANAGER AND
I'M A PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TEACHER AT ORANGE COAST
COLLEGE AND I'M HERE TODAY TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I SOMETIMES
I'M ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR HEALTH
CARE I NEED TO HAVE A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF UNITS TO QUALIFY BUT
EVERY SEMESTER. I'M AT RISK OF
LOSING THAT QUALIFICATION IF MY
CLASSES DON'T BILL OR THE FULL
TIME FACULTY CLASSES DON'T HELP
THEM THEY'LL TAKE MY WORK. FROM
ME AND I WON'T QUALIFY SO I KNOW
IN MY PAST I'VE HAD MEDICAL
SITUATIONS WHERE I'VE REQUIRED
BEING A NUMBER OF DOCTORS AND-
NUMEROUS TESTS. AND IF I HAD NOT
HAD MY COVERAGE IRONICALLY I
WOULD HAVE TO STOP BEING AN
EDUCATOR AND FIND OTHER WORK
THAT I COULD AFFORD HEALTHCARE
IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR EDUCATORS WHO GIVE SO
MUCH. EVERY DAY TO THEIR
STUDENTS AND- IF SUCH WORTHWHILE
WORK I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING HEALTHCARE FOR
OUR PART TWENTY COLLEGE FACULTY. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. NEXT LEVEL TO LINED
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LINDA SNEED AND I'VE
BEEN TEACHING ENGLISH PART TIME
AT CHRISTMAS OF A COLLEGE. TWO
THOUSAND THREE BUT I LIKE SO
MANY PART TIME FACULTY WORK
MULTIPLE ACADEMIC JOB SET UP TO
MORE THAN ONE FULL TIME JOB. I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
ALLOCATION OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO HELP ALL PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HIGH
QUALITY HEALTH CARE. I'M ONE OF
THE LUCKY ONES IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
STAGE FOUR BREAST CANCER. I WAS
ABLE TO GET AN ENTIRE YEAR-
PRETTY MUCH NONSTOP. AFFORDABLE
HIGH QUALITY CANCER TREATMENT TO
MY DISTRICT HEALTHCARE PLAN. I
TALKED TO MY CHEMOTHERAPY
SURGERY AND RADIATION THERAPY.
BUT I LOVE MY JOB AND I LOVE MY
STUDENTS. BUT YOU MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SIMPLY DON'T HAVE COVERAGE.
PLEASE SUPPORT THE LINE ITEM IN
THE BUDGET FOR THE CARE I
RECEIVED. IN THE RULE RATHER
THAN THE EXCEPTION. FOR THE MANY
THOUSANDS OF US ARE CLASSIFIED
AS PART TIME FACULTY. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU CHAIR MCCARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LINDA CHAN I AM A VERY LONG TIME
PART TIME INSTRUCTOR IN
MATHEMATICS AND THE SAN ANTONIO
COLLEGE PASADENA CITY COLLEGE
AND DISTRICT COLLEGE I'M HERE
TODAY TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY. OF WHICH THERE ARE MANY
MANY OF US CAN YOU IMAGINE BEING
A SINGLE PARENT AND RAISING YOUR
CHILD WITHOUT ADEQUATE HEALTH
CARE I'VE HAD MY OWN PHONE GO TO
MILES PER STAY I'VE HAD TO- AND
STILL BE IN MY CLASSROOM AND
GIVE IT A- QUALITY EDUCATION TO
MY STUDENTS. I NEED TO BE
EFFECTIVE. IN MY CUSTOMER ID
GOOD HEALTH CARE. IT IS- HARD
THINGS WHEN YOU CHILD IS ILL YOU
HAVE TO GO TO URGENT CARE. AND
PAY AND THEN DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT YOU HAVE TO. GIVE UP. MY
MEAL OR NOT PAY A BILL. IT AND
I'M NOT ALONE THERE ARE MANY OF
US THAT ARE IN THAT SITUATION. I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED NINE DOLLARS AND FUNDING
HEALTHCARE FOR PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY AND I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANKS FOR THE TO
LINE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU HI I'M CAROL
ABOUT HALF TEN PART TIME FACULTY
AT THE BAY CITY COLLEGE PLEASE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
A TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN ONGOING
HEALTH CARE FUNDING FOR PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY.
I LOVE SERVING MY STUDENTS
HOWEVER WORRYING ABOUT THE
HEALTH CARE AND THE OPEN MARKET
WHICH WILL CERTAINLY CHANGE IS
NOT THE WAY EDUCATORS NEED TO
SPEND OUR TIME OR THE BEST WAY
TO PRIORITIZE AND CURRENT
STUDENT. PLEASE HELP US REGAIN A
SENSE OF DIGNITY IN CONSERVING
AND PRIORITIZING FOR OUR
STUDENTS I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THE FULL TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL FOR PART TIME
HEALTH CARE I ALSO RECENTLY LOST
HEALTH CARE DUE TO THE THING.
WON'T THANK YOU SO MUCH. NOT TO
GO TO LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JOHN HOW
DOES GOD THERE HELLO GERMAN
MCCARTY AND EVERYONE ELSE I'M IN
A PART TIME PHILOSOPHY AND
HUMANITIES AND JUNK PROFESSOR AT
SOUTHWESTERN COLLEGE CITY AND
MIRAMAR COLLEGE. AND I SERVE ON
THE SELECTING COMMITTEE AT THE
OUT OF TOWN FACT THAT WOULD
AFFECT ABOUT I'M HERE TODAY TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS FOR THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FUNDING
FOR HEALTHCARE FOR PART TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY. I
WANT TO SERVE MY STUDENTS IF I
AM SICK ORDER L. THEN I CANNOT
SPARE THEM I AM ONE OF MANY PART
TIMERS WHO DO NOT HAVE HEALTH
CARE WHEN I CANNOT HEAR MY
STUDENTS. AND THEN NOT USING IS
TAKING PLACE HE'LL MONTHS AGO
FOUR MONTHS AGO I HAD TO GO TO A
FEW WHO ARE NOT TO BE SEEN BY A
PHYSICIAN ORDER IT AFFECTION
THAT'S COST ME A HUNDRED TWENTY
DOLLARS TO SEE THE DOCTOR. AND
ANOTHER. FORTY TWO DOLLARS FOR
ANTIBIOTICS. AT ANOTHER VISIT.
PLEASE SUPPORT THE THAT THE
PROPOSED TO. AS YOUNG HELLO. AND
SHE UP TO YOU CARE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT TO THE KLEIN EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI VERY
NASTY AND I'M A PART TIME JOB
DEVELOPMENT INSTRUCTOR AT SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION I'M HERE
TODAY TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE FOR PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY I
AM FORTUNATE TO HAVE HEALTHCARE
CAN MY DISTRICT AND I CARRY THE
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS FOR MY
FAMILY MY HUSBAND HAS
PARKINSON'S DISEASE AND I WORRY
ABOUT LOSING MY DATA BENEFITS
DUE TO- COMPLIMENTS. TOO MANY OF. MY PART TIME FACULTY- CALLING
HAVE HELPED. BUT WHAT STICKS
WITH HEALTHCARE. PART TIMERS AND
IMPROVE THE WORLD MORE I FIRST
YEAR FROM AT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE GO TO LINE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ARE WE NOT TO LINE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO IN
HEARING. YES YES GREAT THANK YOU
HI MY NAME IS MADELINE. HI MY
NAME IS AND I DON'T WANT AND I
AM A LONG TIME PART TIME
INSTRUCTOR AT EL CAMINO COLLEGE
IN TORRANCE CALIFORNIA. AND I'M
HERE TO URGE YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR HEALTH CARE
FOR PARKS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY. EVEN DURING THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC MY DISTRICT. PROVIDES
ALMOST ZERO FUNDING OR
RESOURCES. FOR PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTHCARE. AND IN FACT PART
TIME FACULTY FIND THEMSELVES IN
SIMILAR SITUATIONS AS OUR
STUDENTS. ARE WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS A
SAFETY NET. CLOSING EQUITY GAPS.
WE SERVED THE LARGEST LOW INCOME
NONTRADITIONAL ACADEMICALLY
UNDERSERVED AND FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE. AND THE
BUT THE PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN US
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO SUPPORT
ALL FACULTY IF WE ARE TO TRULY
SUPPORT STUDENT SUCCESS IN
EQUITY. AND YET PART TIME
FACULTY ARE VULNERABLE UNDER
RESOURCE AND ARE THE MOST
IMPACTED BY HEALTH EMERGENCIES.
AND YET WE ARE ALSO THE MOST A
TEACH THE MOST OF A COLLEGE
STUDENT- THESE EQUITY GAP WILL
NOT CLOSE. IT PART TIME FACULTY
DON'T ALSO HAVE EQUITY EQUITY
INCLUDE HEALTH EQUITY AND
FINALLY. IN CONCLUSION PART TIME
EQUITY IS IN EQUITY THANK YOU
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANKS TO
THE TIMELINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS KIM WIDER I
DO THAT ARE SMALL COLLEGE IN EL
CAJON. WE CAN MY CLASSROOM ON A
RATHER REGIS PHILBIN MASK
ARAMBULA RAMP TO DO AN EXAM
REVIEW AS THE GREGIS BUILDING
FROM WHO WANTS TO BE A
PSYCHOLOGY MILLIONAIRE. THE
STUDENTS LOVED IT BUT I'VE
LEARNED THAT ALL OF OUR- HEALTH
CARE. ONE BUDGET YOUR HEART
DRIVE THIS THE I GOT WAS A
CRUTCH THEN CARE WHICH PAID FOR
CONSOLE AN X. RAY AND AN
INJECTION THAT KILLED ME
PERMANENTLY. THAT MY COLLEAGUES
NOT HAVE THIS VITAL PROTECTION.
LATER TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY THANK YOU FROM
ME AND FROM AGREE JUST FELT.
NEXT TO THE TO LINE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS KERRY WASHINGTON AND I'M AN
ADJUNCT INSTRUCTOR WITH SAN
DIEGO COLLEGE OF CONTINUING
EDUCATION. I'M HERE TO STATUS OF
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL INFORMED
GOING FUNDING FOR TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BUT HEALTHCARE
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY BECAUSE I HAVE EXCELLENT
HEALTH CARE I'M MORE IN A
PACKAGE THE STRUCTURE I BELIEVE
ALL ACTION THE HEALTHCARE WITH
THEIR DISTRICTS SO WE CAN BE. AT
OUR BEST FOR OUR STUDENTS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER PLEASE. MEXICO TO
LINE ONE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI THIS IS ARNIE SCHOENBERG
PART TIME AT THE POLICY
PROFESSOR CAN'T BE OPENED LAST
TWENTY TWO YEARS MY WIFE AND I
RELIED ON DISTRICT HEALTH CARE
FOR OVER A DECADE BUT WE'RE
GOING TO LOSE THEIR HEALTH
COVERAGE AT THE END OF THIS
MONTH AND I'M HAVING TO BALANCE
THE EXTRA OFFICE HOURS NEEDED TO
SUPPORT THE STRUGGLE MIGHT. WELL
TRYING TO PACK IN AS MANY
MEDICAL PROCEDURES OF THE
CANDIDATE MONTHS BEFORE **** GOT
ROCKET WILL MEET BY FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA. I JUST GOT BACK FROM
BEING BY LIKE TO THE POINT THAT
THE DOCTOR WAS VERY
ACCOMMODATING LETTING US STOCK
UP ON EXTRA MEDICATION BEFORE
COVERAGE AND BE THE KIND OF
ACCOMMODATIONS LIKE IT MIGHT
STUDENTS TO HELP THEM SUCCEED
AND ASK YOU TO CONTINUE HELPING
US SUCCEED BY SUPPORTING THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. ONGOING
FUNDING FOR PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MEXICO CAROLINA ONE
OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ONE
OF FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE A ONE OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT. YES MY ONE
NIGHT GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
NICOLE AND I'M A PART TIME
ANTHROPOLOGY INSTRUCTOR AT
MISSION COLLEGE AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNMENT'S PROPOSAL FOR TWO
HUNDRED NINETY NINE GOING
HEALTHCARE FUNDING FOR PART TIME
FACULTY IN THE COLLEGE HAS BEEN.
I'VE BEEN EDUCATED BECAUSE WE
CAN'T DO IT VERY LIKELY BUT I'LL
BE FORCED OUT OF PRODUCTION IN
THE FUTURE DEVELOP ACADEMICALLY
PREVENTIVE HEALTH HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE THEREFORE I IMPLORE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONGOING FUNDING COULD
HEALTHCARE GROUP PART TIME.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY THANK
YOU. MEXICO ONE TWO. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
BAKER AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AVE ALONG
WITH CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER
REQUEST THE SENATE INCLUDED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY BUDGET TO
INCREASE STUDENT INVOLVEMENT IN
BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION PROGRAMS
THROUGH THE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF FULL TIME FACULTY
EITHER COLLEGES OF EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN DEALING WITH A
SYSTEMIC REDUCTION OF
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS WITH
BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION WHICH IS
ONLY BEING MADE WORK BY THE
INCREASING TEACHER SHORTAGE. THE
CREATION OF THE PROGRAM WILL
MOVE OUR STATE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BY CREATING MORE
FACULTY WHO WILL BE ABLE TO
OFFER MORE CLASSES IF SUPPORTERS
STUDENT NEARBY BEGINNING A
PROCESS OF REVERSING THAT TREND
THIS FUNDING WOULD BE A WIN FOR
THE CSU A WINNER FOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY A
WIN FOR CALIFORNIA SIGNIFICANT
POPULATION OF ENGLISH LEARNERS.
HOW THEY ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA'S
TOGETHER- GET YOUR SUPPORT A
DIFFICULT OPENING TODAY IF. YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THIS IS
. WHAT YOU CAN APPROACH. OKAY
NEXT WEEK TIMELINE. THANKS FOR
THE TWENTY ONE OH THREE. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I'M SITTING
YOU AT YOUR MCCARTY AND OF THE
ON NAME IS **** AND I HAVE TO
AND AN ADJUNCT INSTRUCTOR IT
COULD COLLEGE OVER TWENTY YEARS
AS A TEMPORARY HIRED OFF AGAIN
ON AGAIN EMPLOYEE I'M ONE OF THE
LUCKY ONES WHO IN MY DISTRICT
DOES QUALIFY FOR BENEFITS
ALTHOUGH OUT OF SEVERAL HUNDRED
FACULTY THAT ARE PART TIME AT
CABRILLO ONLY THIRTY OUT OF
THIS. QUALIFY FOR DISTRICT
BENEFITS SO THAT GIVES YOU AN
IDEA OF THE SCALE OF HOW MANY OF
US ARE NOT COVERED FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS AND THIS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUBSTANTIAL
TO STAY IN THE BUDGET WE NEED TO
GET THIS TO DISTRICTS SO WE CAN
GET THE HEALTH CARE NEEDS TAKING
CARE OF THE MAJORITY OF OUR
FACULTY IN THE SYSTEM BECAUSE
THE MAJORITY OF OUR FACULTY IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DO NOT HAVE
HEALTH COVERAGE TO THE
DISTRICTS. ARE AND THIS IS
SHAMEFUL I BELIEVE SO- TWO
HUNDRED MILLION IS THAT REALLY
GOOD AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR THIS I
REALLY HOPE THAT THAT STAYS IN
THE BUDGET WE NEED EVERY CENT OF
THAT AND WE NEED TO GET MORE OF
OUR PEOPLE COVERED I MAY LOSE MY
BENEFITS THIS SEMESTER BECAUSE I
HAVE A CLASS THE SLOWER ROLL.
AND IT'S ABOUT TO START SOON AND
IF IT'S CANCELED I WILL LOSE MY
BENEFITS AND I HAVE TO LIVE WITH
THAT. TIME TO DO ONE CLASS BEING
LOST AND SO WE JUST NEED TO GET
MORE PEOPLE COVERED WE MOVED
NEED MORE STABLE COVERAGE AND
THIS MONEY WILL REALLY HELP AND
THAT'S WHY I URGE YOU TO KEEP
THIS MONEY IN THE BUDGET. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THINK MEXICO TO
LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DONNA HARRY
I AM A PART TIME ART TEACHER FOR
NORTH ORANGE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ALL OF MY STUDENTS ARE IMMUNO
COMPROMISED AND THEY LIVE IN
SKILLED NURSING OR MEMORY CARE
FACILITIES. THEY RARELY GIVE
VISITORS ARE OUTSIDE CONTACT-
AND MANY OF THEM TELL ME THAT
THEIR CLASS THAT THAT MY CLASSES
ARE THE HIGHLIGHT OF THEIR WEEK.
BECAUSE THEY ARE. I'M NOT
COMPROMISED I HAVE TO SAY MY
HEALTHIEST OR ELSE I CAN
LITERALLY ENDANGER THEM. I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED
MILLIONDOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING TO HEALTHCARE OUR PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE TIMELINE
WHO WON FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE FIFTEEN LINES OPEN.
NOT TO LINE AT ONE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN PARTY AND THAT BIRDS
CONSULTATION ON BEHALF OF THAT
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
I'M PROVIDING PUBLIC TODAY ON
THREE KEY BUDGET PRIORITIES THAT
WE FEEL WILL YOU OPEN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION. FIRST WE URGE POLICY
MAKERS TO EMBRACE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED MULTI YEAR COMPAQ I
THINK THAT WOULD BE PERFECT
POLITICS HUMAN CALL ALLOWING
CALIFORNIA TO PROPHETICALLY
ADDRESSED IN. A LIMITED EQUITY
CAPITAL GRADUATION RATE. WE
INCREASING OF PUMPING TO GROW
CALIFORNIA STUDENT INFO AT THE
IF YOU THE WILL BE INTEGRAL
MEETING A PAYMENT CALL. CAN'T WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT A NUMBER OF KEY
INVESTMENT THE STRENGTH YOU CAN
POPULATE THE WIRELESS
CONNECTION. BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
IN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AT FIFTY
FIVE MILLION TICKETS RIGHT
TRANSPORT FOUR HUNDRED FIVE
BILLION TO MAKE CONCOURSE NUMBER
EIGHT AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO
PROCURE AND IMPLEMENT SOFTWARE.
ABOUT INTERSECT MENTAL PATHWAYS
BOTH. EXTREME ONE TRANSFER
BETWEEN. THIRD IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PAY THE LEDGE A COULD LEADERS ON
. AID TO PASS YEAR'S BY. PARKING
DOCUMENTS FROM OVER A HUNDRED
NEW POWERTRAIN AWARDS ABOUT-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE NEW
ONGOING RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THE CONTRACT WITH THE FRAMEWORK.
WILL BE SIMPLIFIED PROGRESS
PROFIT CAN GREATLY EXPAND. EIGHT
O'CLOCK THANK YOU. FOR THE TWO
LINES OF ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO IF IT TURNS OUT THE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION. RIGHT AFTER
THE ORGANIZATION WITH A
MEMBERSHIP COMPRISED OF CURRENT
AND FORMER BOSS YOU GET ON BOTH
THE FORMER BOSS YOU'VE BEEN A
LONG NIGHT OUT THE BULLET AND
GARDENS COLLEGE PROGRAM WE ARE
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR FUNDING
FOR FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAMS AT THE
PEW PEW. THANKS WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED
ALLOCATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EXPANDING OPTIONS
FOR ACTIVITY COLLEGES HOWEVER WE
WOULD LIKE TO KEEP IT INCREASE
TO TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ALLOW FAUCI THE CROP THE WHOLE
STATE TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUCCEED IN COLLEGE WE HOPE THAT
ALL YOUTH IMPACTED BY
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AND FOR JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND HAVE HE CHANCE ACTIVE.
SUPPORT SERVICES THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CHAIR-
CARTY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS JENNIFER MALEY THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION- JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MINUTE TO ADDRESS
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
JANUARY BUDGET AND THAT'S
FUNDING PER HOUR YOU SEE LABOR
STANDARDS. AT FINDING IT'S BEEN
FLAT SINCE TWO THOUSAND- DESPITE
A GROWING INTEREST IN OUR LABOR
STUDIES PROGRAM. ALSO THERE IS A
NEW LABOR CENTER AT UC MERCED.
AND THERE IS A LONGSTANDING
NEEDED FOR GREATER LABOR
RESEARCH EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
SERVICE. IN THE STATES THAT
FIRST REGION. FELL AT THE
CURRENT CAPACITY LABOR CENTERS
CANNOT MEET ALL THE DEMANDS FOR
THEIR WORK AND WE OBVIOUSLY THE
GOVERNING BODY AND- ALL OF US
THAT WORK IN POLICY REALLY RELY
ON THE CRITICAL RESEARCH THAT
THEY PROVIDE. WE ARE ASKING FOR
AN ADDITIONAL TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO SUPPORT THAT
LABOR CENTERS- NOT JUST AT UC
BERKELEY AND UCLA BUT ALSO AT UC
MERCED AND THE OTHER USER FEES.
OUR RECORD LOOKING TO EXPAND
THEIR LABOR. STUDIES AND PAPERS
GRAHAM. HI MOM AND HAVE A ONE
NIGHT. THANKS TO THE TO LINE THE
ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE TWENTY AIRLINES OPEN. MONTEL LINE AT ONE THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD SURE- MY NAME'S
BECKY SKINNER IN ROOMS I'M AN
ADJUNCT TO HELP FROM A PART TIME
FACULTY COUNTERACTED REAL
COLLEGE. I'M HERE TO ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR AN N. TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS NON GOING FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE FOR PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY.
I AM DISABLED. AND IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
WORKING. WITH MY AMAZING STUDENT
. IT IS CRITICAL THAT I HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE. TAKE A LOT OF
MEDICATION CAN BE A LOT OF DR.
AND AS AN EXAMPLE JUST ONE OF MY
CRITICAL MEDICATIONS ARE. AROUND
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR- I'M THANKFUL AND GRATEFUL
THAT CURRENTLY HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE IF YOU CAN BRIO.
HOWEVER IF I DROP BELOW A
CERTAIN WORKLOAD- I COULD LOSE
THAT AND- THAT IS SCARY. AND
ALSO IT'S A LIMITED INCOME AS AN
ADJUNCT THE COST FOR A
HEALTHCARE IS PROHIBITED. AND
YET AND THE DISABLED PERSON- I
CAN'T AFFORD NOT TO HAVE IT. AS
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THAT- I KNOW A
LOT OF ADJUNCT AND PART TIME
FACULTY WHO DON'T HAVE THAT. AND
SO I ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT
HEALTHCARE FOR ADJUNCT FOR PART
TIME FACULTY. IT IS SO IMPORTANT
TO ME AND MY FAMILY AND SHE'LL.
ARE HELLO PART TIME FACULTY SO
THAT WE CAN DO THE JOB OF
SHOWING UP. AND BEING THERE AND
BEING PRESENT FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND DOING THE WORK AT SOME POINT
IN JULY- I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANKS FOR
THE TIME LINE OF ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATIE
HARTMAN AT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION PTA
APPRECIATE MANY OF THE
INVESTMENT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET RELATED TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES INCLUDING THAT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION FOR PART TIME
FACULTY HEALTH INSURANCE. AND
THE FIVE POINT 3% COLA WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
TODAY AROUND PART TIME FACULTY
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE FURTHER SUPPORT FOR PART
TIME FACULTY AND INCREASE.
FUNDING FOR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. DUE TO RISING COSTS
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
HEAR ME. YEAH. YES GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
THIS IS RAMONA LOPEZ I'M IN
THERE I THANK BACK LOOKING AT
FULLERTON COLLEGE AMOUNT OF THE
PORT THE GOVERNORS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ONGOING FUNDING FOR
HEALTH CARE TO A JUNK FACULTY
MEMBERS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I'M SPEAKING FOR MYSELF MY
COLLEAGUES IN OTHER FACULTY WHO
HAVE HAVE EXPERIENCED MY
PERSONAL STORY OF DECIDING TO
STAY HOME AND DYING WITH A
SEVERE KOBE. NINETEEN CONDITION
. RATHER THAN MY FAMILY WITH A
HUGE HOSPITAL BILL. WE ARE
REFERRING AT THE CENTRAL WORKERS
IT'S CRITICAL THAT EACH CENTRAL
WORKERS SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS JESSICA PETRO JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR USE WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR FUNDING FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAM AT THE CSU AND UC SYSTEM
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED
ALLOCATION OF TEN MILLION
CORRECT FOSTER YOUTH THE POOR AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THIS INCREASE TO TWENTY
MILLION TO ALLOW FOSTER YOUTH
ACROSS THE WHOLE STATE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO SUCCEED IN
COLLEGE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN CARTY
AND MEMBERS RON RAPP SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS SUPPORT OF
AN ONGOING COMMITMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM AT STUDENTS AND FACULTY
SPECIFICALLY WE SUPPORT THE
INCREASED ONGOING INVESTMENT IN
BASE FUNDING AND THE CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING. FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
PROPOSED 5% INCREASE IN
UNRESTRICTED BASE FUNDING
HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
THAT THIS AMOUNT BE INCREASED IT
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE CS
YOU CAN FULLY ADDRESS FACULTY
AND STAFF COMPENSATION. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR HIS PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE THE
INVESTMENT AND PORTABLE STUDENT
HOUSING WE'D LIKE TO SEE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO BE USED
FOR A PORTABLE FACULTY HOUSING
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS STRUGGLE-
SIGNIFICANTLY- TO FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS GREGORY SANCHEZ
AND I AM CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS THAT GET
YOUR RIVERSIDE I'M ALSO A%
VETERAN AND GRADUATE GRADUATE OF
VETERANS TREATMENT COURT. I
LOOKED IN THE MILITARY RIGHT
AFTER NINE ELEVEN AND THE
FREQUENTLY I WAS EXPOSED TO THE
HEINOUS HEINOUS ATROCITIES OF
WAR AND I LIVE WITH SERVICE
CONNECTED PTSD AT A 100% I FOUND
MYSELF ARRESTED AND CHARGED AND
CONVICTED OF THREE FELONIES. TO
WHICH I WASN'T PUT INTO THE
VETERANS TREATMENT COURT WITH
YOU WITH THE AGREEMENT THAT I
WOULD RETURN TO COLLEGE I NOW
HOLD A FOUR POINT OH GPA I PLAN
ON GOING TO GRADUATE SCHOOL
AFTER I COMPLETE MY
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE I HAVE SEEN
WHAT UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
INITIATIVE HAS DONE NOT ONLY FOR
MYSELF BUT FOR ALL MY FRIENDS
AND COLLEAGUES. IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE CONTINUE ONGOING SUPPORT
FOR THE FORMING CARS TRADED AND
JUSTIN EFFECT THE PEOPLE OF OUR
GREAT STATE THANK YOU SO MUCH
PLEASE I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
. THE YOU. NEXT TO THE TO LINE
ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHERYL CARTY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS I'M OUT OF HERE AND I'M
THE VICE PRESIDENT WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE WITH HEALTHY THAT'S
USUALLY REPRESENTED NEARLY HALF
A MILLION YES YOU SHOULD. I'M
CALLING IN TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
PEACE YOU BOARD OF TRUSTEES
BUDGET REQUESTS THAT ARE
PREACHED IN THE INVESTING
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR THAT'S
FAR ARTICULATELY FUNDING THAT
SUPPORTS THE ACADEMIC SUCCESS
AND OVERALL WELL BEING OF OUR
HALF MILLION. IT'S JUST. THIS
INCLUDES THE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS. TECHNOLOGY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAMS. ALL WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US ACROSS THE- SHE
IS ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONTRACT WE BRING WORK TO ENSURE
THAT FINANCIAL AID WORK FOR OUR
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR CONTINUES ADDED TO
THE CART. NEXT TO THE O LINE
THE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHARLES
RIGHT ON THE HALF OF THE SEATS
IN PALM DESERT. THE COACHELLA
VALLEY IS GRATIFIED TO LEARN
THAT UNEXPECTED STRONG REVENUES
HAVE RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN HIGHER EDUCATION
FUNDING WHICH ALIGNS WITH THE
BUDGET ACT QUEST. FOR
SIGNIFICANT ENROLLMENT GROWTH IN
THE SYSTEM. BUT ON THE OTHER
CAMPUS IN A COACHELLA VALLEY AT
THE HIGHEST POTENTIAL CURRENT
MOMENT GROWTH AND IT'S THE MOST
UNDERSERVED REGION IN CALIFORNIA
. WITH THE ISSUE SYSTEM. IT'S
BEEN A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ACRES
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO WITH THE
CITY OF PALM DESERT BUT THE
SPIRIT AND VISION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION CAREER REACHING. I
DIDN'T THINK IT ALERTS BUILT FOR
BUILDINGS FOR STUDENTS TO SEE
THE EDUCATION THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISES. OUR CAMPUS NEED TO
STUDENT SUCCESS CENTER TO CREATE
THE COLLEGE EXPERIENCE FOR
STUDENTS TODAY DON'T KNOW WHAT
HE COLLEGE EXPERIENCES. WITH
SCENIC WINE AND STUDENT SUCCESS
CENTER WILL BRIDGE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE AND CREATE CAMPUS
ACCEPTABLE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
ONE HUNDRED FORTY ACRES REMAIN
BOTH SHOVEL WORTHY AND SHOVEL
READY AND POISED TO MAKE AN
IMMEDIATE AND ONGOING IMPACT ON
OUR REGION. WE'VE DONE THE PALM
DESERT CAMPUS AND STUDENT
SUCCESS CENTER. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR NUMBER. WE'VE CALLED. NEXT
TO GO TO LINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I FELT LIKE A HUNDRED
HI MY NAME IS BILLY ANGEL I'M AN
UNDERGRAD AT UCLA AND I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS. I AM A
PARENTING STUDENT OUR SYSTEM
IMPACTED AND FORMERLY
INCARCERATED AND- ARE YOU
FAMILIAR WITH WRITING COLLEGE
BOUND IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEVEL COMING INTO YOUR FEET.
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS HAVE BEEN.
THE ONLY THING THAT HELPS ME
STAY AFLOAT- THAT'S WHAT HELPED
ME FIND COMMUNITY AND EMPOWERED
ME TO CONTINUE ON- INTERPERSONAL
PHD AFTER MY UNDERGRAD I THINK A
LOT OF US ARE STUDENTS HAVE FOR
MANY INTERSECTING IDENTITIES BUT
ONE THING THAT PREVAILED OVERALL
AT. FOR MYSELF- BEING SYSTEM
IMPACTED FORMALLY INCARCERATED-
PROGRAM IS SO IMPORTANT AND US
GETTING THE FUNDING IS STILL
NEEDED- BECAUSE- IT DOESN'T JUST
EMPOWER US EIGHT. EMPOWERS THE
NEXT GENERATION MY HUSBAND WAS
JUST RECENTLY RELEASED LAST
MONTH AND- NOW WE'LL BE
CONTINUING ON- INTO SCHOOL AND
PROGRAMS LIKE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS ARE CHANGING THE
NARRATIVE OUR CHILDREN. I LIVE
VERY MUCH URGE THIS PROPOSAL TO
BE CONSIDERED- COUNTLESS
FAMILIES WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS
TREMENDOUSLY THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SHANE QUITE HI THANKS TO YOU SEE
AS A STUDENT AND RETURN TO THE
TEACHER EXCEPT THAT EVEN ITS
PUBLIC MISSION. I MENTOR MANY
CHRIS GENERATION
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS. A CURRENT STUDENT BODY
INCLUDES THE HIGHEST PROPORTION
TO UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
PHYSICALLY DISADVANTAGED. AND
FIRST GEN STUDENTS IN OUR
DISTRICT. YOU SEE SOME PARALLELS
ENGINE THE SOCIAL MOBILITY TYPE
OF JUSTICE AND THE STATE
ECONOMY. ACCESS ADMITTING A
STUDENT IS A ONE TIME MOMENT BUT
THE REGISTRATION MUST ALSO BE
SUPPORTED THROUGH THEIR
GRADUATION. FUNDING TO SUPPORT
STUDENT PROGRESSION AND SUCCESS
WELL I THINK THE GOALS OF THE
STATE UNIVERSITY IN PEOPLE.
FORGET TO GO ABOUT YOUR
BUDGETING IS NEEDED SO THE
UNIVERSITY CAN BEST PROVIDE
ACCESS AFFORDABILITY ACADEMIC
QUALITY TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
YOUTH AND STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT HE'S HE'S
FUNDING REQUESTS FROM THE STATE
BUDGET. I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE INVESTMENTS COMPOSED OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INTRODUCTION
AND I HOPE THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL AS BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU. THANKS TO THE TO LINE ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD- HELLO AT
YOUR MCCARTY AND I'M WITH THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS GEORGE
ASHFORD I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF GENERATION UP WHICH IS
A STUDENT LED EDUCATION AFTER
THE ORGANIZATION- AND I'M HERE
TO BOYS I CANNOT SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. UP TO A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PART TIME-
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE FACULTY
HEALTH CARE- YOU'VE HEARD A LOT
TODAY FOR PROFESSORS ABOUT THE
IMPACT THAT THE CURRENT LACK OF
SUPPORT OUT ON THEM- I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THE IMPACT THE TRANSFER DISPUTE-
YOU KNOW NO MATTER HOW MUCH
THESE INCREDIBLE PETER
SACRIFICE- SOMEONE WHO HAD. IT
MAILED A MEDICAL BILL IT'S NEVER
REALLY GOING TO STRUGGLE TO
DEVOTE THE TIME DETENTION OF
THEIR STUDENTS THAT WE NEED TO
THRIVE- I'VE BEEN LUCKY TO HAVE
MANY TEACHERS WHO TRULY CHANGED
MY LIFE AND HELP ME BECOME THE
PERSON I AM TODAY. AND
EVERYTHING THAT THEY WERE ABLE
TO HAVE THAT IMPACT IT'S BECAUSE
OF THEIR PERSONAL INVESTMENT
NEEDS ME WE NEED TO DO IT- IF WE
WANT PART TIME PROFESSORS AT THE
TIKI WHO MAKE UP A HUGE PORTION
THE FACULTY BE ABLE TO MAKE ALL
KINDS OF TRANSFORMATIVE
INVESTMENT INCLUDING. WE HAVE TO
INVEST IN THEM AGAIN I HAVE TO
BE APPROVED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL UP TO A MILLION DOLLARS. AFTER PARK AND BACK THE
HEALTHCARE. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
OVER THE LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. JAPANESE SHARE NUMBERS
GAMING SANTIAGO ON BEHALF OF
CALIBRATE COLLEGE WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THANK YOU.
RIGHT. NEXT DEADLINE ONE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. HELLO. YOU HEAR ME
YES GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MCCARTY
AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SHARON MERIT AND I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
TEACHER EDUCATION WORKSHOP DAY
AND A RETIRED ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR OF TEACHER EDUCATION
AT FRESNO PACIFIC UNIVERSITY I'M
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
COGSTATE BILINGUAL TEACHER
EDUCATORS ACROSS HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
REQUESTING THAT THE SENATE
INCLUDE A TWENTY FIVE MILLION
APPROPRIATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY BUDGET TO
INCREASE STUDENT ENROLLMENT IN
BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION PROGRAM
. COULD AND RETENTION OF FULL
TIME FACULTY IN THE COLLEGES OF
EDUCATION. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
DEALING WITH THE GROWING
STATEWIDE SYSTEMIC NEED FOR
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS WITH
BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION WHICH IS
ONLY BEING MADE WORSE BY THE
INCREASING TEACHER SHORTAGE
ACROSS THE STATE AND THE GROWTH
OF BILINGUAL PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
DISTRICT SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
PROP FIFTY EIGHT. THE GLOBAL
CALIFORNIA TWENTY THIRTY
INITIATIVE PROJECT THE NEED FOR
TWO THOUSAND NEW CREDENTIALED
BILINGUAL TEACHERS EACH YEAR BY
TWENTY THIRTY. THE CREATION OF
THE EIGHTY SEVEN YOU KNOW ONE
JUMP START PROGRAM OF HIRING NEW
FACULTY FULL TIME FACULTY WILL
MOVE OUR STATE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BY CREATING. MORE
FACULTY LINE FILLED WITH HIGHLY
QUALIFIED FACULTY WHO WILL BE
ABLE TO OFFER MORE CLASSES AND
SUPPORT STUDENT. THERE BY
BEGINNING THE PROCESS OF
REVERSING THIS TREND. THIS WOULD
BE A WIN FOR THE CSU A WIN FOR
OUR K. TWELVE SCHOOL SYSTEM BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY A WIN FOR
CALIFORNIA'S SIGNIFICANT
POPULATION OF ENGLISH LEARNER.
ON BEHALF OF CUPCAKES I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
FUNDING TO THE CSU SYSTEM. AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
AFTERNOON. WELL TO ALIGN THE ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ADRIAN I
SAID I DID NOT UNDERSTAND I'M A
LECTURER AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY BAKERSFIELD
SUPPORTING PRE SERVICE TEACHERS
ALONG WITH CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER
IN THE JUMP START PROGRAM AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY I
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO REQUESTED
THAT INCLUDED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION APPROPRIATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BUDGET TO INCREASE STUDENT
ENROLLMENT. SPECIFICALLY IN
BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION PROGRAM
THROUGH THE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF FULL TIME FACULTY
WITHIN THEIR RESPECTIVE COLLEGES
OF EDUCATION. CALIFORNIA HAS
CONTINUED TO BE EXPERIENCING THE
SYSTEMIC PRODUCTION A
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS THAT HAVE
THIS SPECIALLY BILINGUAL
AUTHORIZATION AND IT'S ONLY IT'S
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
INCREASING. TEACHER JORDANS. WE
KNOW THAT THE CREATION OF THIS
PROGRAM WOULD MOVE OUR STATE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION BY PROVIDING
THESE OPPORTUNITIES. AND
REVERSING THIS TREND. THIS
FUNDING WOULD BE A GREAT WIN FOR
THIS YES YOU BUT PARTICULARLY
FOR K. TWELVE STUDENTS- THAT ARE
OFTHE ENGLISH LEARNER OUR
ENGLISH LEARNER POPULATION ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPANY TAKING
OVER CITY BAKERSFIELD ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
FUNDING TO SEE IF THE SYSTEM.
AND I LIKED IT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THIS AFTERNOON. THANKS
FOR THE TIP LINE ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME MY IMPACT HEAT THEY
CANNOT FORMALLY INCARCERATED
DOCTORAL STUDENT AND AN
ASSOCIATE INSTRUCTOR TELL YA GET
YOU KEEP AT IT I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT ON GOING FUNDING FOR THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE.
I CO FOUNDED A CHAPTER AT UC
DAVIS BECAUSE I THOUGHT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING ON OTHER CAMPUSES
THE GREAT BRITAIN'S SCHOOL
PIPELINE RIGHT UP OUR STREET IT
BEATERS BUT SUPPORTING EDUCATING
AND EMPOWERING THEM BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER. COLLEGE I'M I
WAS I THINK HERS RATED OVER
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO AND I
GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE IN TWENTY
ELEVEN. I NEVER MET ANYONE WITH
BACKGROUND I COULD REALLY RELATE
TO SO YOU THINK THAT THE MORE
INSPIRING EMPOWERING IT'S THE
GROWING NUMBER DEPARTMENT
INCARCERATED SCHOLAR GRADUATE UP
TO SUPPORT EACH OTHER AND MAKE
THEIR VOICES HEARD AT THE TIME
OF THE PUBLIC IS DEBATING. THE
FUTURE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. WE'RE OFTEN NETWORKING
WITH EACH OTHER BECAUSE THE PAIN
COUNTRY SHARING INFORMATION AND
RESOURCES ABOUT EVERYTHING ABOUT
FOR MAKING IT THROUGH COLLEGE
AND PART OF OUR GRAD SCHOOL TO
GETTING A JOB EVERY PENNY THAT
TAXPAYER THAN THAT AN
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WILL BE MULTIPLIED. ANY
INVESTMENT WILL PAY DIVIDENDS
FOR GENERATIONS. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND SPOKE. THANKS FOR
THE TIME AT FOUR. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. H. R. MOUTH DROPPED AT
YOUR PROFESSOR FOR TWENTY SIX
YEARS IN LOS ANGELES ONE OF MY
AGENT COLLEAGUES HAS MISSING
TEETH BECAUSE HE HAS TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN DENTAL CARE AND FEEDING
HIS CHILDREN. I MYSELF PAY TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS OUT OF POCKET
FOR DENTAL BECAUSE I WASN'T
COVERED FOR SIX MONTHS AT ONE
POINT SH DO YOU REALLY WANT
TEACHERS UNDERGOING CHEMOTHERAPY
DRAGGING THEMSELVES INTO THE
CLASSROOM BECAUSE IF THEY STOP
TEACHING THEY'LL LOSE THEIR
INSURANCE. SUPPORT FUNDING TO
PROVIDE ONGOING HEALTHCARE FOR
EDGE OF PROFESSORS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. SHE THE
NEXT LINE ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I THINK
ULTIMATELY HAVE THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE GREAT FOR
THE PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FOR PART TIME FACULTY HEALTHCARE
WOULD BE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT FOR PART OF BOXING
RECENT HISTORY AND WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO ADOPT THE
PROPOSAL. WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS TO AMEND THE
FUNDING FORMULA PROVISIONS BUT
WE ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO
CONSIDER ADOPTING FOR ADDING A
COLOR THE FUNDING FOR PROPOSAL
INCLUDES ARE INCREASING THE COLD
KEEP UP WITH INFLATION. FINALLY
REPUGNANT CATIONS THE THIRTEEN
FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR STUDENTS
AND WE'RE ASKING FOR FURTHER
INVESTMENTS INCLUDING FIFTY
MILLION FOR UPS PRISTINE
RECRUITMENT ENTERTAINMENT
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO MEET
THE PROGRAMS TO EXPAND ALL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND THIRTY
MILLION AND ONE TIME NUMBER FIVE
YEARS FOR THE CREATION OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENT COURT IN
PROTEST PROGRAMME TWENTY
COLLEGES IN A COURT. MEETING YOU
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET PROCESS
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LOOKING AT ME. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN REGARDING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GAMERS ALL US I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS INITIATIVE THE UC
IRVINE AND I'M A GRADUATE
STUDENT IN THE DOCTORAL PROGRAM
ALONG WITH BEING FORMALLY
INCARCERATED AND IN RECOVERY
FROM SUBSTANCE USE A TEACHER
REHABILITATIVE CLASS IN A
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON I'M ALSO
ON THE STEERING COMMITTEE FOR
THE FIRST YOU SEE VESSELS
PROGRAM IN A CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON TO USE YOUR VOTE. NOT
ONLY AM I A RECIPIENT OF THE
BENEFITS OF THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS PROGRAM OF SUPPORT ME
NOT ONLY COMMUNITY BUT ACADEMIC
HELP AND ENCOURAGEMENT I'M ALSO
HONORED TO SHARE THE SUPPORT
INSPIRATION WITH MY STUDENTS IN
PRISON WHO ARE CURRENTLY GETTING
EDUCATED YOU PLAN TO MATRICULATE
TO UC ONCE RELEASED SO I'M
ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THE FOUR
MILLION REQUESTS FOR THE
UNDERGROUND COLLEGE BECAUSE
THEY'RE OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
INCARCERATED STUDENTS IN STATE
PRISONS RIGHT NOW WE'RE TAKING
YOU SEE TRANSFERABLE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROGRAM. UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS IS THE ONLY PROGRAM
THAT EQUIPPED TO SUPPORT THEM
AND SUCCESSFULLY BEING ACCEPTED
TO AND GRADUATING FROM UC CAMPUS
YOU'VE ALREADY MADE THE
INVESTMENT OFFER THEM COMMITTEE
COLLEGE COURSES NOW WE'RE ASKING
YOU. TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO TAKE THE NEXT STEP IN
TRANSFERRED TO UC. CAMPUS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FREE TIME TO WORK.
THANKS TO A TWO LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD- ARGUMENT. LOOK. HELLO YES GO AHEAD OKAY HI-
GRAPPLING GERMAN ACCORDION
BETWEEN THE NUMBERS- MY NAME'S
OF THE LOCKERS- LIKE FUNGI-
ALEXANDER THAT I USE TO BERKELEY
I'LL START AND A BIT OF DUNDEE
BOX CUTTERS- AND NOW I'M ON
GRADUATE STUDENT. AT UCLA
WELCOME BACK TO THE SOCIAL WORK
ALSO SUPPORTED BY THE
UNDERGROUND BECAUSE JAPANESE
SURELY AND ARE HERE TO ADVOCATE.
FOR THE FOUR MILLION- WHAT
QUESTION AND YOU WANT TO SAY
LIKE IF THEY WANT TO PUT PEOPLE
ON THE BOX CUTTERS THAT ME
CONNECT WITH. LIKE GOING- AND
OTHER THAN THE PROJECTS AND WALK
HI. MICHELLE A I. NONE OF US THE
ONLY I WILL CONNECT WITH. AND
MANY FEEL ALIVE YOU KNOW I TO
MAKE A COLLEGE. AND I COULD KEEP
GOING. M. ONE OF MANY MANY GO TO
GRAD SCHOOL AND NOW I'M ABOUT TO
GRADUATE- FROM GRASSROOTS JONES.
AND I WAS SPORTING A LOT OF
PEOPLE PLACES. IN TOP OF THAT
SCHOOL YEAH I JUST FEEL LIKE YOU
WERE FIVE OF US POSITIVE. WHAT
ARE YOU ASKING FOR THAT MUCH.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT BUT I WILL DO
SO MUCH MORE. YOU KNOW AND I
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW THE TIME
HEARING ABOUT. AND NOW EVEN WHEN
I PUSH. THE GARDEN VIEW WITH
MORE THAN. FOUR MILLION IN
NINETEEN. TEN AND NOT TO GIVE.
NEXT LINE THE ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND HAPPY
VALENTINE'S DAY EVERYONE I'M IN
THE HEARTLAND AND I'VE BEEN A
PART TIME TEACHER FOR THE SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS. I EARNED
BENEFITS AFTER SEVEN YEARS AND I
WAS ONE OF THE FORTUNATE FEW
HOWEVER MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA DO NOT HAVE
BENEFITS AND MUST WORK AT MORE
THAN ONE DISTRICT OR
HABITATIONAL JOB TO PAY THEIR
BILLS AND THEY HAVE NO CHANCE OF
GETTING BENEFITS UNLESS YOU
SUPPORT THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
FUNDING FOR PART TIME FACULTY
HEALTH CARE. FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. IT IS AN ART FORM.
THAT INTEREST TO BE SURE THEIR
TEACHERS HAVE BENEFITS AND
CREATE ACTIVITY AMONGST OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. JUST LIKE
OUR STUDENTS THE TEACHERS GET
STRESSED OUT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE THE HEALTHCARE RESOURCES.
TO PERFORM THEIR BEST IN CLASS.
WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT SO WE CAN
FOCUS ON TRAINING SUPPORTING AND
ENCOURAGING OUR CURRENT AND
FUTURE STUDENT. LEADERS AND
POLITICIANS THANK YOU WHAT IS
RIGHT AND SUPPORT THE PLIGHT OF
OUR ATTENTION CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT TO THE TO LINE
ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES MY
NAME IS MEGAN BROWN I'M A MEMBER
OF UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AT UCLA
SAID WITH IMPACTED STUDENTS BE
REASON OF THIS FUNCTIONAL FAMILY
GAVE ME A UNIQUE UNDERSTANDING
OF LIFE BUT THE RESORT WILL NOT
KNOWING WHAT A STABLE LIFE FELT
LIKE EDUCATION BECAUSE HE BECAME
A CELEBRATION IS ABOVE
PORTABILITY TO MY LIFE GLOBAL
UNDERGROUND COLORS THAT HAVE
BEEN DIGNIFIED HUMAN LIFE ONCE
AGAIN. HELLO THERE WELCOME
OTHERS THEM NOW I'M MAKING
SCHOLAR READER WRITER AND
RESEARCHER AND I'M OF THE PUBLIC
PERSONA GREATNESS WHAT THE
COMPLETE MY UNDERGRADUATE CAREER
HERE AT UCLA HE ALREADY MADE THE
INVESTMENT THROUGH BOTH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN KELTY
SYSTEMS BUT THE POINT OF THE
CROSS BECAUSE THE NATION AND THE
REQUEST WAS TO FOUR MILLION YOU
WILL BE CLOSING THE GAP TO
HIGHER EDUCATION BUT SUPPORTING
CORPORATE CULTURE IS A SYSTEM
IMPACT THE STUDENTS AT THE. UC
LEVEL THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME
OUT. THANKS TO THE TO LINE ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YEAH HI I'M JULIE JONES
ARE PART TIME. FACULTY AT GREEN
MOUNTAIN POWER COLLEGES IN SAN
DIEGO. YOUR SUPPORT FOR A PART
TIME HEALTH CARE FOR THE FUNDING
FOR PART TIME HEALTH CARE IS
ESSENTIAL I'VE LOCKED MY
FAMILY'S HEALTH INSURANCE TWICE
IN THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
BECAUSE OF THE BUDGET CUTS I CAN
NO LONGER GET ENOUGH TRACTION
BUT ANY ONE SCHOOL TO QUALIFY
FOR IT AND I NEVER KNOW FROM
SEMESTER TO SEMESTER IF I WILL
HAVE INSURANCE. I HAVE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS THAT AFFECT MY
ABILITY TO BE WITH MY STUDENTS
AND I'M HONESTLY DESPERATE FOR
THIS LEGISLATION TO PASS SO I
ASK YOU PLEASE TO SUPPORT IT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CARING
ABOUT YOUR ACTION FACULTY.
NECKED WITH LINE AT ONE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS LOUIS MINUTES FROM THE HOUSE
WHAT ABOUT THOUGHT THAT YOU GET
LAID. OR MEET CUSTOMER DISPUTE
IN IN A SINGLE FATHER VOICE
BROUGHT THE WHOLE USE YEP CASE
OF PROFIT I RECEIVE A
CONDITIONAL SUPPORT FROM THE
PROGRAM. AM I RIGHT WHAT UCLA
THEY NEED ANY HELP WITH THE CARE
HOW CAN I HELP YOU CONNECT TO
SERVICES HELPING STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENTS. BOTH FIGHTING CALLED
AN UNDERCUT CALLERS HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL TO MY ACADEMIC THE PATH
OF RIDING WITHOUT MAKING ANY IN
THEIR SUPPORT I WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN LOCKED ON STREET.
REPAIR PLAN ON ATTENDING GRAD
SCHOOL AND CONTINUE TO PAVE THE
WAY FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS ARE
DUE TO SUPPORT THE UNDERGROUND
COLLEGE FOUR MILLION ON GOING
FUNDING OUTLINED IN THE REGION
BUT GET BETTER SUPPORT ONLY
CURSORY DIDN'T. THE DEMOCRATIC
STUDENT AT THE YOUTH LEVEL THE
IMPACT WILL BE MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY THANKS A COUPLE
POSITIVELY IMPACT THE LIVES OF
THOSE WHAT PART OF THE PROGRAM
THEIR. FAMILIES AND THE
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. NEXT TO THE
TIME ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JULIE
HANSEN AND I AM AN ADJUNCT AT-
SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT GROSSMONT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT UCSD EXTENSION
AND THAT THE ISSUE. AND SO I'M
SORT OF A FREQUENT FLYER
ALTHOUGH ALL WE'VE BEEN ONLINE
BUT IN ANY EVENT I JUST WANTED
TO TELL YOU THAT I DID AFTER
TWENTY YEARS OF TEACHING ADJUNCT
AT SEC PD- MY BENEFITS WERE CUT
BECAUSE IT DID LOAD WAS NOT
LARGE ENOUGH. FOR ME TO HAVE
BENEFITS AND IT WAS A HUGE
SURPRISE AND SO I WENT TO GROWTH
MUCH TRYING. TO GET THE BENEFITS
SERVICE THAT. SHOP GAP MEASURE
QUEBEC TO KILL THAN ANY- IT WAS
GONNA COST ME- MY ENTIRE
TEACHING SALARY FOR THE MONTH-
AFFORD TO HEALTH INSURANCE SO
LUCKILY I WAS PICKED UP BY AT
THE ISSUE BUT- I REALIZE THAT
NOT EVERYONE HAS THAT LUXURY- SO
I WAS. ALMOST IN A REALLY BAD
SITUATION. BUT I WAS GRATEFUL
THAT I GOT PICKED UP BUT ANYWAY
I JUST REALLY CANNOT TELL YOU
THAT LIKE HEALTHCARE IT'S BEEN
NUMBER ONE CONCERN. FOR ADJUNCTS
AND YOU'VE HEARD IT TIME AND
TIME AGAIN SO I JUST WANTED TO
REITERATE IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR LISTENING. NEXT TO THE
TO LINE A ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I. ONE SIXTY FOUR. YES
MY ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD ALSO ALL APOLOGIES MY NAME
IS ONE OF THE MANY OUTSIDE I'M
NOT I'M I'M AN ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR OF SCIENCE AT THE
UNIVERSITY WHEN I CALLED IN AND
IT COULD BE PROBABLY MORE OF
SUCH A MEETING WITH LOCAL PCS
I'M ALSO WE USE- COPTER AND
CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER FIRST OF
ALL I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
SOLIDARITY TO THE PEOPLE BUT
CALLED REGARDING- REGARDING THE
D. GET BENEFITS FOR OUR JOBS ON
THE ON THE GROUND SCORES. I'M
ALSO CALLING BECAUSE I WOULD
LIKE THAT TO REQUIRE THE
DEFENDANTS INCLUDE THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION APPROPRIATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
PROJECT OF THE RECRUITMENT OR
RETENTION AWFUL PARK WOULD BE
THROUGH THE COLLEGE OF
EDUCATION. WE ARE WE THINKING
ABOUT THIS CRUCIAL TOMORROW WE
CAN WE CAN WE COULD AGREE OFFER
GOING TO SOCIAL FORESIGHT WE
NEED TO INVEST IN THOSE FACULTY
MEMBERS BECAUSE WE ARE SHORT
PEABODY WERE APART SECTIONS ON
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC OPPOSITION
IT IS DEMANDING MORE I'M MORE
MULTILINGUAL PROGRAMS EVEN AFTER
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA THESE
WILL BE AVAILABLE WE NOT ONLY
FOR THE FOR THE CSU SYSTEM BUT
WITH DIFFICULTY WHAT'S IMPORTANT
OUR MISSION OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
FOURTEEN BE SURE NURSE ABOUT
WHERE MOST FOLKS ARE ABOUT THE
SAME TIME LANGUAGE WHICH
STUDENTS. SO I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT FUNDING
TO THE CSU SYSTEM AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THE PROCREATION IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BUDGET. FOR THE JUMP START
PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANKS TYLER AT ONE TWENTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS RYAN RISING I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS INITIATIVE OUT OF UC
SANTA BARBARA. I'M ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT THE FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST FOR UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS
BECAUSE THERE ARE OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS INCARCERATED
IN STATE PRISONS RIGHT NOW WE'RE
TAKING A NEW G. TRANSFERABLE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAM I WAS
ONCE ONE OF THOSE STUDENTS. AN
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS HELPED ME
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY AFTER MY
RELEASE THEY HELPED ME BE
UNIFIED WITH MY CHILDREN. THEY
GAVE ME MY FIRST JOB AS AN
AMBASSADOR. WITHOUT THE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS I WOULDN'T
HAVE MY CHILDREN WITH ME TODAY I
AM CURRENTLY IN UC SANTA
BARBARA'S FAMILY HOUSING AND I
HAVE MY CHILDREN WITH ME AND MY
WIFE AND THIS IS BEEN A LIFE
CHANGING EXPERIENCE FOR ME AND
MY FAMILY. AS I WAS STUCK IN
RECIDIVISM. SINCE THE AGE OF
TWELVE YEARS OLD. SO I AM ASKING
YOU. TO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM
THAT HE QUIT TO SUPPORT US AND
SUCCESSFULLY BEING ACCEPTED INTO
AND GRADUATING FROM THE UC
CAMPUS. YOU'VE ALREADY MADE THE
INVESTMENT OPERATING COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COURSES NOW WE'RE ASKING
FOR YOU TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO TAKE THE NEXT STEP AND
TRANSFER TO A UC CAMPUS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU. WELL TO
ALIGN THE ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TINA
CHICKEN AND THE TEACHER EDUCATOR
AT CAL POLY IN SAN LUIS OBISPO
I'D LIKE TO REQUEST THE SENATE
TO INCLUDE A TWENTY FIVE MILLION
APPROPRIATION THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY BUDGET INCREASED
STUDENT ENROLLMENT IN BILINGUAL
AUTHORIZATION PROGRAM TO THE
RECRUITMENT RETENTION OF FULL
TIME FACULTY LIKE MYSELF TO THE
COLLEGES OF EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA IS HAS BEEN DEALING
WITH A SYSTEMATIC REDUCTION OF
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS WITH
BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION WHICH IS
ONLY BEING MADE WORSE BY
INCREASING THE TEACHER SHORTAGE
IN BOTH GENERAL EDUCATION AND
ALSO IN BILINGUAL EDUCATION THE
CREATION OF THIS PROGRAM AND
FUNDING WILL MOVE OUR STATE IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION BY CREATING
MORE BILINGUAL EDUCATION
FACULTY. AND BETTER SERVE OUR
GROWING BILINGUAL AND
MULTILINGUAL STUDENT POPULATION
THE FUNDING WOULD BE A WIN FOR
THE CAL STATE A WIN FOR UP TO
TWELVE SCHOOL SYSTEMS AND OUR
FAMILIES BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY A
WIN FOR CALIFORNIA SIGNIFICANTLY
GROWING POPULATION OF BILINGUAL
AND MULTILINGUAL LEARNERS AS
WELL AS FAMILIES WHO WANT THIS
OPTION FOR THEIR CHILDREN. I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT FUNDING TO THE CSU
SYSTEM AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THAT BLACK. THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO LINE UP- ONE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GERMAN MORE PARKING AND
EVERYONE ON THE COMMITTEE MONEY
HE TALKED OPENLY AND I AM THE
UNDERGROUND COLLEGE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR AT UC SANTA CRUZ I'M
ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THE ONLY
DOLLAR REQUEST FOR UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS PROGRAM WORKS I AM ONLY
COURSE RECORD AFTER ELEVEN YEARS
OF INCARCERATION. I WENT TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. RIGHT AWAY
FROM SANTA CRUZ ON SCHOLARS I'M
CURRENTLY IN THE MASTER'S
PROGRAM AFFECT MENTAL STATE AND
I NOW HAVE THE PRIVILEGE. OF
SERVING OTHER UNDERGROUND SOLEMN
STUDENT. AT UC SANTA CRUZ WHAT
OTHER COUNCILLORS NONE OF IT
WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE- PARKER ONE
POINT ONE WANT TO EXPIRE. IN
EIGHT YEARS I WOULD HUMBLY ASK
YOU TO CONSIDER SUPPORTING A
REQUEST FOR. HOURS TO ENSURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
HOLISTIC. SUPPORTS ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU. NEXT LINE
ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. WHAT THAT TIME TO BUT I WOULD
ONLY GO INTO MISSILE SYSTEM
PROFESSOR BY LANGUAGE EACH AT
CAULFIELD AND- I'M CALLING TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT FUNDING FOR
THE JUMP START PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD HELP STRENGTHEN PATHWAYS
ARE BILINGUAL TEACHERS. AT THE
STATE WE HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION
TO UNDO THE HARM CAUSED A
PROPOSITION TO DO SEVEN IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT WHICH
WORKED TO DISMANTLE BILINGUAL
EDUCATION. ADVOCATES ARE NOW
WORKING TO STRENGTHEN SYSTEMS
WHICH WERE PREVIOUSLY WE CAN BUY
SUCH LEGISLATION BUT THE PASSING
OF PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT THERE
HAS BEEN A GROWTH CONTROL
LANGUAGE PROGRAMS AND HIGHER
DEMAND FOR BILINGUAL TEACHERS
HOWEVER AT THE STATE MEET THE
MARK THREE TWENTY BEST
STRENGTHENING AND REVITALIZING
BILINGUAL TEACHER PREP PROGRAM.
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENTING THE
LANGUAGE CORRECTLY THE CULPRIT
FOR TECHNOLOGIES SUCH AS THE
ENGLISHMAN ABOUT MADNESS AND
INVESTING AT THE PARK WE NEED
MORE FACULTY WITH TECHNOLOGY BY
LEGAL PEDAGOGY TO ENSURE THAT
THE NEXT GENERATION OF BILINGUAL
TEACHERS IF ADEQUATELY PREPARED
TO BRING SOMEONE WITH YOU YOU
NEED TO COVER STUDENT THINKING.
ARE YOU THE SUPPORT FUNDING FOR
THE CHIP PROGRAM THE FUTURE IS
MULTILINGUAL WE MUST EMBRACE
PERFECTLY WITH THAT AFTER MY
DEPARTING BILINGUAL. TEACHER
PREPARATION THANK YOU. NEXT WITH
A LINE ONE SEVEN FIVE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M NAME IS JENNIFER ON
HERE A UNDERGROUND SO THAT YOU
SCHEDULE DON'T I WOULD LIKE TO.
REQUEST FUNDING ROUND COLORED
INITIATIVE IN THE REQUEST TO
RECEIVE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AN
ONGOING FUNDING OUTLINED AND
EVERY WEEKEND BUDGET TO BETTER
SUPPORT FOR MY INCARCERATED IN
PRISON IN PAKISTAN AT THE SAME
LEVEL. AS A FOUR INCARCERATED
ALUMNI I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO HAVE THESE PROGRAMS ON
EACH CAMPUS. THERE ARE SPECIFIC
NEEDS THAT TO SOME IMPACTED
STUDENTS NEED TO HAVE A DRAFT
THAT ARE NOT ALREADY ESTABLISHED
AT THE STATE LEVEL- AS ALSO AS A
MENTOR FOR THE WRITING FOLDERS.
MENTORSHIP PROGRAM AT
SOUTHWESTERN COMMUNITY COLLEGE I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO
WANT TO APPLY TO THE UT SYSTEM
BUT CONTINUE TO HAVE THE SAME
SUPPORT THAT THEY DO AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL. SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR SUPPORT%
AND I- THANK YOU TO SUPPORT THE
UNDERGROUND COLORS AND THEIR
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR QUESTION.
THANK YOU. THIS TIME THERE'S NO
OTHERS IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WERE HERE YOU HEAR YOU
LOUD AND CLEAR AND WITH THAT WE
WILL ADJOURN THANK YOU.